foreign
hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on blockchain and
cryptocurrency full course for 2022.
blockchain is a groundbreaking
technology that enables anyone to track
transactions on a distributed digital
Ledger without a central Authority
the most notable byproduct of the
blockchain revolution is without a doubt
cryptocurrency
with some refer to as the trust machine
technology
in this video we will explore various
important aspects revolving around
blockchain and cryptocurrency and the
related Concepts in depth but before
diving deep into their Concepts we will
first explore the basics starting with
what is cryptocurrency and what is
blockchain
and then moving on to understanding the
origin and functionality of various
popular cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
ethereum Dogecoin Solana Shiba in a coin
nft
finance and ripple
followed by top crypto trading platforms
of 2022.
then we will make you understand how one
can become a blockchain developer
and what are its eligibility criteria
then we will take you through in-depth
concepts of blockchain like smart
contracts Mining hyperledger and crypto
wallets also we will show some real life
applications of blockchain and at the
end we will introduce you to some of
interview questions related to
blockchain and cryptocurrency to make
you base more stronger and boost
competence in you
by the end of this video I can assure
you that all your blockchain and
cryptocurrency related Concepts would
have been cleared
so for this training with me I have our
experience specialist Rahul together
we'll walk you through the different
crucial blockchain and cryptocurrency
Keynotes and Concepts
so let's start with an exciting video on
blockchain and cryptocurrency full
course of 2022. but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets Banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends Jack Ted
Sam and Phil meet up for dinner after
they're done Jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when Phil sends his share to Jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then Ted
and Sam send their respective shares to
Jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transactions cites
some issues at the bank that's when Jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
Authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like Litecoin ethereum
Z cash and so on one reign supreme
Bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have Phil Ted and
Sam Send Jack two Bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume Phil Ted and Sam
have three Bitcoins in reserve while
Jack has five first Phil sends two
Bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block This Record also
holds the number of Bitcoins each of the
friends own so after after Phil's
transaction Jack has seven Bitcoins
while Phil has won following this Sam
and Ted send two Bitcoins to jack a new
block is created for each of these
transactions these blocks hold the
transaction details as well as how many
Bitcoins Sam Ted and Jack have in
reserve these blocks are linked to each
other as each of them takes reference
from the previous one for the number of
Bitcoins each brand owns this chain of
Records or blocks is called a ledger and
this Ledger is shared among all the
friends which acts as a public
distributed Ledger this forms the basis
of blockchain so what happens when Phil
has only one Bitcoin left and he tries
to send two more Bitcoins to Jack the
transaction will not go through this is
because all his friends have copies of
The Ledger and it's clear that Phil has
only one Bitcoin left his friends will
flag this transaction as invalid a
hacker will not be able to alter the
data in the blockchain because each user
has a copy of The Ledger the data within
the blocks are encrypted by complex
algorithms all of this is made possible
with the help of blockchain Technology
blockchain can be described as a
collection of Records linked with each
other strongly resistant to alteration
and protected using cryptography now
let's have a closer look at the Bitcoin
transaction between Jack and Phil and
find out how it works every user in the
Bitcoin network has two keys a public
key and a private key the public key is
an address that everyone in the network
knows of like an email address of a user
the private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of Bitcoins he wants to send to
Jack along with his and Jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
incred scripted using encryption
algorithms and using Phil's unique
private key this is done to digitally
sign the transaction and to indicate
that the transactions came from fill
this output is now transmitted across
the world using Jack's public key with
this the message or transaction can be
decrypted only by Jack's private key
which only Jack has knowledge of
different cryptocurrencies use different
hashing algorithms while Bitcoin uses
the sha-256 algorithm ethereum which is
also a famous cryptocurrency uses one
known as ethash this transaction and
several other similar ones are taking
place all around the world these
transactions are validated and then
added block by block the people who
validate these blocks are called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem The Miner
who solves this first adds the block to
the block chain and is rewarded with
12.5 Bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining with this Phil and Jack's wallets
are updated just like every person in
the network who has completed a
transaction now that you know about
blockchain and its important Concepts
time for a small quiz what is the
concept of blockchain that ensures data
cannot be altered by any of the users
within the network a public distributed
Ledger B proof of work
C proof of stake D hash encryption let
us know what you think is the right
answer in the comments below three lucky
winners will get Amazon gift vouchers
details are mentioned in the description
below let's have a look at how Walmart
uses blockchain to provide its customers
with better service Walmart was facing
problems in delivering quality products
to its customers they were facing a high
return rate and large amounts of refunds
due to their products bad quality they
were unable to determine the point of
failure in the supply chain which
started from Farm to storage to
transportation to processing all the way
to the customer then Walmart adopted
blockchain technology with blockchain
the quality of the goods at each step
was permanently inscribed within a block
for example when a customer Flags a
product as damaged it can be correctly
identified where the product got damaged
in the entire supply chain thus helping
Walmart to identify by the problem areas
and fixing them and this is just one of
several ways blockchain is used in Real
Life Application hello everyone welcome
to Simply learns YouTube channel my name
is raneem Rashid and I'm a blockchain
trainer at simply learn and we do
provide trainings uh in terms of
blockchain development and application
and architecture before starting your
today's session just please make sure
that you subscribe and hit the like
button for the video so that you don't
miss any update from us so today's topic
that we will be discussing is about how
do you become a blockchain developer and
it's one of the most frequently asked
questions that I have encountered as
well for most of the people coming from
different backgrounds it's not only from
only technical uh for only people from
coming from technical side but also
someone from a very different industry
and they are quite interested in joining
uh the blockchain domain in terms of how
they can build something that can change
the whole game aim of how we do the
transactions and these things so um we
are going to discuss a little bit about
um what could be the kind of steps or
what could be the ways that you can be a
blockchain developer and before going
into the uh discussion of what are the
ways for that first we must need to
understand who is a blockchain developer
itself because there are quite different
terms that being used like some of you
maybe have heard about smart contract
engineer or blockchain engineer or our
blockchain developer so these are
different terms that's being used
interchangeably so along with it you
must need to know the the main
understanding and the terms are being
used and what is the meaning of being a
blockchain developer so moving forward
we are going to discuss a kind of what
could be a type of blockchain developers
on which side you can focus and then you
are going to explore some of the steps
that how you can become and how you can
be planning your journey to become a
blockchain and developer as your career
so we are we'll be moving forward in in
terms of also just exploring a little
bit about the market there was the
salary range that's being provided and a
kind of you can say obstacles uh that is
for someone who wants to learn
blockchain development or who wants to
learn this technology so this is a kind
of our whole agenda that what we will be
discussing in our today's uh session so
first of all uh let me first move
forward with the kind of questions that
who is a blockchain developer so
initially what I would say whenever you
want to achieve something or you
whenever you you plan to get yourself
into as a part of your career as a part
of your next role first of all you
shouldn't understand some of the
questions and you should ask yourself a
few questions who what and why you want
to be uh to be that position so uh
that's very important first of all you
do try AI to understand who you want to
be like who who is a blockchain
developer who is a kind of position that
you are looking for then what are the
ways to become that specific
professional in the market and then why
also you should know that why you are
looking forward to be yourself be a part
of this industry or be a part of this
domain that's quite very important
questions that you should ask yourself
uh not going to answer anyone but ask
yourself and satisfy yourself with these
answers the reason is that that is going
to compose your whole goal or whole
motivation for the uh for your whole
career journey in the terms let's say if
you know that why you are planning to be
a blockchain developer what is your
reason to be in this industry what is
your main motivation you will be stayed
on the whole track and you can plan
these things in a real way or you can
say in a kind of you will have some
timeline that you wanted to achieve that
you wanted to be in this domain so make
sure that you do ask these three
questions before getting into any XYZ
technology it's not just related to
blockchain it's a general kind of three
questions that I usually uh make sure
that I am clear enough why I'm going
into this direction so that's just my
personal opinion or a kind of my
personal uh belief that I should know
that okay why I wanted to be there and
what could be the ways and who I am
going to be so as a part of this whole
series we are first going to explore a
questions that is who is a blockchain
developer so starting from if you are
just discussing about a blockchain
developer uh it is presumed for sure
that you are well versed with the
technology itself or with the the
working of this technology why it exists
why it came into the picture what is
this buzzword everywhere and why this is
booming a lot so as a whole it's being
assumed that you should know what is the
blockchain technology so if you talk
about the technology itself the core
functionality or you can say the core
features of it you are well aware of it
so implementing and designing that whole
blockchain network is something that a
blockchain developer do as well like how
you design a whole network how you
implement and support a network also and
then coming towards creates and
optimizes blockchain protocols and the
very last thing that you go with is how
you develop dapps and smart contract
applications on the blockchain network
that's very important to understand
those terms if we talk about
the dapps DAP is a kind of like
distributed applications that we use
these terms quite often when it comes to
blockchain developer you may have heard
from someone like okay I'm looking for a
Dap developer someone who can develop
adapt for me it's something like we are
talking about applications that needs to
be developed on the top of blockchain
technology and it could be any
blockchain like public or private any
blockchain so that is very important if
you understand these kind of acronyms
and you really know the meanings of
these acronyms that's also very uh
that's something that matters a lot so
dapps is something that you are going to
have those applications built on top of
blockchain and that's one of the part
that blockchain developer do also and
then come towards the next part that how
do you develop these daphs using like
writing some smart contracts using any
programming languages that we'll be
exploring in the in the few slides
afterwards so coming towards like how
you write a smartphone contracts what
are those kind of programming languages
that is needed for you to know and to uh
to be well versed with this so you know
the uh how you're going to make it
technically feasible for your whole
career and and to get your next role so
coming towards
um what could be the type of blockchain
developer you can be because what we
will discuss is a quite a lot of
different things if you notice the very
first part that I mentioned was that how
you can like designing the network
implementing uh and architecting the
solution that's one part of it then we
talked about another aspect of how you
can like um security and optimizing the
whole
um Gap development and then writing the
smart contracts and developing the
applications itself so if it if you
focus on the sides it's being divided
into two kind of two sections one is a
core blockchain developer who actually
works into the underlying buying
blockchain architecture or you can say
working on the consensus algorithm that
how these things going to be working so
that comes under the core blockchain
developer and then another part that's
important is the blockchain software
development or you can say the app adapt
developer who is going to develop the
application that's being used or that's
being built on top of that blockchain
technology so if we talk about the whole
blockchain development cycle or you can
say the layers is you have one
blockchain hosted on which you are going
to develop your blockchain application
so first you should be clear enough what
kind of blockchain that you are going to
adopt it could be a public blockchain it
could be a private blockchain or maybe a
kind of hybrid somewhere Consortium or
hybrid blockchain and then coming
towards finding the right talent for the
type of blockchain that you are working
on then that's the next part of uh where
software developers or where you can say
developers in journal lies into so
that's the next part of blockchain
developer is that how you are going to
write the smart contracts or kind of
chain codes and how you're going to make
make those applications work on top of
blockchain so when we talk about first
thing that is core blockchain developer
they are the one who are going to work
on the core features of the blockchain
network itself so if you focus on the on
the category of the blockchain that you
will be selecting let's say if you are
going to go for the public blockchain
for ethereum or archive any application
that you wanted to host in public
blockchain so that's a kind of different
thing you know your consensus you know
everything that's already running into
the network but when it comes to a
private or enterprise-based blockchain
you have a quite different architecture
it's quite bulky it's quite vast like
you have to work around what kind of
network you wanted to build into how
many organizations will going to
participate into the network what will
be the consensus mechanisms that will be
used then how you're going to set up
like let's say if you're talking about
hyper laser fabric you have to architect
the whole thing like participation of
endorsing nodes and Cas and let's say
how it's a whole MSP is going to work
and then the consensus mechanism and how
it is going to be committed to The
Ledger after going through this whole
endorsement policy so there is quite a
lot of network part that needs to be
done in terms of private or our
enterprise-based blockchain which is not
that much required when it comes to any
public blockchain so that whole
blockchain developed for are the one who
is responsible for working on those side
of how these network is going to be
built into so if you just explore a
little bit about hyperledger fabric
Network Administration that's something
a separate role that's being required
for the organizations who develop on top
of hyperledger fabric it's not that they
expect the programmers to do the whole
networking you know who architecting at
the base layer but they expect the the
net the network part is something that
they expect someone else who are
expertise who have the required
expertise in that aspect so that where
is the core blockchain developer come
into like when you talk about
architecture or working on this
consensus algorithm and how you're going
to set up the whole blockchain network
that is one part
of the blockchain developer that you can
be now the next part that when it comes
to software development side this is
where the programming comes like how you
are going to develop your application
that is going to work on on the top of
that specific blockchain let's say if I
decided that I wanted to build uh an
application that is going to be on
hosted onto a public blockchain so it's
a public blockchain application so I
want adapt for that like I want to build
an application so definitely you don't
need to work on to that underlying core
blockchain layer setting up the network
and these kind of stuff what we usually
do is that we directly go towards
writing our smart contract logic once we
understand the whole architecture whole
flow of our solution that okay what kind
of smart contracts we are needed at what
stage we are needing that smart contract
act and what is the whole flow of
information from one end to another end
and who are the participating entities
and all these stuff
once you have a very clear idea of that
you go into developing those
applications in terms of writing your
core code core program into the core
programming side then it comes to
writing your smart contracts and first
you are going to use a test Network
let's say so you're going to host it on
a kind of like test Network for ethereum
or then you are going to move into a
main net so that's the kind of things
that mostly on the side of blockchain
developer that how you are going to
write your code compile it and deploy it
itself onto the blockchain network so
coming towards that what kind of
responsibilities and the usual and the
major responsibilities that needs to be
covered by a blockchain software
developer is smart contracts writing
their smart contracts or you are
required to develop the whole
distributed applications so the reason
of mentioning this develops the
distributed application is that just
writing the smart contracts is not
something you do only you should know
that about when what what will happen
when you are going to deploy your
network and how you're going to check up
all these gas fees and a lot of stuff
that happened there once you deploy your
smart contract onto the blockchain
network so that's where this blockchain
software development come into and then
the
location so we have a kind of some
middleware
um apis on which we work let's say if we
are talking about uh specifically
ethereum based development we use a
web3.js to interact with our smart
contract and to talk to our front end
also so that is the library that you are
expected to uh write the code and know
that how you are going to interact with
these two layers and act as a middleware
and how you're going to write that
specific kind of HTML code which will
link to your smart contracts easily and
the same thing that follows if you're
talking about any other blockchain let's
say in terms of private blockchain so in
hybridledger fabric when we are
developing an application for that
middle layer specifically we have
different kind of sdks that we use
that's been provided let's say by a
fabric SDK so you you you are bound to
be used like kind of java SDK or node
SDK or any kind of new sdks that being
provided to them let's say part thing is
python is in um in line as well with
them so these are a lot of things that
also involve that how your middleware
will work to talk to a front end for
your blockchain based application that
also comes under under the blockchain
development or kind of how you're going
to work as a software developer or
um or the core technical team for your
blockchain development side
so coming towards that how do you become
a blockchain developer now that's not a
question is that I am going to give you
a rigid answers on that and that's
something that you should follow but I
believe that as I started in the earlier
um part of our video that you should
know uh answers of these questions by
yourself how you're gonna do that or
what you want it to be and who you want
it to be and what are the ways to be at
this stage so when it comes to how do
you become a blockchain developer so
there are a few things that's being
mentioned here it's it's a few things
I'm mentioning because it could be more
than that it definitely depends on the
type of role that you are looking into
or on the type of organization that you
are planning to uh planning to like join
in or targeting to be uh the next
employer for them so it's quite uh you
can say uh quite varied options that how
do you become a blockchain developer but
that's one of the you can say core
answers that's everywhere if you found
uh the ways of being a blockchain
developer the very first part that's
very important is the programming
language because as we discussed
the part of being a software developer
is that you should know a kind of
programming language of writing the code
into the blockchain uh in into this
blockchain whole network so some of the
programming languages that's being
mentioned here it's like Java C plus
plus JavaScript go Python and c-sharp so
as a whole I would say that is very
important for being a blockchain
developer is
you should be well versed about the
basic programming paradigms and
how a whole object-oriented programming
work like the base propellers of object
oriented programming the reason is
that's something quite similar when it
comes to
um those programming languages so if you
talk about any of those programming
languages it's not something that you
are expected to know all of them
definitely no one is not uh expert in
all of these programming language but if
you are well versed with any one of them
let's say any two of them you are
expected to write your code or
understand the main uh main you can say
um main rules of writing any programming
language because you are already well
versed with anyone of or any any two of
them that's very important part that
this is the core of a programming
language that you should know now how it
works into writing a blockchain based
development it's something that you are
going to learn when it comes to any kind
of blockchain development course or any
kind of session that you will be joining
so that's something that you will be
learning as an advanced uh aspect of it
but the base if you know you are that
that's going to help you a lot in in
terms of your next Journey for the
blockchain development so coming towards
uh the side of writing programming
language or the side of software
development on top of any a blockchain
application there is also one
programming language that started with
the smart contract so with the with the
existence of ethereum it's solidity
so solidity developers are something
that they are exclusively expert in
writing this validity uh code or
solidity smart contracts that is being
said because solidity itself is a
contract oriented language okay
but if you just get yourself into or if
you just uh if you just go through a
little bit of how it works or
um a journal view of it you will notice
a lot of thing that is very common and a
lot of Concepts that is very related to
object oriented programming like if you
talk about how you create a class in
object-oriented programming language so
that is the same thing that we follow
like how you create a contract in
objective in in solidity itself then we
have few of the uh few of the concepts
that's very much similar to it we have
inheritance in contracts we have
abstract classes interfaces then we have
a kind of aspect that how you
encapsulate things like the
encapsulation aspect of it so a lot of
things how you use a Constructor also so
there are a lot of common things that is
uh very much similar to what we already
know in object oriented programming
language so for those of you who are a
kind of confident or kind of comfortable
with any of the programming language
that we just discussed you will be able
to understand solidity very much easily
one of the different thing that you will
find in solidity is that
how you are going to play around with
with a kind of wallet with a kind of
addresses how it is maintaining
um connecting to a wallet or maintaining
an address like say smart contract
address itself and then how it's going
to hold some ethers so there are a lot
of uh things or some of the terms or
keywords that is different when it comes
to solidity
and obviously it is expected to be
because that is something that makes it
unique
so these are the things that is
different when it comes to solidity
based programming language so if you are
comfortable enough in writing solidity
based code or you can say uh you are
well versed with any of the programming
languages that is in uh oop that's
object oriented programming you will Ace
the solidity side very easily so you can
Smart Start understanding the concepts
and writing those
um contracts and kind of remix IDE that
is a browser-based tool you don't need
to install anything and you can just
start compiling and trying out your
first smart contract very easily by just
installing a kind of like metamask
wallet or something
so there is a very core part of uh
blockchain development side first is the
programming language and then the very
next part that I told you already that
is fundamentals of object-oriented
programming language so we know that how
this is related to a blockchain based
development that how you write a kind of
functions how you get the details for
your users and how you use some
functions to send and receive payments
and let's say how you create a abstract
contract or there's a kind of how you
write some interfaces for your contract
so some very of the concepts that we
already know in object oriented
programming language it's quite you can
say similar to what we have in solidity
then we have a kind of flat and relation
databases or you can say that uh to
understand the main concept that how
that rdbms work or the flat databases
work in terms of if you know this kind
of file storage or data storage you will
be easily
understanding that how we are talking
about the importance of blockchain
technology itself and how important this
technology itself the reason is that if
you talk about blockchain based
technology as a whole it's just a kind
of uh data structure or you could say a
technology which works on storing of
data that how do you store data and then
the architecture or the flow of storing
the data that is how it makes it
different that how you're going to store
it like either it's in a distributed
Network either it's in a kind of um you
have a ledger that is decentralized
there is no Central Authority so these
are some of the things if you understand
uh the the main concept of flat relation
database you will be easily
understanding these kind of things about
data structures and how it's being
storing this data in terms of um in
terms of blockchain and how it is unique
to any other
databases or any other data structures
also
so one of the major things also that's
written here is that you have to have
some understanding about data structures
like let's say Stacks LinkedIn list
queues so these are some of the um data
structures that we do we have so if you
understand some of them that's very
important that it is linked to
blockchain in the way that blockchain
itself is also a chain of blocks that is
linked together like it's a kind of
linked list and every block is
containing the patch of previous block
so it is changed together so kind of it
is linked together so it is it works in
the same way that we have linked list so
that's one of the reason if you
understand those data structures the the
way how blockchain works at its core of
a data structure it's going to be very
easy for you and you will be able to
understand that how this Works in a kind
of data structure perspective
and then about some of the knowledge of
web development web app development so
that's very um common thing that when
you talk about any kind of development
side so if you know that how
um web and mobile application works and
how you create these applications and
apart from it because the concepts that
let's say if you create a mobile
applications and you have some you want
to expose some apis to get data onto a
mobile application that's something very
much same that we we do in in blockchain
development also so these are some of
the concepts that you are being expected
to know when it comes to becoming a
blockchain development so the very last
part of this um the these points that
how do you become a blockchain developer
is the peer-to-peer networking that's
something that I already mentioned in
the type of how you understand the core
concept of blockchain technology in
terms of storing the data and then it
comes to the networking side it's really
important like let's say
those of you who are coming from let's
say
um a very old and very um basics of
computer science you must have heard
about a client server architecture so
what client server architecture do we
have a server to which all the clients
report to for any of the requests for
any of the things whatever being
accepted or whatever being provided by
the server those lines receive and work
on it and and they will be able to
perform uh next steps on it so client
server architecture architecture is
something that is centralized like we
don't have any relation with one client
to another client but all of those
clients are linked to one server or
let's say more than one server but those
servers are the one who is controlling
and who are the managing Authority
but when it comes to a blockchain based
system we don't have that aspect of
centralization
it is a code decentralized Network
that's being also said as peer-to-peer
networking why because all the peers
talk to each other and can see the
transactions whatever others are seeing
also so that's the core part of
blockchain development side if you
understand those terms if you understand
that how these things work that is one
of the major thing and then we we talk
about some of the acronyms that's very
important like let's say that is peer to
P2P and one of the things that I
mentioned earlier is daps related to
distributed applications that's also
very important and very last third uh
acronym that I wanted to mention is DLT
so what is DLT DLT is a distributed
Ledger technology so if you talk about a
blockchain based uh blockchain based
technology or
you are trying to understand this
technology as a whole
you are expected to know that okay what
is DLT itself because it is a very
important questions most of the uh most
of those who are just newly entered into
this field they know the code they know
the very advanced level of blockchain
but they are not well versed with this
term that said as DLT it is a very
important term if you just focus on in
this term is it's an umbrella term like
we have a lot of different Technologies
under DLT
and one of them is blockchain technology
so blockchain is a DLT okay but we have
other technologies that comes under a
DLT as well let's say we have hashgraph
we have
um directed acyclic graph that is the AG
then we have
um let's say we have another
technologies that we work into we have
hedera hashgraph and blockchain and many
of those technologies that comes under
DLT it's very important to understand
that the core of DLT is The Ledger is
distributed like it's going to work in a
decentralized way in a peer-to-peer
manner but how it's going to store the
data like the storage of the data it's
different not all of those Technologies
store the data in blocks so it's not all
dlts are blockchain but at its core the
blockchain is a dld itself so that's a
very Broad and umbrella term that you
should know as a as being a potential
blockchain developer make sure that you
are clear enough about these terms and
you are well versed about where and why
you are using these terms
so these are some of the prerequisites
that we discussed that okay how you want
it to be how you do becoming a
blockchain developer uh what is a
blockchain developer itself I believe at
this stage of this session you are clear
enough about two of this
what you want it to be like what is a
who is a blockchain developer so who is
what you wanted to be like what's what
could be your next role and then how do
you become a blockchain developer so
these are as a whole it's just a core
steps and then you can extend your
research you can extend your plan and
make your uh you can say whole journey
that how you wanted to reach a specific
goal in terms of becoming a blockchain
developer and getting yourself into this
uh whole ecosystem
so let's move into the very next step
that's that says the very first step if
we have got all our prerequisites that's
clear we know what we want it to be uh
we know how we are going to be at this
stage so the very first step if you
notice of of this whole system is the
first thing that you understand the
basics of blockchain
so to whoever usually asked me this
question I would say that as a whole
that's very important to to you to
understand and to go backwards to the
point where this technology started
so for the blockchain if we talk about
the very first white paper or you can
say uh one of the white paper that that
started gaining the traction for this
blockchain based technology is Bitcoin
so what you do you go towards this uh
Bitcoin white paper and try to read it
and try to grasp the whole concept
what's being written and why it came to
an existence and how this technology
played an important role in the whole uh
in this whole system that's being
proposed in that white paper
and that stage I wouldn't expect you to
be a master of blockchain technology and
even to be clear of all the terms that's
written there
but after reading that specific white
paper you should be just clear enough
what is this technology what is the
potential of this technology and either
I am interested or not like let's say
either I am convinced with what this
technology has done uh to this whole
payments ecosystem and everything so if
you are little bit clear enough at this
side you are very good to proceed
further and then what you do you proceed
further with about understanding the
core terms or core concept of blockchain
technology let's say we have uh
different types of blockchains public
blockchain private blockchain then we
have hybrid blockchain so coming towards
understanding the terms if you
understand the base term of blockchain
then you move forward with let's say
public blockchain that is Bitcoin and
after going towards Bitcoin you go and
check in the history the next step in
the next Revolution came into the terms
of ethereum how ethereum came into what
was the reason for that and how it
changed the whole game of this
blockchain ecosystem so there you are
going to explore a lot of thing in terms
of this blockchain based technology the
reason of that is that with ethereum
ecosystem
we had a lot of things that came into
the picture which was not there earlier
we got the way that how you can automate
your business process in terms of those
smart contracts and then using that
smart contracts the scope of this
blockchain technology extended and it is
being explored that you can use this
technology out of this payment ecosystem
or out of this financial services we
have a lot of uh you can say potential
of using it in different ways or you can
say in different use cases so there come
the the potential and the power of this
this technology
and if you explore a little bit of the
whole journey of ethereum you are going
to uh find a lot of things that's very
interesting the tokenization aspect of
it
um the mining process that how it
changed up to the latest Trend that we
have in now in 2022 so that's very
important part of the whole journey of
of learning these core of this
blockchain based technology and then
come to coming towards the the base
let's say hash uh that how this
cryptographic hash is used how the
system is secured what kind of
encryption that's being used so you can
go through and play around with some of
the you can say demos and illustrations
that's been provided using the how your
data is encrypted how you cannot change
a block and it will break the chain so a
lot of things that you can explore in at
this step and you you know okay there is
some mining that's being provided some
consensus that's happening and the
reason of that consensus also and the
next part of knowing after knowing those
kind of terms is that how you explore
these things let's say ethereum
hyperledger hashgraph or Coda artery
Coda that's very important as well and
other solutions that is built on top of
layer one Solutions that's let's say we
have layered a lot of layer 2 Solutions
into the market now but that's another
very extended form of blockchain
so as a base what we do is that you
explore
um starting with Bitcoin white paper
then you move toward ethereum based
blockchain and then you go and explore a
little bit of hyperledger fabric and if
you are at the stage of understanding
hyperledger fabric you can look up into
the R3 Corner as well so a lot of things
you are going to explore in this whole
journey and you will going to understand
the basics of this blockchain itself so
if you talk about this whole steps that
we have in this whole system in this
whole systematic way
it is started from prerequisite if you
are done with prerequisites we are now
move towards step one that we have
already done that says the concepts of
blockchain and the very next stage is
that you understand economics behind
cryptocurrencies and blockchain-based
technology so that's the part that is
very important you understand the whole
um whole economics in the term of the
usage of blockchain uh blockchain
Technologies in in crypto world and a
lot of it on the side of how it works in
terms of issuing some kind of tokens and
then we have token standards how you
write these tokens and the important and
the and you can say
um how it it the price is how you're
going to increase your price for tokens
and then we have the next era that we we
know that right now we just passes this
nfts that how nfts came into the market
and what is the best use case of it so a
lot of things you are going to explore
or in terms of security
that says hashing that is a kind of
hashing algorithm that's being used and
the digital signatures knowing that how
this core this works as a core and then
the consensus mechanism Also let's say
proof of proof of stake why it's being
used or why there is some transaction
that transaction that being happened
from proof of work to proof of stake
knowing the benefits and disadvantages
for each of them it's very important
also
so that's one of the things that needed
to be uh on the side of
you can say more onto the side of
security or more to the side of
technical aspect of blockchain the other
part is that the economic side
on the economic side we have the
understanding that the miners or you can
say the validators who validate the
transaction are being incentivized so it
is very important for you to understand
that how you are going to be like what's
is there some calculation that's been
happening it's something some halving is
done and after that what's going to
happen if it's finished uh the block
reward is finished so what's going to
happen with Bitcoin so that's some of
the questions that if you explore that's
going to have some
um you can say
some interesting facts that you will
need to explore in this whole journey
along with it it's very important that
you try to understand about private
blockchain also if you are exploring it
try to go into going to as a whole not
just go through towards public
blockchain and you don't know the
difference between private and public so
if you're talking about private
blockchain you should try to explore a
little bit what happens with the
validators who validate the transaction
in a private blockchain so who is being
rewarded what kind of reward is being
given so you can read out some of the
use cases or some of the success stories
and case studies that's been published
to let's say onto the
um official website of hyperledger
fabric or Linux Foundation or official
website of ethereum
ethereum foundation itself so a lot of
things that you are going to find out on
their own official website and for for
further you can say latest up-to-date
Trends and happenings into the industry
you can watch out to some of the videos
let's say and videos and terms that
what's been happening and what's being
announced by their like say co-founders
Founders or any of the speakers who
participated into the conference because
that's also very one of the interesting
part of the conferences if you join that
or if you follow some of the blockchain
latest conferences some of the very
um biggest uh you can say announcements
or biggest
um change that's been happening into the
ecosystem they announce usually there
into the conferences also so you can
follow up to the conference to
understand and to you can say follow the
trends what's happening into the
industry as well so the very next step
that is how uh to understand how
cryptocurrencies work that is also very
important the reason is that when it
comes to
the blockchain based ecosystem it
started with the very first use case is
the financial use case is how you can
eliminate a middleman and do some
transaction peer-to-peer let's say Alice
and Bob they don't need anyone in
between and they can do the transactions
without any one of them so that's very
much important to know that if we are
removing the middleman
who is going to do our transaction then
definitely we do have at the core we
have this blockchain based system let's
say blockchain Bitcoin who is going to
do this transaction for us and if you if
you just go backward in terms of the
middleman we are going to have some
validator a miner who is going to mind
the Mind our transaction but things are
a lot of things that are changed when it
comes to peer-to-peer transaction uh
when it compared to the transitional and
a current system of current banking
system or financial system that we have
so that's very important to understand
how this cryptocurrency system work
if you send the money from one account
to another account let's say in terms of
ethers or not only in ethers if you are
trying to do some transactions and you
are having let's say some tokens or
something then you will be able to
um do this transaction very quickly and
you will be able to understand it very
quickly how this thing is very different
to the traditional system that we have
so that is also one of the very
important step of this uh four steps or
five steps Journey so you start with the
concepts of blockchain based technology
and then you understand the economics
behind it in which you explore the kind
of like security aspect of it the
cryptographic algorithms that's being
used and who will be rewarded and how
the reward will be done and then how you
under then you understand with how this
cryptocurrencies work and the last thing
is that you're getting on some hands-on
experience
and then when it comes to now at this
stage at the fourth stage I believe you
have a clear idea about the technology
you know the strongest strong use case
of this whole technology so far that we
have
you are well versed with the technical
terms that is being used in this whole
uh you can say in this whole technology
or what kind of consensus or encryption
or encryption algorithms or mining why
it's being happening and and the whole
flow okay and if you are clear enough at
this stage you are now able to getting
yourself onto some Hands-On or into some
coding aspect of it so for this kind of
writing some uh programming and some
smart contract you are now able to start
your journey as a blockchain developer
so this stage is very important for a
kind of how you are going to select what
kind of programming languages that you
want to be like what kind of uh
blockchain development you want to be
let's say it's private blockchain public
blockchain and then you will decide that
okay I want to write a smart contract or
I want to write a let's chain code in
hyperledger fabric that's also uh the
choice that you made initially and then
you write your smart contract and you
know that okay if let's say you are
writing it on ethereum based blockchain
you are going to publish it on ethereum
based uh Network so let's say in in
terms of test Network or in terms of
mainnet you can publish it on on the
ethereum based blockchain and then let's
say one of the major thing that's
written into the whole journey what I
appreciate it's not that you do the work
from your end and you expect the things
to happen like magically from from the
employer and or from the end of hiring
you
what is the best way is that if you make
something if you have coded something
even it's a very small application
try to
show off to it to others that what you
have made by showing off means that you
can convince other that you have the
right talent that is required for this
specific programming language
it could be in any way like it could be
like either you go for having your own
GitHub profile maintain your own GitHub
um whole GitHub portfolio that you can
provide to others so that's the kind of
all your programs they're written you
have all your files that that you can
provide to others just to know that okay
what kind of smart contracts that you
can write
but also you can write some articles out
of it let's say if you are writing a
code in solidity programming language
and you came up with an issue of how
you're going to like you explored some
different ways of error handling like
you have different functions in in
solidity right for error handling and
from your own experience you find out
some amazing way of doing error handling
and solidity that saves some gas fees
and you believe that's a a better
solution out of what you have been
already being provided over the internet
what you can do you can write a complete
whole article on it on the basis of okay
this is my personal finding in my whole
journey I found out this is the best way
and I I I encountered these issues and
to resolve this kind of problems I tried
fixing it in this this way I wrote this
code and that's how it worked
so what will happen others will know
your problem solving skills
your skills of writing a good and solid
smart contract that's very important
so never underestimate the line of code
that you have written or the application
that you have created it might be very
small for you it might be something
that's not convincing for you but for
other or let's say to others that who
are looking up to uh as a as a a
candidate for you as a candidate to to
you maybe
it's going to be something that's very
big for them so try posting whatever you
have learned whatever you have made you
can also do some participation in
hackathons let's say you you can
participate and team up with others and
create some uh very you can say
convincing and solid application in a
hackathon that's also going to add on a
lot in your portfolio and that also uh
it's very valuable when it comes to
being this whole blockchain development
Journey so it's not something that I
would say only in in blockchain uh
developing Journey but for any of the
development side it's very important
that until you create something you are
not going to learn it in that way
so try getting your hands dirty as early
as you can and then once you are in this
stage that you created a solid
application you can just go and and post
it somewhere and create and maintain
your own portfolio so that you will be
able to portray to others what you have
made okay
and then that is very important again I
would say the whole blockchain ecosystem
or this whole blockchain-based
technology it's evolving very fast so
the developments or the happenings in
this industry it's very quick that you
don't know that when what will happen
so the very important part is that you
keep yourself updated with whatever
being happening it's not about just
keeping yourself updated let's say who
adopted uh hyperledger fabric for their
problem or who which bank adopted R3
core die and they are working on a
solution with partnering with let's say
Swift is now working with blockchain
based technology it's just the high
level that you should know
but at the core you should be knowing
what's happening inside of this
blockchain industry itself
one of the very common and latest
trending news that we had in the in the
past few weeks is the merch that
happened in ethereum from proof of work
to proof of stake and how they merge
this whole layers in the ethereum
ecosystem
so the reason of understanding and
keeping an eye and keeping yourself
updated is that
this technology is evolving very fast
and even the solutions and the startups
that's being built into it it's quite uh
you can say
quite quite you you cannot expect
anything to happen maybe into the next
few weeks but there is some very uh
amazing happenings or amazing startups
that's being built upon on top of let's
say any Financial ecosystem or or for
any any industry so try to keep yourself
updated and how you do that so it's up
to you you can follow some of the latest
trending articles that's uh that's
publishing some news on blockchain or
you can also
um just find out some of the solid
connections on LinkedIn and get uh get
connected with them follow them in
Twitter so that you know the latest news
what's happening there and that's one of
the reason that's important that you
visit and write some articles visit the
blogs as well and be a part of this
ecosystem
always make sure to put your input to
add your input wherever you feel you can
let's say if today after uh today you
know that okay I wanted to be a
blockchain developer and you are looking
for some of the Articles and you have a
quick thought that okay no this is how
it should be no I believe that this
ecosystem is is like growing so
scalability something that's very
important or something you can't put
whatever you know and whatever your
thoughts into a comment don't ever feel
shy because that's how you are becoming
to a part of this whole ecosystem
now the very important part is what we
will be discussing next because how you
become a blockchain developer we
discussed it and then comes to what kind
of obstacles do you face when it comes
to learning blockchain based technology
so coming towards the part is that how
difficult or easy this programming
language is something that's related to
what kind of issues you face okay so
first of all that's very common and I
believe it's uh most of us face this
issue that the outdated content
let's see if you are working on solidity
based uh programming language and if you
are reading and following an article but
it was written for a very old version of
solidity a compiler version but you have
followed the whole exact program and
your program is not working on that
latest version because maybe something
has changed and they've made it work in
in another way for the latest version
so this is very important the content
that you are following must be
latest it's not a very old content that
you are following or it's not something
that that you can say uh already
outdated okay so that's very one of the
obstacles that we would say into the
solidity or into the blockchain based
journey is that the tutorials you follow
or the content that's being written
there may be the issue is being resolved
already but you are following some
content some tutorial that's very old
and one of the second aspect is very
common again is the lack of quality
content okay so the major thing is that
most of the places where you will see
that okay you will be a blockchain
developer in six weeks in two weeks you
will be a smart uh in four hours videos
a lot of videos that you will be able to
see that it's not that they will not
give you the right content they will
definitely give you but the quality
content is very important and also
after getting this content what you do
afterwards is also very important
so the investment from your side as a
learner or as a as a potential developer
in this field is still there don't just
expect things to happen in a magic way
once you follow a tutorial and you
believe that okay I created this
application now I am a master and I look
forward to the opportunities and I
believe I will be getting hired
somewhere hopefully you will be
definitely but how you can make your
place in the industry is that you try to
create something and then
make some updations on it let's say now
we have a lot of layer 2 Solutions also
so try to explore many of those
um
Solutions or many of those uh you can
see some of the sdks doesn't that's into
the system or some of the tools that uh
that's now just came into the in this
whole blockchain based development side
so that's also very important for you to
learn from a quality content not from
old content
now that's another very uh you can say
one of the very uh attractive part of
blockchain based development is the
salary of a blockchain developer so
coming towards the average uh how much a
blockchain developer earns is something
around
um if you talk about in in USD it's
different definitely so it it starts
from 100K per annum okay it's just a
starting I wouldn't say it's it's an
average but it's more of a start but it
definitely depends upon the size of
company that where you are looking for
and where you are aiming to let's say
for a startup it's going to be a
different or a kind of a big
organization is going to offer you a
different rate
but when it comes to uh blockchain based
uh development to any other
um core Tech development let's say
dotnet or c-sharp or even just Java as
well we have a slight difference in the
range that of the salary that's being
provided so the blockchain based
developer or blockchain developer is
usually highly paid
and one of the core reason is not that
the program the technology is booming
only
but also
the supply and demanding
when you talk about the blockchain
ecosystem or blockchain based Developers
the supply itself is like very small and
the demand it's like very huge so if we
talk about the demand the demand
outgrows the supply a lot
so demand is growing very rapidly but
the supply of the development or the
supply of the developers is not very
high that's why it's one of the highest
paid when it comes to any of those uh
development side of um into this whole
software development side so which
companies and how companies are using
blocks blockchain based technology again
that's a very common thing that's IBM
Microsoft and they are using in a
different way let's say for trade
finances and we have some countries that
they are using let's say Australia and
Estonia is very famous you can explore a
little bit about estonia's case study
how they have revolutionized their Whole
Health ecosystem the the smart card that
they have for the for the for their uh
citizens or for the residents and then
we have a lot of things that's also
evolved in Dubai also with the respond
Dubai initiative they have a gone
paperless uh within a shade of paperless
they buy so a lot of things that's
happening in in different regions it's
not just one or two countries most of
the countries China has also used this
technology in a lot of different ways so
you can explore with how these
Technologies work in different countries
and different companies just to have a
better understanding of the potential of
this technology and if you were
convinced enough that okay
this technology is very uh booming and
the support from the government is very
high then you are
satisfied what you are doing and where
you are investing your time that's very
important and you are motivated enough
you are going on a right track you will
be able to do it very easily and very
happy
so that's a little bit of what we can
discuss in our today session related to
how you can be a blockchain developer
who is a blockchain developer and what
are the steps to becoming a blockchain
developer so now let's have a look at
Supply Chain management now let's look
at a scenario before blockchain so
that's a delivery boy bringing John his
order of apples now John thanks him and
sees that is apples are rotten and John
says that he wants his money back
however the delivery boy says he can't
help since he's just the delivery boy
not the person who created the product
so these problems are the ones that were
faced before blockchain but with
blockchain technology there is
traceability across the supply chain
this means that you can trace back to
what happened to the product at each
step of the supply chain blockchain
technology enables these transactions to
be tracked in a very secure and
transparent manner now some benefits of
using blockchain technology other
there's a single record policy which
means there's a single record throughout
the entire supply chain there's reduced
cost since there's no requirement for
multiple records across the entire
supply chain there's eliminating error
and less human intervention now the last
two points come somewhat in correlation
since the less of the human intervention
usually the lesser the amount of error
let's have a look at an example of a
Supply Chain management so the product
starts from the farm goes through
storage undergoes food processing it's
manufactured distributed given to the
retailer and finally reaches the
customer now in Supply Chain management
blockchain is able to provide a
permanent record a whole lot of
transparency and the ability to validate
the transactions that are shared across
multiple supply chain partners with
blockchain the transactions are recorded
in a decentralized distributed Ledger
now the advantage of this is that anyone
can verify the authenticity or the
status of a product that is being
delivered now if you want to look at
real life example you have to look no
further than Walmart Walmart is building
a blockchain distributed ledger so that
they can connect and track poke supplier
those cheapest purchases and other units
involved in its supply chain that are
delivering the food product across China
now this is done to reduce the risk of
data tampering or inaccuracy or
inaccuracy now let's have a look at how
blockchain helped cyber security imagine
the scenario where a is sending twenty
dollars to be a census money and this
transaction details are stored in the
cloud now what if a hacker hacks the
data within the cloud and tampers this
he tampers this in such a way that he
receives the twenty dollars instead of B
here you can see the hacker being all
smug about it now this is the main
problem with the current banking system
now it is prone to cyber attacks because
it has a centralized Network this can
also lead to fraud as well as data theft
cyber attacks are one of the biggest
threats that the public has to face
however blockchain is a solution that
makes sure that your data is protected
from tampering as well as helps
improving cyber security across a number
of different Industries some of the
benefits are that it provides high
security with the help of the
cryptography that I mentioned before it
has a decentralized storage quick
transactions which take only about 10
minutes and lower cost as compared to
banking transaction costs now let's look
at the same scenario but with the help
of Bitcoins or blockchain now a sending
0.0025 Bitcoins to B which amounts to
approximately 20 dollars these Bitcoins
are sent and blue blockchain which is a
distributed Ledger distributes the data
across multiple nodes within the network
and secures this data using cryptography
another thing that you have to remember
is that each node has a copy of The
Ledger and cryptography protects the
data within it against any changes
making it immutable now imagine a hacker
trying to hack the data here he's
unsuccessful because the peer-to-peer
connection which prevents data from
being altered as well as tamper now and
finally B receives the 20 in Bitcoins
now for a real life application
MasterCard has its own blockchain
project where MasterCard is using
blockchain for sending as well as
receiving money it also allows the X
change of currency without the need of a
central Authority now let's have a look
at how blockchain can help with the
voting process now before blockchain a
voter would have to submit their voter
ID their voter IDs need to be verified
and after the verification the voter
would submit his or her work to the evm
or the electronic voting machine after
that the Voting is complete however it
is possible for the evm to be hacked
since it's a centralized system this can
lead to some amount of manipulation with
the word count however with the
decentralized system like blockchain it
is possible to completely eliminate any
scope of forgery as well as data
manipulation now let's have a look at
how voting can be performed with the
help of blockchain now first the voter
downloads a voting application the voter
submits a voter ID and registers for the
election after the verification is
complete the voter has been authorized
to cast his or her vote and the voters
submits his or her award without
revealing their identity to the public
now once this board has been added to
the blog option the information within
the blockchain can never be erased after
this the officials can count these words
knowing that each ID can be attributed
to just one vote now with blockchain
voters can also count the number of
words themselves using blockchain in the
voting process provides complete
transparency by eliminating any need for
third-party systems to be involved along
with that it can also eliminate voter
fraud as well as election rigging it
increases the transparency in the voting
process and reduces the expense of
conducting the elections now in real
life examples me vote which is a token
based blockchain platform works very
similar to that of a digital Ballot Box
now it protects the Integrity of the
word as well as protects the security of
the election process now this is already
implemented in Australia so it's only a
matter of time before this or similar
Technologies can be set up across the
world now let's have a look at some of
the other applications there's Insurance
where with blockchain they can eliminate
forgery as well as false claims and real
estate where this increases the speed of
the conveyance process and eliminates
any requirement for money exchanges so
if talking about blockchain and its
applications have caught your interest I
suggest we get on to simplylearn.com and
check out our blockchain certification
training course here we provide 50 hours
of in-depth learning 40 plus Hands-On
exercises with integrated Labs 11
practical projects covering multiple
Technologies like ethereum hyperledger
multi-chain and Bitcoin flexibility to
choose your own class timings case
studies and 24 7 support we'll be
covering Technologies like git ethereum
ganache go Docker hyperledger and much
more we'll also be talking about Bitcoin
blockchain ethereum deploying smart
contracts hyperledger blockchain or
multi-chain and a whole lot more so why
don't you go on to simplylearn.com and
get started on your journey to getting
certified and getting ahead
foreign
[Music]
blockchain is going to be a very
critical technology for the future
development of the world it's not only
about the financing blockchain
technology is not about Bitcoins Bitcoin
is just a small function of the
blockchain technology I'm a strong
believer of the blockchain technology
this is not about Bitcoin or digital
currencies or crypto assets it's the
underlying blockchain technology now
people can trust each other and they can
transact with anything from money to
music to votes to their identities
peer-to-peer Bitcoin is either my space
or it's Facebook I don't know but
blockchains social media
so at the macro blockchain is going
nowhere
right like blockchain's here to stay
forever and it's a very big deal
enter blockchain
Satoshi Nakamoto 2008 Anonymous person
came up with this way of people
transacting doing business with assets
peer-to-peer and trust is not achieved
by a middleman it's achieved by
cryptography by collaboration and by
some clever code and what that means is
that we now have a native digital medium
for Value effectively a software okay so
the distributed database that's managed
independently and that inherently that
inherent combination makes it a utility
makes it software effectively that has
value in YouTube
[Music]
foreign
the business world of the future say 10
years from now it's gonna run on Smart
contracts it's going to run on strong
encryption and on you know peer-to-peer
based consensus mechanisms so the core
Technologies underlying blockchain
are going to pervade everything just
like the internet has just like
object-oriented software has right no
so the choice when I talk to people I
said what do you think will be here in
2040 cost me 22 years from now
well golf she'll be here well it's been
here since eternity
will the dollar will the dollar be here
I don't think so and will blockchain be
here I think so
we think of Bitcoin as a digital gold so
gold 2.0 but it's money the first sip of
money that was ever built purposely for
the internet so it's sort of like what
your email did to snail mail
um cryptocurrency or Bitcoin does for
money
well Bitcoin is exciting because it
shows how cheap it can be uh Bitcoin is
is better than currency and you don't
have to have be physically in the same
place and of course for large
transactions currency can can get pretty
inconvenient the customers were talking
about aren't trying to be anonymous you
know they're willing to be uh known so
the Bitcoin technology is key and you
could add to it or you could build a
similar technology where there's enough
attribution that people feel comfortable
this is nothing to do with uh terrorism
or any type of money laundering
foreign
it's still very early
institutions everybody knows about it
everyone's heard about it and there's
some very sophisticated people in even
these Banks who know about
cryptocurrency but they're still not
really in the game yet it's still very
much a retail driven Market very much a
lot of the actions out in Asia so we we
still think it's the bottom of the first
inning it's if you read this book you
understand how we got here and how far
it's come but it's also just sort of the
beginning in a lot of ways well I think
it is working
and there will be other currencies like
it that may maybe even better but in the
meantime there's a big industry around
Bitcoin and you know people have made
fortunes out of Bitcoin some people have
lost money out of Bitcoin
um it's volatile yeah but it is quite
volatile but um but you know when in
volatility volatility people can make
money yeah so where I see crypto is
effectively is a replacement for cash
but not as a replacement for as a
primary
no not as I do not see crypto being the
primary database
[Music]
I would say there is a lot of Need for
developers even at the core protocol
layer and so things like improving
protocol scalability like working on the
client of limitations
implementations of things like proof of
stake
um layer two systems things like Sting
channels and plasma could probably use a
lot more smart people
on the application stuff I mean I guess
you could always use more but there's
probably quite a lot more of that
already
welcome to this session of blockchain
tutorial part one my name is saurabh and
I'm part of the simply learn team so
let's get started and understand what's
in it for us today so let's take a
hypothesis in our city not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there is a hacker who hates the bank who
wants to steal the money of all the
people lying in the bank now here's why
I hate them even more what are the
nuances and the problem areas of the
banking system the banking system has
higher transactional and international
transfer costs a lot of documentation is
required for setting up of an account
for opening an account and onboarding a
customer and the banking system is not
always accessible it's not 24x7 it's
closed on banking holidays and it has
other limitations also like transfer
limits in a day and you know you can't
transfer x amount within a stipulated
time now banks in such an ecosystem acts
as a center point of failure it is a
centralized based system which is prone
to failure from a centralized point of
view so if the bank fails all the
transactions will come to an halt which
are dependent on the bank now let's see
what happens if the hacker is able to
get into the banking system and hacks
the bank all the investors or the people
associated with the bank the information
associated with them will get corrupted
will get jeopardized and it can lead to
huge losses to the bank and to the
individuals and all this can happen with
a click of a button it's as simple as
that so once a hacker has access to the
system he can manipulate the system
compromise the information share it with
the parties which are not supposed to
have that information and lot can go
wrong though the hackers can be caught
right it is possible through cyber
security and various means but once the
information is compromised it is very
difficult to roll that back and that's
why we need more secure systems and
systems which are not dependent on a
centralized Authority which work in a
more decentralized fashion whereby
making it hat proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also now this incident
of course will catch the bank manager's
attention now he will go to his advisors
and want to make sure this does not
happen again so the technology come
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
blockhead now of course the manager
who's looking into the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
achieve for us so we will understand
today what is blockchain the Bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed Ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of my training
and then we will cover up a use case
where how blockchain can be used for
banking operations now what is
blockchain blockchain is a list of
Records called blocks which stores data
publicly and in a chronological order
and the entire information is persisted
using cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
Authority for unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the Democratic
Authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network so a typical blockchain
network is a public blockchain so as
long as you have access to the network
you have access to the data within the
blockchain if you are a participant on
the blockchain network you will have the
same copy of The Ledger which all other
participants have so therefore everyone
every participant on the network has the
same copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring that
data remains untempered so even if one
node or data on one particular
participant computer gets corrupted the
other participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will Rectify it as soon as possible
so basically the question is is this the
same technology that Bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes Bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand how Bitcoin adopted
blockchain in order to reach to its
Journey today so Bitcoin was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of people
known as Satoshi nakomoto it aimed to
solve the problem faced by Fiat
currencies with the help of blockchain
check technology now as of today in 2018
there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies that follow the
concepts of Bitcoin and blockchain for
example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
Litecoin Dash Ripple and many more now
let me explain how a Bitcoin transaction
works the sender transmits the
transaction details worldwide basically
whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send Bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
Bitcoin and transmit it now verification
to authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
Bitcoin Network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of balance
for the Bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver and ensuring that
the sanity of the underlying blockchain
Network to the Bitcoin remains correct
and not get corrupted so once the miner
has authenticated the transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block and then
that block is made part of the main
blockchain once the block is added to
the blockchain the money the
transactions which were associated in
the block then gets executed money is
deducted from the sender's wallet and is
added to the receiver wallet thereby
once the transaction is completed the
block is added and The Ledger across all
the nodes are updated each and every
participant Ledger copy is updated with
that particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore all
the participants have the same copy of
the information now so what makes
blockchain special now these are the
special four features of blockchain
which we're going to talk about in
detail it is a public distributed Ledger
it works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof of work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting your investing in
their resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
Bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger so
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
altered the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data so therefore if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them changed the
data the others would find that the data
does not match with their own blockchain
Works in a similar fashion in the data
within a blockchain is accessible to
everyone so with this as long as you are
part of the network you could access the
entire history of transactions that have
taken place since the blockchain was
created since Inception and the first
block in any blockchain is called the
Genesis block so from the Genesis block
to the current block you will have the
access to the entire chain any additions
to blockchain have to be approved by the
participant users in the blockchain
network so a majority of the members
within the network have to approve of
any additions to the blockchain this is
the public part of The Ledger and this
is important because any additions made
to the blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which cannot be altered
once registered they cannot be modified
and are available for audit and
verification 24x7 so this means that
each and every detail is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against everyone's personal
version of the blockchain so if
someone's tried to modify a data on a
block on a particular node then the
other ledgers which are having the same
information will come to know that
someone has modified data on a one
particular node and they will try to
rectify it and the fourth property no
Central Authority is controlling the
working of this blockchain network it is
a decentralized network so this is where
being decentralized helps everyone has a
copy of the blockchain which means there
is no central point of failure there is
a single source of truth even if things
go wrong the data can be recovered if
one node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security how is privacy maintained
if everything is so public and here
hashing encryptions comes into picture
it takes care of that so now we will
talk about the second feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption we need to understand
the content things what are the contents
of a block so a block in a blockchain is
like a container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
set of attributes it has the block
version number it has the hash of the
previous block to which it is linked the
current timestamp the timestamp at which
the block was verified the nons we will
see what is the attribute what is the
meaning of loans and the target value
now the transaction details are nothing
but the example which we talked about
earlier it is the transaction which the
sender and receiver are sharing the
sender is trying to send certain amount
of Bitcoin from his account to the
receiver's account now it is represented
in the form of a 256 fit hash value in
the header called as Merkel root or the
hash root so basically the Merkel root
is the hash of all the transactions
structured in a Merkel tree called
binary tree it's a kind of a binary tree
and the hash value of the root node of
the Merkel tree is called the Merkel
root hash so the transaction details of
a block are contained in the header in a
hex value known as Merkel root the
Merkel root can be calculated in this
way so basically the list of transaction
each transaction is passed through a
hashing algorithm then all the hashes of
the transactions are paired and then
again passed through another hashing
algorithm until only one value remains
and which will be the root now let me
tell you how a hash function Works
blockchain utilizes a hash function to
perform cryptography data from a data
set of random size is sent as input to a
hashing from function to get an
encrypted value of fixed size and that
is the feature of any hashing function
so some unique properties of hashing
function are these are deterministic the
same input will always produce the same
hash output small changes in the data
can drastically change the output so
basically any small things to the input
produces an output that's drastically
different from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation and hashing
functions are one-way functions
basically you won't be able to determine
the input based on the output value so
you can't do the reverse calculation now
let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier so as we were
discussing what are the features in the
header the previous hash is the
resultant hash of the previous Block in
the blockchain and this is the way two
blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a Merkel tree and the hash of the
Merkel root is put in the header non is
a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
header it has a block version number
basically the sequence number of the
block it has the hash of the previous
block the timestamp then the blog post
mined and verified the nonce value the
header is then this entire header is
then passed through a hashing algorithm
in the case of a Bitcoin Network it is
sha256 and a hash value is generated and
now this hash value becomes the hash
value of the block now this value is a
256 bit value that is used to uniquely
identify the particular block so sha256
ensures that alterations to data can be
easily detected so for example consider
these two blocks in the blockchain they
have a similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
Alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change too now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the Hacked block will get
dealing now this will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block so
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security blockchain also include digital
signatures these ensure that the message
come from the right identity right
person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user on board a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his her own account this is
kept as a secret by the user so
basically it says like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the sender side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm in in this
case of Bitcoin it is sha256 and the
hash is generated plus the private key
is used to generate a digital signature
now this output is passed through a
signature algorithm along with the
user's private key to create a digital
signature now during the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitter across the network so these
three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a verification algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if both the hashes are compared and
if they match then the transaction and
the identity of the sender is approved
otherwise it is rejected so basically
this is the process by comparing the
hash values to authenticate the identity
of the sender now what about the people
who verify these transactions and how do
they actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called Norms
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof of work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
there are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use Norms so this target hash value is
decided months in advance for every
block the miners keep variating the
nonce value to find out an output that
falls within the target requirement so
they keep on generating a hash value
using the nons and if it is less than
and the target the hash value is
accepted and if it is greater then the
hash values rejected the miners effort
is not considered valid now a minor
transmits across the world that he has
found a nonce that satisfies the target
requirement as soon as you find it and
thanks to the hashing algorithm used
this claim can be easily verified by
others so basically the proof of work
algorithm it is very hard to generate
the nons and get the hash value but it
is very easy to verify the transaction
by the other miners so that's a whole
lot of work what a Miner's payoff is so
for all his or her hard work they get
paid in the Bitcoins and this is the
only way the Bitcoin get added to the
network sometimes they get other forms
of remuneration as well and this is the
concept of mining so the entire process
when the miner has done the proof of
work consensus they are rewarded and
this is called as mining so mining is
the process of adding a block to the
blockchain this minor is the first
person who found a nonce value that fell
within the target requirement right now
for doing this the miner is rewarded as
of today on the Bitcoin Network a miner
is paid 12.5 Bitcoins for adding a block
onto the blockchain but the reward a
miner gets reduced by half every four
years so when the fourth year will
approach for the threshold the Bitcoin
reward will go down to 6.25 Bitcoins and
miners also get the sum of all the
transaction fees for that particular
block so the 12.5 Bitcoin reward is
Justified as mining is a very expensive
process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has
invested now we will take a look at the
use cases where blockchain is applicable
in Banks so we have been incorporating a
program where Banks can validate user
identity as of now a user needs to do
the process over and over again in each
Bank he has to go and prove the identity
in each bank is there a way we can ease
a process with blockchain and the answer
is yes we can we will be using truffle
ethereum ganache and smart contracts all
of these blockchain technology ecosystem
to make it work and welcome to this demo
for how to build your kyc blockchain
application now I'm gonna show you all
the steps required to deploy your kyc
application what all components are to
be developed and how to go about
deploying and testing your application
so primarily this kyc application will
allow Banks to do us decentralized kyc
of the customers which come to their
Banks so in the demo we will see when a
customer walks into the initiating bank
will do the kyc for a customer enter its
details sales and verify it and if any
subsequent Bank wants to use the kyc
done by another bank he or she needs to
take the permission of the customer and
then you can use the same kyc for
verification so we will see how can we
do that so just to start off with we
have developed a kyc solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once this contract is ready
we will be placing it in our sample
truffle package so this is my truffle
package and in this I have the contracts
folder in the contracts folder I have
kept my kyc DOT solve file
now in the command prompt I will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which I
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
Port 8545 and it has already given me 10
accounts pre-funded with 100 ether now I
had already mentioned that my truffle is
connected to localhost 8545 so now when
I'll do my truffle migrate command it
will connect to my ganache and deploy my
kyc contract so now I can go to TOEFL
control and for me it's very important
to see at which particular address my
solidity contract has been deployed I'll
copy it
and in my
UI code under root jscontract details.js
I will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when I deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks
so suppose I say Bank 1 and the password
should be the first address of the bank
so basically we are associating One bank
with one account which we have on our
ethereum Network so we will sign up now
bank one is successfully registered so
how I now in order to login I can check
now bank one I have logged in now I need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
now after filling the basic details I
will create the customer and the
username I have kept is customer one
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or vidhar number or any
unique identity which is attached to the
customer or the email ID and can be used
as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to login as
a customer to allow this bank to see the
kyc details now suppose if I say
customer 1 and search it it is saying
access denied and take the permission
from customer to proceed so before the
bank can do the kyc complete the
customer need to approve it so I am
creating the credentials for the
customer
thank you
now customer can see his details
whatever were filled by bank one and he
can see that there is a request from
bank 1 to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow I will also create
another bank bank 2 and Associate it
with my another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not done the original kyc right but
it is trying to look up and its access
is also denied so it needs to explicitly
take permission so the bank will take
explicit requests from the customer
so now the customer has requests from
bank 1 and bank 2 for the kyc it is up
to the customer whether he or she wants
to allow and deny the kyc request after
the permission has been granted then
only the banks can be able to view the
kyc so if I say Bank One allow and bank
to deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank one was allowed and bank 2
was denied so if I again login with
Bank One
and the password is my first address
View kyc Customer one
so here it is the bank one is able to
see the details now if I log in as bank
2 and give password and try to see the
it is saying permission denied so let's
ask bank2 to again request
now Bank two is now again a quest thing
and now this time it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the contract details dot JavaScript
where we have to provide the address at
which the contract was deployed the ABI
file the API so you can get the Avi at
here this is the Avi and you can paste
it here and this is the binary data
which has to be
pasted over here so the binary data can
be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
just to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
kyc records of a particular customer now
we can modify
the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment so hey thanks for coming
back to explain how blockchain work now
let's talk about the features of
blockchain is the public distributed
Ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof of work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with the concept
of mining in order to reward the miners
for keeping them and maintaining the
sanity of the network and finally about
how you can Implement blockchain in a
banking system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a One bank can be
leveraged by another bank and the
customer does not have to go through
multiple kyc iterations with each and
every Bank whom he or she wants to
transact with now we will get a little
deeper into blockchain and today we will
talk about these topics we will talk
about what is a candidate block we will
talk about Byzantine fault tolerance
which was one of the earlier consensus
mechanisms then we will talk about the
problem of if we have to add two blocks
at the same time then how does
blockchain handles that then we will
talk about the concept of forking what
are soft folks what are hard folks and
other areas where blockchain is getting
used what is the future of blockchain
and what are the upcoming blockchain
jobs and the profiles which are upcoming
in the market and then in the end we
will do a quick demo on how to create a
smart contract and deploy it for a
particular use case now before a block
can be mined a miner has to make an very
important decision which transactions
would be added to his block so before
transactions are added to the blockchain
they are collected in a temporary
container called a memory tool the
miners select transactions from the
spool and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miners selects from the memory pool
The Miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as Byzantine fault
ronderance so in order to maintain the
sanity of the network and to have the
correct consensus there was something
called as Byzantine fault tolerance
consensus algorithm to understand this
you need to know what the Byzantine
General's problem is so let's imagine a
Byzantine General and three other
lieutenants need to take over this town
however they are at different places and
can't directly communicate with each
other so here we have the general and
history lieutenants the general has to
ensure that all lieutenants follow the
same order he or she gives them to
attack or to retreat now this has to be
ensured even if one of the lieutenants
is a traitor so this is the Byzantine
General's problem that how does the
general communicates the correct
decision which he has taken to all his
lieutenants in his Network irrespective
if someone is a traitor in this case a
traitor could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages to
different lieutenants now here we can
see that General is giving all his
reference the command to attack the
traitor could ruin this by sending every
other Lieutenant the command to retreat
the opposite now in this situation the
traitor would make others believe that
the general asked them to retreat so as
we can see the lieutenant in brown is
the traitor and he could communicate to
other lieutenants the wrong information
and make them act on his behalf as a
traitor themselves now this would cause
the lieutenants to retreat and the
General's attack to fail so how do we
tackle this the only way an attack or a
retreat will be successful is by having
a majority supporting that particular
action to achieve this the lieutenants
keep a tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to each of his
lieutenants the lieutenants in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the lieutenant near to them so
each Lieutenant will pass this order to
the nearest left in it the Tracer also
will do the same but hence the retreat
order to the other lieutenants however
this will not be successful successful
because each Lieutenant now has a
majority of attack and minority of
retreat so this shows that the majority
of the lieutenants would follow the
General's command and the attack will be
successful the scenario I mentioned
before is Byzantine fault tolerant now
the same situation can be encountered in
blockchain as well the traitor would add
invalid transactions into the blockchain
the Creator would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain this would affect the
reliability of blockchain the network
blockchain are able to achieve Byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computive because it is
heavily reliant on value obtained from
the existing blockchain chain to have
any meaningful impact the hacker would
have to take a lot of time resources
producing sufficient proof of work
interesting imagine if you and I were
miners and we both had a block to the
blockchain at the same time how do we
handle such a situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first Miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined limit if the generated
hash value is less than the target then
the value is accepted and the block is
added to the blockchain but if it is
greater than the target then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain but in this case if two
people will have obtained a satisfactory
hash value at the same time so minor 1
and minor 2 were able to find the hash
which was less than the target then what
will happen whether minus one block will
get added to the blockchain or minus 2
block will get added to the blockchain
Now 50 of the network has accepted minus
one block and suppose rest has accepted
minus two block so half of the network
continues to work considering miners one
block to be the right block and the
other half Network continues to work
considering minus two block to be the
right block however only one minus
blockchain can be allowed to remain we
cannot have two blockchains running it
will defeat the purpose now this is
achieved by selecting the substance to
which miners have first added a block so
suppose minor 3 adds a new block to
minus one blockchain this block now
added by minor 3 is verified by everyone
in the network it is there and accepted
as the dominant blockchain and is used
by everyone else in the network the
other version of the blockchain The
Miner 2 is completely discarded and the
entire network now accepts minor one's
blockchain and we have now a single
blockchain existing now this situation
is also called an accidental Fork so I
heard about a version of Bitcoin called
Bitcoin cash what's the difference
between them there are other kinds too
like Bitcoin gold and Bitcoin private
these are all outcomes of a fork so what
is a fork a fork is said to have taken
place when a blockchain diverges into
two potential Parts a fork happens when
the users of a network cannot come to an
agreement with regards to a Network's
transaction details and the new rules to
validate those transactions so there are
two types of folks which can exist
either it can be a soft work or it can
be a hard Fork a soft focus occurs when
a change in the Soft C protocol makes
new blocks added to the blockchain
following the new rules but are Backward
Compatible but in order to have a soft
work it requires a majority of the users
to commit to that change to be
successful so a soft Fork could have
multiple uses it could be for tighter
rules it could be for cosmetic changes
addition of new functions but not
affecting the structure so consider the
scenario where the accepted block size
is to be reduced from 1 MB to 100 KB so
first of all it has to be approved by a
majority of the network now the old
version will be running on 1mb block
size but once approved the new version
will start working on a block size of
100 KB so anything which is less than
100 KB will be approved and will be
added to the new block so over time
people following the older version of
the blockchain would be forced to move
to the new one since none of their
transactions would go through so
basically people using the old
blockchain they will be using the 1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100 KB block now let's talk about
hard Fork a hard Fork involves a change
in the software protocol so radical that
it forces a new blockchain to be created
altogether so basically in a hard Fork
there will be two versions there will be
one blockchain that hasn't upgraded and
there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate the New
Path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now Bitcoin performed a hard Fork on 1st
August 2017 which created bitcoin cash
so thereby both Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash
remain existent now Bitcoin cash was
different from regular Bitcoin because
it increased the block size from 1 MB to
8 MB so thereby it held reducing the
transaction cost significantly lesser
than that of the original Bitcoin
Network now other than with Bitcoin
where else is blockchain used the other
areas are for preventing voter fraud
blockchain helps in ensuring that there
is only one vote per person ensuring
that the data is not being tampered with
or any false alterations are done it
helps creating an immutable ledger to
record the votes as tallied so once a
transaction or a vote is recorded it
cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the products
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easily so where
do you think blockchain is going to be
used in the future so blockchain is
seeing wide range of adoption amongst
organizations as of now only one percent
of all organizations have begun using
blockchain Technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next five years or so then there is
a need for blockchain regulations the
rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear for
organizations to be comfortable using it
and move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several Industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning and believe that the
adoption of a blockchain system is
inward the effort and there is an
increase in job opportunities for
skilled Personnel so as the technology
is maturing there would be a huge
requirement for individuals who can
understand and implement the concepts of
blockchain so what options do people
have for jobs involving blockchain at
the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blocked in architect and
blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile which requires
designing implementing and supporting a
distributed blockchain Network analyze
user requirements Design Technology
around a certain business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile requires to
design and architect blockchain industry
Solutions creates blockchain networks
leveraging blockchain technology
platforms produce high quality code
based on Project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain Frameworks and assets so
let's have a quick demo on how to deploy
a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and solidity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my Local Host it is running
on Port 8505 and network ID 5778
whenever you run a ganache client it is
preceded with 10 accounts and 100 ether
balance now this is my movie rating app
and in this app I am going to deploy a
smart contract called rating dot Soul
which is gono capture the ratings for a
certain set of movies which I'll
predefine and the users will be able to
set the ratings on a blockchain network
in a decentralized fashion and we will
be able to see that in every transaction
a block is getting generated in my
ganache client so in my movie rating app
under the rating folder I will run the
command trough compile and it will
compile my smart contract rating dot
Soul now the next command which I have
to run is trough migrate
now at this instance the trough migrate
command will deploy my smart contract on
my ganache client so if you see there
are four blocks which have been created
and
my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so I can go back to my command
prompt and say trough console and check
the address of my contract so this is
0x695 which is this address now when I
deployed my smart contract I had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploycontract.js under rating
migrations and in that I had given this
entry I had given the path to my rating
solidity file and I had initialized my
smart contract with three movies Star
Wars Avatar and Inception and given some
predefined gas now once these steps are
done and I know the address at which my
contract is deployed I will copy that
and paste it
in the file of ethereumsetup.js which is
lying under my rating app UI Source
folder and I'll just change this address
now once this rating address is changed
I have to go back to my movie rating app
folder under app UI I have to give the
command npm start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see I'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level my block is going to increase
block 6 Inception block 7 and as and
when my rating is increasing a block is
getting added so this demonstrates the
usage of truffle and ganache in order to
build your decentralized app hyperledger
and its importance
hyperledger
hyperledger is an open source
collaborative effort created to advance
cross-industry blockchain Technologies
it is a global collaboration hosted by
the Linux Foundation including leaders
in finance banking internet of things
Supply chains manufacturing and
Technology
it is a framework to create deploy and
maintain blockchains for businesses that
ensure accountability transparency and
Trust among business partners as a
result hyperledger makes business
networks in transactions more efficient
concept of hyperledger
now before I tell what hyperledger is
let me tell you what hyperledger isn't
hyperledger isn't a blockchain a company
or a cryptocurrency
hyperledger is a software used to create
one's own personalized blockchain
service
it is basically a project within the
Linux Foundation just like several other
projects under them which include
node.js all join drone code and akumos
since it is open source people across
the globe can come and help develop and
grow the platform
restrictions in public blockchain with a
goal in mind to develop an
enterprise-based blockchain platform
developers started testing interactions
between applications and secure
blockchains and realized that public
blockchains require each peer to
validate transactions and run consensus
this is a major challenge when it comes
to scalability moreover the transaction
confidentiality and privacy was also
getting lost as every node in the
network was receiving a copy of The
Ledger private and confidential
contracts let's consider an example a
certain bank is giving better privileges
to its premium customers for instance in
credit cards thus if I am a premium
customer of the bank and have been
banking with them for quite some time
then it will give me a better offer on
credit cards or will give me a loan at
discounted rates these things are common
in the banking world
however if these Banks start using
public blockchains which have complete
transparency disparity like these will
become evident
moreover there is an issue with regards
to competition
all banks are competing with each other
in order to create a better place for
themselves in the market thus they want
their confidential information about
transactions and other operations to
stay completely confidential
this won't be possible in a public
blockchain like ethereum which stores
all smart contracts on public ledgers
this is where platforms like hyperledger
come into the picture which permits
permissioned and private transactions
and it is highly scalable as a platform
solution to the restrictions
on hyperledger network only parties
directly related to the transaction deal
are updated on The Ledger thus
maintaining privacy and confidentiality
hyperledger primarily leverages the
concept of channels to ensure privacy
and confidentiality
a channel is basically a virtual
blockchain Network which sits atop a
physical blockchain Network and has its
own access rules
they employ their own mechanism for
transaction ordering and thus ensures
scalability thereby permitting effective
ordering along with the separation of
data in the above example when John and
Kat are conducting a transaction a
private Channel between them serves as a
method of interaction
the smart contract can thus be viewed by
only these two parties and the Network's
endorsement policy verifies their
membership with the network to ensure
privacy thus the transaction is secured
and private and confidential
hyperledger transaction
in the above example John is initiating
a transaction to send a message to Cat
Let's assume that we have a state in The
Ledger named as message denoting the
last message that had been sent and its
store as a key value pair in peer of
organization
now John has decided to send a new
message to Kat and submit a request to
the node.js backhand from the message
dashboard the node.js SDK client takes
this new proposed state and sends a
proposal to all the endorsing peers of
the organization as per the endorsing
policy defined in the channel
configuration as well as confiding to
the membership services this includes a
proposal request to invoke the
corresponding function described in the
chain code the message thus gets
verified by the orderer and finally gets
committed to the couchdb thus confirming
the transaction
Linux family
hyperledger is a part of the umbrella
project under Linux Foundation where a
community of developers work on open
source projects Linux Foundation
provides infrastructure Services events
training and financial resources for
creating sustainable open source
ecosystems
Linux Foundation is known for its open
source projects
hyperledger is a Consortium of
organizations it's not a blockchain
platform with hyperledger there are
different blockchain projects the
original code for these projects was
submitted by various companies like IBM
Intel
Etc
Linux then made these codes open source
to invite the entire Community to work
together and contribute to the codes the
vision was to create an Enterprise level
blockchain platform hyperledger projects
hyperledger umbrella strategy
hyperledger nurtures a lot of blockchain
Frameworks and Technologies Under the
Umbrella strategy some of the well-known
projects under hyperledger are as
follows
Sawtooth Lake hyperledger Sawtooth is a
blockchain platform implementation which
builds deploys and runs distributed
ledgers it is a modular platform which
provides a digital record without a
central Authority or implementation
it is primarily used for supply chain
Networks fabric hyperledger Fabrics
framework was contributed by IBM fabric
works as a foundation for developing
applications with a modular architecture
the framework utilizes container
technology to host smart contracts chain
code comprising the system's application
logic one of the examples where it is
used is fishing industry to track the
supply chain of fishes
burrow hyperledger burrow hosted by the
Linux Foundation is a blockchain
framework implementation the framework
was contributed by monax and
co-sponsored by Intel
burrow is a permission smart contract
application engine partially developed
in accordance to the specifications of
ethereum virtual machine evm
it is used to run ethereum smart
contracts iroha
hyperledger iroha hosted by the Linux
Foundation is another blockchain
platform implementation
the framework was contributed by Sora
mitsu Hitachi NTT data and kolu written
in C plus plus hyperledger iroha
incorporates a unique algorithm on
chain-based Byzantine fault tolerant
consensus it provides a small set of
fast commands and queries covering most
common operations for the digital asset
and identity management it can be used
in mobile application organization
indie hyperledger Indie is a distributed
Ledger and utility Library built for
decentralized identity
the distributed Ledger provides tools
libraries and reusable components to
create and use independent digital
identities based on blockchains they are
inoperable across administrative
applications domains and any other silo
it is used as a decentralized identity
database
Sawtooth
hyperledger Sawtooth is a blockchain
platform built for Enterprise use where
the design focuses on maintaining the
safety of smart contracts and the
ledgers are kept distributed Sawtooth
offers a simplified platform for
blockchain application development by
separating the application domain at the
core system level
application developers could opt for a
language of their choice to write smart
contracts logic following are some of
the key features of Sawtooth
application layer in core system
separation
parallel transaction execution plugable
consensus algorithm private networks
with Sawtooth permissioning features
ethereum contract compatible with Seth
event system hyperledger architecture
hyperledger blockchain Network
participants
following are the different participants
Within hyperledger blockchain
blockchain user a blockchain user
performs transaction on the network the
user can invoke a function from the
chain code in order to send the
instruction message to the underlying
Network which can then process the
transaction
certificate Authority
the certificate Authority ensures that
only certain restricted parties can be a
part of the business Network on
hyperledger they access security
certifications in order to determine the
parties who have required privileges to
be an actor on a network
traditional database it is a standard
database which is used to store data
traditional processing platform it
stores access to the logical code
written which is used to run the network
as per the design blockchain development
Network
it operates the blockchain network which
enables the execution of smart contracts
chain code as well as various
transactions that take place between the
participants which are part of the
network
blockchain developer
a developer develops applications on the
blockchain using chain code currently
hyperledger fabric supports node.js Java
and golang languages to write such chain
codes
regulator
regulator runs oversight to ensure that
the platform is operating without any
bias
hyperledger architecture
following are three main components of
hyperledger membership service
it is a set of cryptographic materials
certificates that defines organization
by itself every peer and orderer needs
this type of certificate this
certificate has some common property by
which we decide whether the peer and the
orderer belongs to the same organization
or not appear which is a part of the
same MSP can communicate with each other
a peer from other organizations cannot
be allowed to communicate with each
other blockchain and transaction layer
this layer constitutes the core code of
the blockchain it comprises of consensus
algorithm which is required to make the
final decision on the state of every
transaction
it also contains the distributed Ledger
and Ledger storage which stores the
entire history of the transactions and
the last known States lastly we have the
PDP protocol which is used for
communication between different nodes on
the network
chain code it is The Logical programming
layer which consists of the business
logic required to run an operation on
the hyperledger permissioned blockchain
and its consensus model permissioned
blockchain maintains an access control
layer and allows certain actions to be
performed only by a few identifiable
participants it is also called private
blockchain following are the properties
specific to permissioned blockchains it
has legally accountable validators it is
suitable for off-chain assets they can
be used as an IT tool for settlement and
clearing examples include Ripple which
determines roles for a select number of
participants who can act as transaction
validators on their Network such
blockchains are also popular among
industry-level Enterprises and
businesses for which security identity
and role definition are important
permissioned versus permissionless
blockchain let us see some differences
between a permissioned and a
permissionless blockchain
one in regards to access a permissioned
blockchain only allows pre-approved
members to access the network and make
transactions to it whereas a
permissionless blockchain allows anyone
to be a part of the network as it is
completely open and transparent
two permissioned blockchain are faster
than permissionless blockchain when it
comes to Performance as they have less
number of participants in the network
three permissioned blockchain use
different types of consensus algorithms
like pbft proof of stake and more
usually permissionless blockchains rely
on proof of work four the transaction
cost in a permissioned blockchain is
lower than that of a permissionless
blockchain five in regards to stability
permissioned blockchain are considered
more stable compared to permissionless
blockchains as the former have a better
governance due to known parties which
are part of the network
six in a permissionless blockchain all
participants have the same level of
access whereas a permissioned blockchain
provides full access only to the members
which are registered to be a part of the
business Network
seven
permissionless blockchains work in a
peer-to-peer fashion relying solely on
consensus algorithms to create a trusted
environment however permissioned
blockchains have trusted members as part
of the network which enhances the Trust
on the network consensus and its
interaction with architectural layers
consensus
consensus is the process by which a
network of nodes validates the block of
transactions and provide a guaranteed
ordering of transactions and validating
those block of transactions that need to
be committed to The Ledger consensus
must ensure the following in the network
confirms the correctness of all
transactions in a proposed block
according to endorsement and consensus
policies
agrees on order and correctness and
hence on the results of execution
depends on Smart contract layer to
verify correctness of an ordered set of
transactions in a block hyperledger it
makes use of the permissioned
voting-based consensus from the pool of
the other consensus named the lottery
based consensus
consensus properties consensus must
satisfy two properties to guarantee
agreement among nodes safety and
liveness safety means that each node is
guaranteed the same sequence of inputs
and results in the same output on each
node the algorithm must behave identical
to a single node system that executes
each transaction atomically one at a
time liveness means that each non-faulty
node will eventually receive every
submitted transaction assuming that
communication does not fail
activities performed to reach consensus
hyperledger Frameworks reach consensus
by performing two activities transaction
ordering transaction validation
biologically separating these activities
we ensure that any hyperledger framework
can work with any hyperledger consensus
module the first step of the consensus
process flow is receiving the
transactions from the client application
consensus depends on an ordering service
to order transactions transaction order
enables confidentiality of the
transactions it also increases the
efficiency of the transactions to
validate transactions consensus depends
on the smart contract layer because it
contains the business logic behind what
makes a transaction valid
transaction validation contains business
logic to make the transaction valid it
also ensures the confirmation of
policies and contracts specified for the
transaction
then it also checks for syntax and logic
errors
consensus model for permissioned
blockchain consensus in hyper Ledger
fabric as seen in the image above is
broken out into three phases endorsement
ordering and validation
endorsement is driven by policy EG M out
of n signatures upon which participants
endorse a transaction ordering phase
accepts the endorsed transactions and
agrees to the order to be committed on
The Ledger
validation takes a block of ordered
transactions and validates the
correctness of the results including
checking endorsement policy and double
spending
as soon as a new transaction is created
it is sent to the endorsement peer to
generate a read write pair the read
write pair from every endorser is then
sent to the orderer which orders the
same and generates a block based on
consensus
the ordered block is then sent to the
validator to update the couchdb with the
most recent state
API and network topology in hyperledger
API it enables clients and applications
to interface to the blockchains
hyperledger supports the following types
of apis admin apis this class creates an
Administration connection to a
hyperledger composer runtime the
connection can then be used to deploy
business Network definitions
undeploy business Network definitions
update business Network definitions
send a ping message to the runtime to
ensure it is running and correctly
configured
storyconnection profile document in the
connection profile store Common apis
they are used to obtain information
about the connected networks this
information can include business Network
metadata enum declaration and many more
runtime apis
these are used to perform all
transaction operations like running a
query managing assets and more Network
topology
Network topology is a technical
infrastructure that provides smart
Contract Services and ledger to
Applications listed below are the
components of network topology
Ledger a ledger consists of two distinct
Parts a blockchain and the state
database
unlike other ledgers blockchains are
immutable in contrast the world state is
a database containing the current value
of the set of key value pairs that have
been added modified or deleted by the
set of validated and committed
transactions in the blockchain
smart contract a smart contract is a
code that is invoked by a client
application external to the blockchain
network it manages access and
modifications to a set of key value
pairs in the world state
in hyperledger fabric smart contracts
are referred to as a chain code pure
nodes it is a network entity that
maintains a ledger and runs chain code
containers in order to perform read
write operations to The Ledger peers are
owned and maintained by members
ordering service it is a defined
Collective of nodes that orders
transactions into a block the ordering
service exists independent of the peer
processes and orders transactions on a
first-come first-served basis for all
channels on the network
channels a channel is a private
blockchain overlay which allows for data
isolation and confidentiality
a channel-specific ledger is shared
across the peers in the channel and
transacting parties must be properly
authenticated to a channel in order to
interact with it fabric certificate
authorities hyperledger fabric CA is the
default certificate Authority component
which issues pki based certificates to
network member organizations and their
users
the ca issues one root certificate to
each member and one enrollment
certificate to each authorized user
steps to create a hyper Ledger Network
following steps should be followed to
create a hyper Ledger Network step one
create a network the network is Created
from the definition of the Consortium
including its clients peers channels and
ordering service the ordering service is
the administration point for the network
because it contains the configuration
for the channel within the network
Step 2 Define a Consortium a Consortium
is comprised of two or more
organizations on the network
consortiums are defined by organizations
that have a need for transacting
business with one another and they must
agree to the policies that govern the
network
step 3 create a channel for Consortium a
channel is a means of communication used
to connect the components of the network
and or the member client applications
step four join peers to channels peers
are joined to channels by the
organizations that own them and there
can be multiple peer nodes on channels
within the network
step 5 install Smart contracts smart
contract chain code must be installed
and instantiated on a peer in order for
a client application to be able to
invoke the smart contract
step 6 optimize the network while there
is no theoretical limit on how big a
network can get
as the network grows it is important to
consider design choices that will help
optimize Network throughput stability
and resilience
step 7 add another consortium definition
as consortia are defined and is added to
the existing Channel we must update the
channel configuration by sending a
channel configuration update transaction
to the ordering service step 8 add a new
channel
organizations are what form and join
channels and channel configurations can
be amended to add organizations as the
network grows when adding a new channel
to the network channel policies remain
separate from other channels configured
on the same network
step nine add peer and join it to
multiple channels you can continue
adding new peers and connect them to
several channels within the network
Network topology the diagram above shows
a fabric network with the following
configuration
there is a fabric Network in with
network policy np1 and ordering service
o
Channel C1 is governed by Channel policy
cp1
Channel C1 has been established by
Consortium rarb
Channel C1 is managed by ordering
service o and Piers P1 and P2 and client
applications A1 and A2 have been granted
permission to transact on C1
client application A1 is owned by
organization ra
certificate Authority ca1 serves
organization r a
peer P2 maintains Ledger L1 associated
with Channel C1 and L2 associated with
C2
peer P2 makes use of chain code S4 and
S5
the orderer nodes of ordering service o
are owned by organization Rd meet Frank
and Daniel one day they decide to go for
a trip to Venice they made a budget list
for all their expenses like residence
flight Etc they thought of making their
bookings online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day while making their respective
flight bookings Daniel's transaction
failed and he missed the offer going on
on the other hand Frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three Lucky Draw winners Daniel
was surprised and asked Frank how he
could make the transaction when Daniel
himself could not to which his response
was it's simple I used Bitcoin a type of
cryptocurrency
Daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
Frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 By
Satoshi Nakamoto Daniel felt that it
sounds similar to other online payment
options yes what makes it so different
Frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or Central Authority unlike
other payment systems that Banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
Daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit or his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank but on the other hand
cryptocurrency charges almost no or very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
24 7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges on making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account on any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency this is what makes
cryptocurrency see different from other
online payment options Daniel was
impressed by cryptocurrency but he
wondered how it works without the
control of an external Authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital Ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system then it is verified and validated
by every node to proceed with the
process of making the transactions the
crypto and cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives now Daniel was
completely aware of the whole technology
and concept behind cryptocurrency and
was influenced by Frank to adopt
cryptocurrency in his daily lifestyle
too he did that by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount
like Daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide due to this
increasing popularity new companies like
metoo and PayPal are coming forward and
investing in cryptocurrency every day in
2018 Malta an Island located in the
Mediterranean Sea south of Italy was
titled blockchain Island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like finance and
okx have already begun to take advantage
of malta's financial incentives and have
moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island
so here is a question for you which
hashing algorithm does cryptocurrency
use
a script
B ethash
c
sha-256 d none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers cryptocurrency is
revolutionizing finance and banking
around the world thanks to
cryptocurrency now anyone with an
internet connection can trade spend and
borrow money around the world and nobody
can stop them people like Bill Gates
co-founder of Microsoft Corporation and
Elon Musk CEO of Tesla support
cryptocurrency as it is much better and
secure than physical money and also
holds a great future for the world's
economy and on the other hand some
people think of cryptocurrency as a bane
to the world's economy like Warren
Buffett CEO of Berkshire Hathaway and
Ajay benga CEO of global MasterCard feel
the cryptocurrency is a platform of
criminal activities and will destroy the
world's economy well one thing is clear
that this conflict is going to stay put
for a little longer welcome to this
session of blockchain wallet now before
these blockchain wallets came into
existence what were the means in order
for us to do the transactions and what
were the drawbacks in the old days the
transactions with whatever medium and
channels we had the problems were that
the transactions were slow and Banks
were the central point of failure
basically any transaction which has to
go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blockchain wallet a blockchain wallet is
a the cryptocurrency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example Bitcoin
ethereum Etc now a blockchain wallet
helps exchanging of funds easily
transactions are secure as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blockchain wallet is
a typical cryptocurrency wallet that
allows users to manage cryptocurrencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
PayPal or any other Gateway which you
use today but now you can use
cryptocurrency instead similar to PayPal
which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem how
of blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain.info
Jax mycelium Samurai and Bitcoin paper
wallet these are just to name a few
blockchain wallets which are existing in
the market but there are many more based
on the requirement you have based on the
security you require and based on the
kind of wallet which suffices your need
so we will see what are the
categorizations of these kind of wallets
are now how do blockchain wallets work
let's take a look so before we move on
to how blockchain wallets work let's
understand what a private and a public
key is and how are these Keys related to
a blockchain wallet now whenever you
create a blockchain wallet you are also
provided a private and a public key
which is associated with your wallet now
let's check an example in order to
understand this imagine a person knowing
your email address is sending you an
email so in our regular day-to-day
activity if you we want to receive an
email from someone we give him or her
our email ID and expect an email from
them now what if an unknown person is
able to send emails through my account
so I am giving my email address for
receiving emails but when I am
disclosing my email ID I am not assuming
that someone will be able to send emails
through my account because then for that
he has to be aware of my email account
password so knowing your email address
will not give a person the ability to
send an email from your account you are
not giving your password to the person
to send an email you're just giving the
email address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now blockchain wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share that public key with anyone in
order to receive funds private key is
top secret it's similar to your password
it should not get hacked or you should
not disclose it to anyone and you use
this private key to spend your funds so
now instead of sending an email imagine
you want to transfer money to your
friend just answer process is done
through your blockchain wallet with
blockchain wallets you can now send and
receive cryptocurrencies so as I said a
blockchain wallet has two keys a public
key and a private key public key is
shared with everyone just like an email
address private key is just like your
password which should be kept secret
with the sender so with blockchain
wallet no one will be able to send
crypto coins just like emails through
your public key until they know your
private key but if someone gets access
to your private key there is a high
possibility that your account is hacked
and you might end up losing all the
cryptocurrency deposits in your account
now let's take a look what are the
typical features of a blockchain wallet
it's easy to use it's just like any
other software or a wallet which you use
for your day-to-day transactions it is
highly secure it is just like a matter
of you securing your private key and it
allows instant transactions across
geographies barrier-free without
intermediaries and also these
transactions charges you low cost fee
and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies so you can make
payments across cryptocurrencies which
helps you do easy currency conversions
now let's talk about what are the
different type of blockchain wallets now
basically there are two types of
blockchain wallets based on the private
Keys one is hot wallet and another is
the cold wallet hot wallets are like
normal wallets which we carry for
day-to-day transactions and these
wallets are user friendly cold wallets
cold wallets are similar to a vault
where cryptocurrencies are stored with a
high level of security now let's take a
look at the differences hot wallets are
online wallets through which
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
quickly they are available online on
internet example coinbase
blockchain.info coal wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed offline and then
later disclosed online so they are not
maintained on the cloud on the internet
they are maintained offline to have high
security and the examples of cold wallet
are treasure and Ledger now in case hot
wallets private keys are stored in the
cloud for faster transfer in case of
cold wallets private keys are stored in
a separate Hardware which are
disconnected from the Internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper-based
document hot wallet they are easy to
access available online 24 7 can be
accessed through desktop or mobile but
has a risk of unrecoverable theft when
hacked cold wallet this method of
transaction helps in protecting the
wallet from unauthorized access from
hacking and other online vulnerabilities
now the wallet can be further
distinguished on these criterias there
can be software wallets they can be
Hardware wallets which are like kind of
USB driven and you plug into your USB
drive and your Hardware wallet can be
used or they are a typical paper-based
wallet where you print your public key
and a private key on a paper and keep it
in a secure place let's talk about
software wallet a software wallet is an
application that is downloaded on a
device either it could be a desktop or a
mobile or it could be a web-based wallet
which can be accessed online now here
are certain examples Dax bread wallet
and copay are the popular software
wallets so software wallet can be
further categorized into desktop wallet
online or we can call it web wallets or
mobile wallets now desktop wallets are
like cold wallet in which the private
keys are stored in cold servers
basically the desktop wallets in the
private keys are stored in your desktop
you can unplug it from the internet do
some offline transactions and then bring
it back online now in case the mail
server is lost then a cold server
basically a desktop is used as a backup
server these wallets can be downloaded
on any computer but can only be accessed
from the system they are installed on so
you make sure the desktop or the machine
on which you I have downloaded the
desktop wallet is safe has a backup
you're maintaining the hardware you're
not letting the machine go anywhere and
it is on a secure location now these
wallets are definitely cost efficient
and one of the examples is electrum and
is one of the most popular desktop
wallet online wallets are the other kind
of hot wallets that run on the Cloud
that are available on the internet now
here users have the benefit of accessing
these wallets across any device it could
be tablet desktop or you can use it from
your mobile browser the private keys are
stored online and are managed by a third
party you have to be dependent on a
third party service so for example green
address is a Bitcoin wallet which is
available on the web has an Android app
it's available on a desktop and also is
available on iOS Apple mobile wallets
mobile wallets are like similar to
online wallets except that they are
built only for mobile phone usage and
accessibility these wallets are also
user friendly and they have a
user-friendly interface from which helps
you in doing transactions easily the
example is mycelium which is the best
available Mobile Wallet Hardware wallets
Hardware wallet is a type of cold
storage device typically like a USB
which stores the user's private key in a
protected Hardware device these volume
plates are similar to Portable devices
that can be connected to the computer
can be plugged in as I said earlier it
is less prone to malware attacks
malicious attacks and it is hack proof
examples are Nano Ledger treasure and
key key are the top Hardware wallets
available in the market to make a
transaction from your Hardware wallet
you have to ensure the hardware wallet
is plugged into your computer system
before you can do a transaction from
your Hardware wallet paper wallet a
paper wallet is an offline process for
storing cryptocurrencies this wallet is
a printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a QR code now since these
wallets are says they are widely used
for storing large amount of
cryptocurrencies now in amplar Bitcoin
paper wallet and my ether wallet are one
of the widely used paper wallets but the
question arises how do I add
cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on your paper wallet now let's
do the comparison blockchain info
blockchain info is a cryptocurrency
wallet which supports Bitcoin and
ethereum it is easy to use and has a low
transaction fee it has its API is
exposed you can easily use them to order
to make your own custom wallets also
Ledger Nano Ledger Nano is a hardware
wallet which offers a high security to
your account it is available for Bitcoin
ethereum and Litecoin users it is also
possible to maintain multiple accounts
and access them anytime Bitcoin paper
wallet paper wallet helps you to print
your own tamper resistant Bitcoin wallet
it minimizes the threat of hacking Jacks
Jax is a software wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for Bitcoin
ethereum Litecoin and many other
cryptocurrencies with Jax a user can
view his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so
bitaddress.org provides you a paper
wallet it uses the client-side
JavaScript in order to generate a random
hash for your wallet so you keep moving
your mouse and it will generate a hash
public and private key it is recommended
that when you are doing this process you
should be disconnected from the internet
and once these keys are generated you
can print it and keep it secure and
clear the cache of your browser so as
you can see on the screen this is my
public key for receiving my Bitcoins and
this is the private key for me to spend
it I can print it and keep it handy with
me but of course the safety of these
physical documents cannot be entirely
guaranteed if a hacker discovers the
location of your paper wallet and
physically steals it then they can
access your Bitcoin Holdings so
basically it is of high importance that
you keep the paper wallet in a very very
secure location some users hide or
disguise the paper wallet it should be
protected from physical damage if the
keys fade or can no longer be scanned
then the user will never again be able
to access the Bitcoin which are parked
in that address also take care if you
are using an incorrect type of printer
that also may damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bit pay so you can
download bitpay online and create your
account over here
you can create a personal wallet you can
create a shared wallet or a joint share
wallet once you create a wallet like if
you see the example over here this is my
personal wallet and I have
3.645 test Bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test Bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
Bitcoins from
testnet.coinforcet.eu hyphen in
now in order to receive it you just need
to
copy
your Bitcoin address
in the test net address
so the test net has given me 0.87
Bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from 3.5 to 3.64 and I can see this
transaction
see three minutes go I just received
0.872287 Bitcoin the transaction is
still in process but in a while as this
transaction is getting mined on the test
net I will receive it now as I have
received it I can even make a
transaction and send it to someone
so from my personal account I can send
Bitcoin to
someone whose Bitcoin address I have and
I have to just paste it over here
transfer to bitcoin wallet either I can
select one of my own wallets or I can
search for any other Bitcoin address
which someone has shared with me and I
can send it to that particular address
now let's take an example of our
Hardware wallet how does Hardware wallet
works with the online wallets so here we
have metamask which has a feature of
connecting with Hardware wallet so once
you have metamask installed you will see
this option of connect Hardware wallet
now metamask has provided support for
Treasure so now once you connect your
Hardware wallet the USB with your
computer you can select an account you
want to view on that particular Hardware
wallet and you can only choose one at a
time and then you can start using that
particular wallet for your decentralized
apps so basically once you have your
Hardware connected it is integrated with
your metamask and then you can start
running your decentralized apps so that
they can start using the tokens or the
currency in the particular Hardware
wallet so use your Hardware account like
you would with any ethereum account
login to dapps and send ethereums buy
and store erc20 tokens and non-fungible
tokens like crypto kitties so if you
click connect to treasure over here
metamask will start looking out for the
connected treasure device now what is
bitcoin Bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like Banks governments agents Brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediate now
Bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called Satoshi
nakomoto now Bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular Fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed immediate trees from between the
cost of transaction also goes down and
it is cryptographically secure it uses
cryptography infrastructure and thereby
the identities of the sender and the
receiver are also secure and the entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the user's information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of Bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a Bitcoin Network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public Ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the Bitcoin Network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so Bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
Ledger in which transactions made in
Bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized Authority or the body and
the transactions are towed in containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain which records all the
transaction a basic structure of a block
is some something like this it has four
Fields these are the primary attributes
for Block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block nons
so in proof of work consensus algorithm
which is used in Bitcoin nonce is a
random value which is used to vary the
output of the hash value so every block
is supposed to generate a hash value and
nonce is the parameter which is used to
generate that hash value and the proof
of work is the process of transaction
verification done in blockchain now hash
is the resultant hash value obtained by
passing the previous hash value the data
and the nouns through the sha256
algorithm to generate the hash of this
block so this is the digital signature
of the block which is generated and this
is the basically identity of this block
now sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographical
algorithm whatever input you give it
will always produce a 256 bit hash now
let's understand the concepts of Bitcoin
mining what is Bitcoin mining Bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
Bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain Ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by Bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called minus so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of Legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in Bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining Community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every Miner's job is to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction The Miner who first solves
the person gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzle as I said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand Bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public Ledger it uses sha-256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
Bitcoin mining so distributed public
Ledger a distributed Ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by Bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secure they are
digitally signed then hash value once
generated cannot be altered now sat 256
it takes an input string of any size and
returns a fixed length 256 bit output
value and that is the primary feature of
sha 256 encryption algorithm you give
any input it will always always give you
a 256 bit output and it is a one-way
function you cannot derive the input
reversely from the output what you have
generated and third is the proof of work
in blockchain mining is a process to
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the miner is to
determine the nonce value and that nonce
value is that mathematical puzzle that
minus required to solve in order to
generate a hash Which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the Bitcoin
Network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying a
nonce which produces a hash value lower
than a predefined condition which is
called as a Target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 Bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the Bitcoins associate with
the transactions can be spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of Bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
Define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value Which is
less than the Target now let's check an
example so for example Beyonce wants to
share 10 Bitcoin with Jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so bronze transaction data is shared
with Bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block their remain in that
unconformed transaction pool now minus
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions they aggregate in a data
block and start validating they start
solving the puzzle The Miner who solves
the puzzle first shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners now once the block has been
verified the nonce has been generated
then the nodes will start granting their
approval if maximum nodes grant their
approval the block becomes valid and is
added to the blockchain now
simultaneously The Miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
Bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the Bitcoins the 10
BTC for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from Beyonds to
Jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for Block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash Target of
the first block divided by the hash
Target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have told the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash Target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as I said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of Bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of whatever the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks ABC Now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to Tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of Block B
will all get dealing because the
previous hash value of Block C will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the Block B which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of Block B which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying Hardware requirements for
Bitcoin mining and how the hardware has
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit CPUs now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as I said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so they've
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular CPUs so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any minus who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called Asic application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so miners are profitable when
their cost of resources to mine one
block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they own so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new Bitcoins are created
in the network so the Bitcoin total
Supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million Bitcoin
are in Supply 17 to 18 million Bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 Bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the Bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the Bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 Bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is Bitcoin mining pool Your Chance by
multiple lottery tickets and pool their
tickets together then this will increase
their probability and chances of winning
more so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed amongst all the participants
Bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to minor
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result the Bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
Bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the Bitcoin Network as you can
see this is a block and this is the
block reward 12.5 Bitcoin so this was a
block which was mined this is the block
number and these are the set of
transactions which were part of this
block now once this block was mined by
The Miner all these transactions then be
done these are the transfers of Bitcoin
from one account to the other this is
the nonce which was generated by The
Miner or the mining pool in order to
mind the block and these are the other
attributes
and if you take a look at this URL this
is an example of a mining pool it's a
demo account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have mine
ethereum and its Concepts
ethereum simply put while Bitcoin is
defined as digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime fraud
and third-party interference and also
has its own cryptocurrency called ether
ethereum aims to enable Innovations in
three key areas
currency Assurance through ether which
serves as an innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum the first feature
of ethereum is that it is secure because
it is almost impossible to tamper with
the transactions in the block or to add
any fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
Community following
ethereum has attracted a lot of
attention from people all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset a virtual share a proof of
membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast while Bitcoin requires a block time
of 10 minutes in ethereum it's only a
few seconds the last feature that we
will discuss is the fact that ethereum
is uncensored ethereum's open source
Network allows complete transparency to
view every transaction
all right that's all about the features
of ethereum let me tell you about an
important Concept in ethereum called gas
in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain it is the crypto fuel for
ethereum it can be considered a
transaction fee which has to be paid
when one party sends ethers to another
party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails gas price is expressed
in ether and the miner decides whether
to refuse the transaction process or not
based on the expected gas price one can
see their transaction fee in eth or USD
when searching for the transaction on
etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit the total cost of a transaction is
the product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single transaction
this avoids situations where there is an
error somewhere in the contract and you
end up spending a very high amount of
gas however the units of gas required
for a transaction are defined by the
amount of code executed on the
blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much if enough
gas to cover the computational resources
of the network is not supplied with the
transaction the transaction will fail
due to an out of gas error SO gas is a
commodity which is essentially a cost of
using the system
like Bitcoins ethereum also has its
currency which is called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations it ensures that the
developers write error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost ethereum is a blockchain based
platform and ether is the cryptocurrency
that fuels the platform it is commonly
denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between Bitcoin and ether
Bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is in the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies while
Bitcoin uses
sha-256 to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses ethash to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
Bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier Bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services however ethereum being a
touring complete platform also supports
smart contracts and decentralized
applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies currently the
price of BTC is approximately 3 500 US
Dollars while that of eth is
approximately 100 US dollars
the market cap of BTC is almost six
times greater than that of BTC even
though eth has a higher circulating
Supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
BTC is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of BTC is
much slower than eth while btc's
transaction speed is measured in minutes
eth is just a few seconds
like Bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets let's understand
what our wallets in ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies basically a wallet
stores the means of accessing your
currency using the private key
now that I have told you about the
ethereum and its currency it will only
be fair that I explain evm now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm is an engine which executes
translation code
smart contracts are compiled into byte
code which an evm can read and execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi-turing complete
machine it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm bytecode
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm bytecode
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of five eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in
ethereum-specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm byte code and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity solidity
is an object-oriented high-level
language used for implementation of
smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
solidity was influenced by python C plus
plus and JavaScript
it is designed to Target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like language
abbreviated as Triple L it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is Viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is Mouton Mouton is
similar to C like language and supports
a dynamic full higher level language it
compiles to Native ethereum assembler
however Mouton is now deprecated
the last language is Julia it is an
intermediate language that can compile
to various different backends like evm
1.0 evm 1.5 and e w ASM let me now tell
you about the accounts handled by
ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts eoa is an
account controlled by a private key that
has the ability to send ethers and
messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no Associated code
smart contract smart contract is a code
running on top of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other as an account it has the
following properties firstly it has an
ether balance
secondly it has an Associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts and fourthly when
executed it performs operations of
arbitrary complexity some of the
advantages of smart contracts are as
follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes and lastly it lowers
the transaction cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing they operate autonomously
to execute the terms of the contract and
verify the transactions without the need
of a third-party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant process
of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works first an optional
contract between the parties is written
as a code into the blockchain the
individuals involved are Anonymous but
the contact is made through a public
Ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike prices hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next Regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract thus
the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes Undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce in an externally owned account
nonce represents the number of
transactions sent from the account's
address however in a contract account
the nonce is the number of contracts
created by the account
the next property is balance this number
shows the amount of whey owned by the
address whether the eoa or contract
account each ether is divided into one e
plus 18 Wei the next property is code
hash it is the hash of the ethereum
virtual machine code of an account this
is the code that gets executed if this
address receives a message call it is
immutable and thus it cannot be changed
once the construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string for contract accounts this is the
code that gets hashed and is stored as
the code hash the last property is
storage root it is a 256 bit hash of the
root node of a Merkle tree that encodes
the storage contents of the account
encoded into the tree as a mapping from
the keycac
256-bit hash of the 256-bit integer keys
to the rlp encoded
256-bit integer values this tree encodes
the hash of the storage contents of this
account and is empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts let's understand the
process of mining now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining ethereum makes use of
proof of work mechanism to ensure
security the algorithm used in ethereum
is called ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a minor is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where Bob
wants to send one eth to Alice
now we would take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining first Bob attempts to
send Alice one eth once Bob's
transaction is initiated it is combined
with other transactions that have
occurred in the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated The Miner creates a new
block and is rewarded for it
thus Alice receives one eth after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
The Ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 each to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next date for the transaction
State Storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes State routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system State when
the block was created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process to see how ethereum
stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair this way the
last remaining hash becomes the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three Merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state to maintain
the transactions and to maintain the
receipts also each block always refers
to its previous Block's hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools the ethereum
ecosystem consists of eight major tools
they are Geth ganache
parody
metamask
Ed wallet
swarm
ipfs
whisper
now let's move forward and take a look
at each of these in detail
gef
is a multi-purpose command line tool
that runs an ethereum node implemented
in go
it is the official golang implementation
of the ethereum protocol and is commonly
used to interact with the ethereum
network
though there are several ways to
download GIF the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache CLI
ganache CLI
ganache CLI is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost thirdly
accounts can be recycled reset and
instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and Mining speed can
be modified fifthly a convenient GUI
gives you an overview of your test chain
events
parody parity is the fastest lightest
and most secure ethereum client that
provides the core infrastructure
Essentials for quick and reliable
services
parity is written in Rust language it
offers better reliability code Clarity
and performance it is an ethereum client
that is integrated directly into your
web browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an ethereum GUI
browser it provides access to a diverse
range of ethereum features including D
apps
metamask
metamask turns Google Chrome into a
browser that allows the users to send
and receive transactions and also fetch
data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plugin to your Chrome
browser it permits you to run ethereum D
apps directly from your browser without
the need for running a full ethereum
node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain to
overcome this metamask hosts a number of
nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install a
metamask and can automatically get
connected to the nodes thus you can use
the ethereum blockchain seamlessly
let's talk Mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
missed wallet
missed wallet is the end user interface
for ethereum that is developed for
browsing and using d-apps mist is an
official ethereum wallet it was
developed and distributed by the team
which is responsible for the management
of ethereum ecosystem it is usually used
by developers who want to create deploy
and use Smart contracts it is a full
node wallet which means you'll have to
download the entire ethereum blockchain
onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second storing ether
third creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services it acts as a
native base layer service of the
ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
Records to distribute blockchain data as
well as the app codes it leverages the
underlying ethereum infrastructure
through the use of contracts in ethers
to encourage cooperation among nodes the
files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micro payments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs stores data by use of a distributed
hash table or DHT once we know the hash
we request the peer Network who has a
copy of the content located at the
corresponding hash and then we download
the content from the node who has the
desired data which we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in BitTorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time thus it defines how
files move across a network making it a
distributed file system by combining all
of these properties
ipfs is enabling a new permanent web and
augmenting the way we use existing
internet protocols like http
whisper whisper is an identity-based
communication protocol for D apps to
interact with each other
d-apps that need to publish small
amounts of information to each other and
have the publication last some
substantial amount of time prefer using
whisper
for instance a d app running a currency
exchange may use whisper to record an
offer to buy a currency at a pre-agreed
price on the exchange platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows it has low level API which is
only exposed to D apps and never to
users second it has low bandwidth and is
not designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency and
lastly it has no reliable methods for
tracing packets
ethereum Frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
Frameworks
web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node it can be done with
the use of IPC or an HTTP connection the
key connection between ethereum Network
and dap that allows you to compile
deploy and interact with smart contracts
is called web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain let's take an example of
traditional development when you develop
a website it talks to apis using Json or
jQuery to make Ajax calls a website
talks to blockchain using web 3 using
json.rpc which is similar to making a
remote procedure call ethereum comprises
of a large number of nodes which talk to
each other we use Json RPC to make a
request to a particular node which is
like an API call thus if we want to talk
to a Smart contract or read an account
we do it through web3
eth.js it is a highly optimized
lightweight JS utility for ethereum
based on web.js in this all the
unnecessary characters are removed from
the source code and the code is reduced
to 160 kilobytes ethereum development
environment the three commonly used
ethereum development environments
include remix IDE truffle and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail
remix IDE remix IDE is a browser-based
compiler and IDE that enables users to
debug transactions and build ethereum
contracts with solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code the next slide shows how
remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle truffle is a development
environment testing framework and asset
pipeline for blockchains using the
ethereum virtual machine or evm it helps
users in developing smart contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications it performs
the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts third managing the complex
systems of interdependent contracts
fourth performing test driven deployment
with contracts using JavaScript
fifth managing different chains like
testnet private net and livenet and
lastly redeploy the contracts if any
changes are done let's talk about
ethereum Networks
ethereum Network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network they are
also referred to as clients they provide
wallet functionality and allow users to
perform transactions on the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
type sub Network there are three main
types of networks the test net the
mainnet and the private Network
ethereum d-apps and daos
D out
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure they run on a
peer-to-peer computer network all the
activity which takes place on an
ethereum decentralized application is
cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
Network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third-party intervention and high
security
example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain and 4G Capital these companies
have developed different applications
using blockchain
next we have the daos
d-a-o
daos or organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a Dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works
let's consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system
a Dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way in this video we will
explore ethereum Mining and we'll go
through some of the fascinating Concepts
and confidence revolving around it
to pay him as defined as a
blockchain-based Computing platform that
enables its developers to build and
deploy decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
ether is the cryptography of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it traps and
facilitates all the transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof of work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the minor
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script ethash to solve
computationally hard puzzles of
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions in the ethereum blocks in
network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why you need to
mine ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a data mining tone factors
ignoring the network enjoy relatively
complex but profitable business also
miners receive a certain amount as a
reward for money in each block of the
ethereum proxy Network including the
transaction fees paid by the users thus
it is a mining benefits each and
everyone participating in Italian
blockchain Network
foreign mining
the parent mining can be performed in
three ways the time in Solo mining
lithium pool Mining and Italian Cloud
mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine the Italian block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also so mining is only profitable when
you have plenty of resources with you
like 100 plus graphics card
and in Solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of area needed
a dragon pool mining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with Terraria
mining in this you walk along with other
people together in a single pool and hit
someone from the pool get the hash code
correctly they share the reward among
everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool like
Google size minimum payout and Tool fee
full size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares the word
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get reward okay fees
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
Italian you need to mine before it gets
credit to the wallet and 40 is the
amount you need to pay to continue using
the pool this amount is percentage based
on the amount of ethereum the mining
it's having Cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you you pay some amount of money as
ease to them for investing their time
and resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward the gain by the mining materials
thus this technique of mining ethereum
has to close and cons too so you're not
responsible for any equipment damage you
don't have to acquire all the necessary
equipment and look for ample space to
store it
you can set back of the market and enjoy
the reward for investment in their
mining
corn in the ethereum price drop then
there is no way you are getting the
money back the money you invested or the
fees pay to The Miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
material Cloud money is considered a
safer vehicle mining service provider
the guarantee a profit for the resource
they have purchased
let us understand how the ethereum
mining process works
to create a mining follows a specific
set of steps to function
Step 1 a user requests for transaction
with the help of the private key of its
digital Wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 The Miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transactional data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified and it stores a copy of it in
helium the process of full form work
Begins for the respective block
step 6 when the notes of the ethereum
network verify are the checksum of the
state of the minus Block matches the
checksum of the updated state of events
after execution of all transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the ethereum blockchain network
step in on successfully mining the blog
it rewards The Miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet the block reward
of ethereum is three ether
and step 9 the requested transaction is
approved and credited to the respective
wallet or wallet
which transaction is mined only one with
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be a sufficient
Miner for ethereum on your personal
computer art and attack a wallet to
store all your currency on
GPU drivers or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb RAM
a mining software suitable according to
your Hardware like GPU
and a compatible operating system the
Windows 7 or 10 with 604 bit
before getting started with mining
Italian you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your info press the
Model T and Ledger Nano are the most
reliable and secure one in the market of
cryptocurrency
installing GPU drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet the
need to update all the hardware
that is drives in a system you can use
two types of graphics card they are AMD
graphics card and Nvidia graphics card
Claymore is considered the best soft
vessel mining ethereum on G3 drivers
now we need to follow a few set of step
to get started with mining
step one download the latest version of
play mode dual Miner for the operating
system the latest version is Claymore
11.0
Step 2 click on the latest version of
Windows and download the zip file
step three extract the file to Claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5 right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6 edit the start.exe file and add
these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better Source results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your full address instead
of mining pool address
step 9 say if you start the txt file
within new updates remember while saving
select type as all files
have set 10 once you see click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
State transition field group of work
the newly introduced concepts of
ethereum 2.0 the roadmap plans to
upgrade to group of states consensus
algorithm in which it will provide all
existing miners with ethereum network
with a limited time to earn a return for
the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021 or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
October 2020 with the history of delays
regarding this upgrade is worth talking
about
nobody could know when I tell him 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now we may know all about ethereum
mining this makes me wonder if Italian
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area
as a rule anything below
0.12 dollar per kilowatt consumes in an
hour is considered profitable you can
mind either and turn it into a vital
source of income by analyzing these
figures like hash rate of ethereum block
reward number of blocks per day and the
coin price of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors or you can use this
formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and save an ethereum now why smart
contract now let's take a look
traditionally how contracts used to
happen if suppose two parties A and B
have to get into a contract they will
utilize the services of a third party
whom they have to trust and get the
contract executed now with the
introduction of smart contracts and the
technology which is evolving removes the
dependency on such third parties and
automates the execution of such smart
contracts so if we compare traditional
versus the new smart contract in
traditional we used to have governments
lawyers or any other third party on
which we can trust in smart contracts we
don't need any third party we don't need
any intermediate execution time
definitely there is higher execution
time in traditional contracts because as
many number of middlemen's and their
intermediary years that many number of
days and time it takes smart contract is
just a matter of minutes it gets
executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined condition
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it's
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional Contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre-embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
credited automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency
is not available 100 in traditional
contracts the transparency is bound
peripheral between the parties and the
entities and the intermediaries involved
as compared to Smart contract
transparency is 100 available 24x7
online anyone can go and review audit
and validate the transactions executed
by the smart contracts archiving
archiving is a big difficult problem for
traditional contracts as most of the
transactions are paper-based or the
records are maintained offline it
becomes very difficult to maintain and
identify the traceability provenance of
all the transactions which have happened
in a traditional contract whereby in a
smart contract it becomes easy as all
the transactions have happened through
the smart contract there's a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till present day And
archiving is automatically happening the
log the audit the transaction history is
automatic vertically getting generated
security definitely is a concern in
traditional contracts as the
intermediaries and involved manual
processes involved security can be
compromised at any level at any stage
but in a smart contract the security is
maintained through cryptography mainly
through public key infrastructure the
public and private key infrastructure it
is a very secure way of maintaining
security and cryptography of the
transactions using a smart contract cost
yes traditional contracts are expensive
the cost of transaction is high as
compared to Smart contracts as the
middlemans are involved smart contract
the cost is low as we don't have any
intermediaries and only the cost of
transaction is charged by the underlying
infrastructure of the blockchain network
which is running the smart contract
signatures its manual process all the
transactions are signed manually and
verified manually but here in the smart
contracts all the transactions are
digitally signed using the private key
of the entities and can only be decoded
by the public key shared by the parties
involved in the smart contract so in a
nutshell smart contracts give us n
number of advantages the primary
advantages are listed here and these are
the advantages which enforce us to move
towards an economy and to a system where
we start using smart contracts for our
transactions to avoid any disputes to
keep the transaction costs low thereby
giving the advantage to the end consumer
now what is a smart contract let's
consider a real life example where you
are taking out a chocolate from a
vending machine you deposit a two dollar
note in a vending machine after that you
hit A1 button which is mapped against
the chocolate bar that you want to buy
as a result a lever in a vending machine
moves and pushes out the chocolate so
basically even button is programmed to
the lever in order to move the chocolate
out now a smart contract is very similar
to a vending machine it eliminates the
need of an intermediary in case of the
vending machine is replacing a direct
seller and allowing you to make a
purchase without a middleman and it only
minutes in need of Escrow Services now
smart contracts are self-executing
contract which contain the terms and
conditions of an agreement between the
parties and the peers who are involved
in the beginning so the terms and
conditions of an agreement are written
in a piece of code and it is executed on
a blockchain based decentralized
platform now these agreements
facilitates exchange of any digital
asset it could be digital currency it
could be shares it could be property or
it could be anything which you want to
transact so a blockchain based
decentralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept Anonymous now
let's consider an example where Rachel
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to Rachel as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flight's
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and it's
monitoring the flight's delay Rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above x
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get that trigger and
ritual will be credited with that amount
for which she is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so AXA flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
ethereum smart contract AXA is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
Beyond two hours then the insurance
contract will get executed and Rachel
will get paid so a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delay is less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain network to their EVMS
for evaluation so evm is a runtime
compiler to execute smart contracts code
it is the brain it is the electronic
virtual machine which executes the smart
contract all nodes on the network
executing the code using the evm must
come to the same result because all the
EVMS would have the same copy of the
smart contract deployed so if the flight
is delayed two or more hours smart
contract will be self-executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
Rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middleman paperwork which ritual has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company May going through the manual
process all that has been bypassed and
ritual has been compensated directly now
let's understand why do we need solidity
for developing our smart contracts now
here comes the important question which
programming language does us not
contract use there are two widely used
programming languages for writings
Italian smart contracts solidity and
serpent however on blockchain platforms
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we are
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides now solidity is a high level
programming language used for
implementing smart contracts it enables
to check the program at runtime rather
than compile time solidity is a touring
complete language it has all the
conditions all the while Loops for Rook
operators
Etc which are there in any matured
programming language in order to write
your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain Loop if
you have while conditions Etc now what
are the advantages of smart contract as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediaries involved the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's a high
speed highly computive smart contracts
which runs on programming code the speed
of its execution is higher than a
traditional contract as the data is
stored in the decentralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and I would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirements terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
network through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
blockchain in voting process can
eliminate voting malpractices a
centralized voting system faces a lot of
problems when it comes to tracking votes
there could be manipulated identities
they could be manipulation in counting
there could be biased decision making a
smart contract is introduced to
eliminate all these malpractices there
are certain predefined terms and
conditions which are already set in the
contract no voter can vote from a
digital identity of any other voter the
counting is full proof every vote is
registered on a blockchain network and
the accounting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each ID should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the blockchain network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous organization
based blockchain setup also but it is
100 transparent and every voting
transaction is recorded result every
voters won't get recorded on The Ledger
and that information cannot be modified
it is transparently publicly available
for audit and verification now let's
take a look at one of the examples of
our voting solidity contract so here we
have our voting solidity contract it is
built in solidity and I'll just give you
a brief overview of what are the primary
functions in this so if we look at this
particular contract this contract gives
you certain basic parameters like what
should be the minimum number of
participants or proposals which are
required for voting then what should be
the minimum amount of time for debate
that needs to pass before the vote can
be executed then the margin of votes for
majority a proposal passes if there are
more than 50 of the votes plus the
margin so basically we are defining what
is the winning condition what is the
majority margin for any word to be
accepted then you you have data
structure where you are accepting the
proposals right and then subsequently we
are defining data structures for members
who are participating in the proposals
who are submitting the proposals we are
fetching the addresses of the members
basically this is the digital identity
of the members who are submitting the
proposals and Etc so this smart
contracts basically allows you to create
a voting system where you can add
members we can remove the members you
can change certain voting rules based on
certain conditions like if you want to
increase the minimum Forum if you want
to change the debating period minutes or
the majority rule changes then this is a
function for submitting a new proposal
for which the voting has to happen so
basically this example is about if I
have to take a vote within a
decentralized autonomous Organization
for a particular decision so rather than
a central Authority taking a decision
you can have a voting mechanism within
your organization to give a majority to
your proposal if you get them majority
The Proposal is accepted otherwise
reject then there are peripheral
functions like check proposal code then
there is a voting function the actual
vote happens and for a particular
proposal you start increasing or
decreasing the number of votes then you
execute the proposal if the majority has
been achieved now let's take a look on
how to deploy a smart contract so here
we have our voting smart contract now we
will take a look on how to deploy our
voting smart contract on the ethereum
test Network called robston this is our
voting smart contract now when you open
remix you should also have metamask
which is a chrome plugin installed this
is a utility in order to connect to the
robsten test net which is a ethereum
test Network so basically you say
robson.etherscan.io and this is the
ethereum test Network on which we will
deploy our contract so once you log in
into the metamask you will have a
account created and in that account you
should have some test ethers already so
that you can use them to deploy a
contract so when you create an account
on robsten you can buy certain ethers
using the robsten test faucet
so when you reach this site the option
test faucet is already taken the address
for the account for which you are
raising the request and you can raise
request of one ether now whenever this
transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as I already have ethers in it I
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract I have copy pasted it here and
if I go to my run My remix has already
communicated via injected web3 to the
metamask and take in my account which
has 7.83 ether
now I need to do some settings
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and Congress is my
major contract now I will deploy my
contract so on the Run section you will
be able to see in the drop down the name
of the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like I had owned token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a congress so I need to deploy
my Congress contract now in order to
deploy this contract there is a
Constructor which requires certain
inputs so I can give certain values like
what minimum number of proposals I need
800 then minimum number of debates 10
and margin of votes for majority so I
say deploy now as soon as I'll click
deploy it is going to request me for gas
because when the contract gets deployed
it will deduct certain ethers from my
account so when I'll say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the robsten
etherscan.io I click on it so this is
the transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
ethereum network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
created and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0xcc I can load it now this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option ether scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish your
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your metamask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we opened here
now after you have deployed the contract
you can interact with your contract
directly through remix just to test your
contract all the pink members are the
ones which make changes onto the
blockchain and all the blue ones are the
ones which are only performing read
operations so in order to do any read
operation you will not be requested to
spend any gas so there will be no
pop-ups for metamask requesting for gas
spending but if you do any of these pink
actions then you will be required to
spend gas as it will be requiring to
make some changes onto the block
watching so this was a example of a
voting smart contract and this will be
available as a link for you to take a
look now all our other contracts which
we will be covering subsequently will be
deployed in a similar Fashion on the
Robson test net now let's check another
example if you want to use Smart
contract to issue your own
cryptocurrency or called digital token
you can use ethereum based smart
contract to create your own digital
tokens for performing transactions in
design and issue your own digital
currency create a tradable computerized
token that can be utilized as a currency
share or any asset which you want to
transact these tokens use the standard
coin API like in case of ethereum we
have standardizations of erc20 Etc which
allows contract to automatically access
any wallet for exchange as a result you
build a tradable token with a suffix
Supply and this particular platform
becomes like a central bank issuing a
digital money your smart contract
becomes the bank issuing the money so
let's take this example here so this is
a implementation of a erc20 token which
is a specification by ethereum and uh
the primary attribute for this token is
that you need to provide a name of your
token a symbol the decimals to which you
support and the most primary is the
predefined supply so just like in an
economy you have limited supply of money
here also you have to Define what will
be the supply of your tokens and it will
be capped that will be the supply so you
need to redefine these parameters and
then you create certain data structures
within solidity to keep a tap on the
balances of the entities to which you
are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep per address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the erc20
specification like transfer transfer
from from approve and Call Etc so all
these methods in a typical token allows
you to do the transaction send and
receive your custom token among multiple
parties so this would also be available
as a link for you to take a look now
let's take another example of a use case
for crowdfunding using smart contracts
to crowdfund your project so suppose you
want to start a business and for a
business you need a lot of funding which
is required but who would lend it money
to someone whom they don't trust how
will you generate that money for such
problems smart contract plays a major
role with ethereum you can build a smart
contract that will hold a contributor's
fronts unless a given date or a goal is
met based on the result the funds will
be released to the contract owners or
will be sent back to the contributors so
basically you can create a crowdfunding
project for yourself if you want to
raise certain amount of money and the
contributors or the investors will give
you the money but the amount will be
kept on hold till the time your project
goal our date has been met and
accordingly the investor will get you
the token which you have developed for
crowdfunding in hers or his account
accordingly now centralized crowdfunding
system has plenty of issues with
Management Systems so therefore a dow a
decentralized autonomous organization is
utilized for crowdfunding the terms and
conditions are transparently set in the
contract every individual participating
in the crowd funding is given a token
and the token is credited to their
ethereum based account now every
contribution gets recorded on the
blockchain because then the token
transfer has happened from the Dow to
the individual investor that transaction
get recorded on the blockchain network
so let's quickly take a look at the
contract for a crowd sale also so a
crowd sale contract provides you the
basic attributes like what is the goal
of the funding how much money you need
to raise what is the amount raised
real-time time you can keep a track what
is the deadline right and what is the
price of the token in ethereum basically
what is the your token amount in
ethereum then there could be that you
might give certain tokens in reward then
you can have attributes for your reward
and then you have your methods in order
to keep a check that once you have
received the funds you can withdraw the
funds you can check whether you have
reached the goal for funding and then
you have the methods for transferring
tokens from the sender to your own
account this particular kind of contract
allows you to maintain and keep a check
on amount of funding you have received
or you want to receive have you achieved
your target who are the investors in
your token how much percentage share
belongs to your account and how much
percentage share has been already been
distributed all amongst the investors
Etc so everything can be tracked so
their smart contract can build in such a
fashion that there are methods and
utilities available in order to run your
entire crowdfunding in this video we
will explore ethereum 2.0 and we'll go
through some of the fascinating Concepts
and components revolving around it
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy the
centralized application
either is the cryptocurrency for
ethereum used to build decentralized
application smart contracts and make
standard peer-to-peer payments it tracks
and facilitates all the transactions and
makes sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
the what led to the origin of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions currently it is capable
of handling 15 to 45 transactions per
second which is comparatively impressive
but it is not enough to handle all of
Italian's users worldwide also the high
demand is affecting the driving up of
transaction fees
notes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.2
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of state and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work to record and
invalidate their transactions
the problems with proof of Works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain undergoes verification by all
participating nodes that means now the
speed of its fluids participant limits
the processing speed of the entire
network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the Network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient than its upgraded version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
like ethereum 2.2 has been in research
and development since 2014. it has
actually been making some progress the
bacon chain went live in December 2020
introducing this taking concept but
still there is no official claim for the
completion of this transition
the next pace is minute
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum Network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increase transactions per
second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way to completing
the whole trans session so what is the
future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total Game
Changer it will create a modified
Network that could potentially process
one lakh transactions per second
and a much more sustainable Network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide increasing the
ethereum's network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
Alec buterin once said that the issuance
of new doku should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain Network did you know
there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide
and among them Bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
Bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide Trading
according to decrypt.com any day new
companies like me to and PayPal are
coming forward to invest in Bitcoin and
ethereum on March 7 2021 need to
confirmed that it had purchased 40
million in Bitcoin and ethereum on the
other hand PayPal is about to launch a
scheme with the public in purchase and
sell cryptocurrencies initially
featuring Bitcoin and ethereum via
Paypal digital wallet but have you all
ever wondered how they compare based on
their similarities and differences in
various aspects well before moving any
further let's have a quick look at how
Bitcoin and ethereum originated and made
a benchmark in the economic system
worldwide
Bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
Satoshi Nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after Bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
they tell themselves as a Computing
platform that enables its developers to
build and deploy their decentralized
application now let's move ahead and see
the difference between them which make
them compete with each other in this
economy this video will cover individual
aspects for comparing ethereum and
bitcoin's performance in that particular
field
by time Bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
Bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts and
application for its users without any
centralized interference for Bitcoin it
is an alternative to Fiat money or
physical currency the main function of
ethereum is to provide its users or
developers with a platform to build
smart contracts using daps or
decentralized application
on the other side Bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain Network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the ethash cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
Bitcoin uses the sag-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
Bitcoin Network
algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy a certain Network requirements
sat 256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private Keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum and Bitcoin
ethereum uses solidity solidity is a
high level programming language used by
ethereum for implementing smart
contracts but in terms of programming
language Bitcoin keeps it simple Bitcoin
uses C plus plus as its programming
language it is a stamp based programming
language used to give Bitcoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both mining is
a process in which transaction made are
validated and added to blockchain public
Ledger and blocks and the people mining
these blocks are called miners a theory
mine is mine the unvalidated transaction
using the proof of work method but it
aims to switch to proof of State because
it will make its Network more immune to
centralization energy efficient and
stronger support for its shared chain on
the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the proof of
work method to mine unvalidated
transactions these method is enough to
function in Bitcoin Network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies but
let's first understand what monetary
policy is monetary policy is known as
the process of drafting announcing and
implementing the plan of actions taken
by the competing monetary authority to
control the money supply and Achieve
goals that promote sustainable economic
growth so ethereum's policy is defined
by the reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises of
two parts having and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining Bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of Bitcoins
you get if you successfully mine a
blockchain block the current block
reward for ethereum is to either per
block and for Bitcoin the block reward
is 12.5 Bitcoins per block also every 14
seconds a block of ethereum is generated
and one block of Bitcoin take 10 minutes
to generate monetary policies are
considered to be fixed and
non-inflationary due to this over time
mining blocks will become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
Bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and Bitcoin is only
used as the value for real world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and Google pay a determine Bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption now talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies ethereum is not limited
but it can occasionally reduce due to
large Network upgrades however Bitcoin
is limited to 21 million coins and as of
today 18 million Bitcoin is already used
but in the end both Bitcoin and ethereum
being the top cryptocurrencies share a
few similarities like both a decent
mentalized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction proof of work
also both have a large network of
independent nodes choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's have a demo now
in detail coinless is a site specialized
in digital currencies it is used to
explore the news and price data related
to cryptocurrencies and also explains
how cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration this graph shows the gradual
change in the price of Bitcoin it
started from 64
439.29 on April 14 at 12 pm and right
now by April 15 at 6 00 am it is at
63189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
which shows the change in the price of
Bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2. the value of ethereum
started at
2388.13 dollars on April 14 at 12 pm and
the current status on April 15 is
positive with a value of
2442.37 when an increasing rate of 4.67
down below we have a metrics table that
shows the change between the starting
and ending value of ethereum the total
supply of a cryptocurrency in 24 hours
the total number of transactions that
occurred and the average transaction fee
for all these transactions now this
graph shows the current status of
cryptocurrency in USD dollars we can
also see its value according to any
centralized currency like Euro or INR
this graph shows the concentrating
change in the value of cryptocurrencies
every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an R to its lifetime recently we
all have been hearing about the
cryptocurrency famously known as
Dogecoin but what exactly makes it so
different from others that almost every
person is talking about it
so let me tell you that Dogecoin is an
altcoin and an almost sarcastic mean
coin that serves as a peer-to-peer open
source cryptocurrency well that's not
enough
so let's dive down and understand the
concept of Dogecoin more precisely but
before starting let's have a look at why
is it in the news since the beginning of
the year 2021 Dogecoin has surged more
than 950 percent from less than half a
penny to more than 5 cents per Dogecoin
then Elon Musk CEO of test line
corporation took his interest in it and
tweeted too much concentration is the
only real issue but cryptocurrency
making the owner of the Dogecoin wallet
a subject of attention later on are the
celebs like Snoop Dogg also started
taking an interest in Dogecoin and
started tweeting and promoting it on
social platforms which made Dogecoin
climb to a peak of 8.2 us cents and
market capitalization of 10 billion
dollars in this video we will come
across the following topics first we
will see the origin of Dogecoin and then
we will understand what is Dogecoin how
does it exactly work
and then we will see what led to the
growth of Dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of Dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of those going today
and lastly how can we buy it
start with the origin of Dogecoin
Dogecoin was invented by two software
Engineers IBM engineer Billy Marcus and
Adobe engineer Jackson farmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the Year 2013 Bitcoin and
Deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is Dogecoin Dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meat coin inspired by Shiba inu's
popular meme AKA Doge moving ahead let's
have a look at how it works to
understand the workflow let's take the
example of two friends Mark and Susan
Mark owes samani to Susan and now he
needs to return it
he thinks of an idea and decides to send
her Dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital Wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information first his private key and
second her public key
to get access to Susan's private key he
needs to scan a QR code from his
smartphone
then the application alerts all the
Dogecoin miners around the world to
proceed further with the process the
Dogecoin miners validate where the Mark
has enough Dogecoin to make the payment
or not and after the validation process
they approve the transaction request
Dogecoin miners race with each other to
collect all the data of the pending
transaction known as the nons
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for that particular nodes of the
pending transaction The Miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 Dogecoin in
his account
after that Mark and Susan gets a
confirmation message that the request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of Dogecoin is credited into the
one of the Susan thus the transaction is
completed so what led to the growth of
Dogecoin Dogecoin officially Came live
in 2013 and became an instant hit within
the community of people who just wanted
to play around the cryptocurrencies
freely
as I said earlier Dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for Content creators but
they were very well received it uses of
Internet forums like Reddit and Twitter
adopted Dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
Dogecoin made it surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically Bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000 for a NASCAR driver Josh
Weiss and in return he printed the logo
m98 Dodge Coin over this race car
eventually it almost became the mascot
for what crypto should be let's have a
look at who uses Dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants crosses web hosting products
retailer ebook Sellers and travel
Services uses Dogecoin for transaction
these are a few example of companies in
every sector that uses Dogecoin grossers
hello pets gamerheats.com for web
hosting
gamer for products retailer meltdown and
nordx ebook seller canal and travel
services like Velo leo.it this makes me
curious about the current value of
Dogecoin let's have a look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is
0.059357 USD with a trading volume of 16
billion dollars the circulating supply
of this cryptocurrency is 129 billion
Dogecoin and the max supply of Dogecoin
is not available
how can we buy Dogecoin
so to buy Dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps Step One open a
digital wallet buy you coin is
considered a perfect application for
trading cryptocurrencies Step 2 register
your account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhar card step 4 add your
bank account details step 5 secure your
account by creating a convenient trading
pin that is only accessible by you
and step 6
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about Dogecoin currently we
have heard a lot of Buzz about the
cryptocurrency Dogecoin and the
shenanigans of its community
did you know that on 20th April 2020
Dogecoin searched its value to one
dollar making this day named after
itself as doste the supporters of
Dogecoin were trying to amplify the
value of it to make it one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency well all this is done by
a process called mining and this is what
affected torch coin resulting in the
rise of its value
mining coins of the Dogecoin network is
called Dogecoin mining
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is Dogecoin
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology also it provides its users a
completely unknown decentralized and
secure environment free from any
third-party interference to make their
transactions
to secure all its transactions this
makes me curious to know what is a net
worth and availability of those coin
today
according to market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is
0.266 247 USD dollars the circulating
supply of this cryptocurrency is one
traditions for mining Dogecoin that
makes me wonder what the difference
between Dogecoin Mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining process
let's have a comparison between Dogecoin
Mining and the Bitcoin mining process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors first
algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm Dogecoin mining uses
script Bitcoin mining uses sh-256
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the SSG 256 algorithm
making mining easier for miners of the
Dogecoin Network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty Dogecoin is
2798
252 Bitcoin is 3 trillion 511 billion 60
million
552
899 thus the crews that Dogecoin is easy
to mine among other cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is a Time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
Dogecoin is one minute for Bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at fourth and fifth we have reward
per block and per block USD
it is the amount
in USD to The Miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for Dogecoin is 10 000
dogecoins per block which in USD is
27.36 dogecoins for Bitcoin it is 12.5
Bitcoin per block and in USD it is 86
391.63 Bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine Dogecoin
Dogecoin can be mine in two ways the
first one Dogecoin pool Mining and the
second is solo mining
a Dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
Dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of Mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between Dogecoin pool Mining
and solo mining
in Dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees in Dogecoin
solo mining you don't need to pay any
fees and you're mine all by yourself
also in pool mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the poor
one button solo mining the total reward
earned will be received by you only
as in pole mining many people work
together so the Mind blocks more often
and on the other side solar mining could
take a lot of time before one mine their
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in Solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about Dogecoin pool
Mining and solo mining let's proceed
further and see what we need to start
mining Dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us a PC with any operating system
like Windows Linux Ubuntu Etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the
dogecoins you mind which hardware and
software can we use for Dogecoin mining
you will need your PC CPU which should
be powerful enough to mine Dogecoin a
GPU a graphics card can also be used for
mining Dogecoin for example Sapphire
pulse Radeon RX 580 Asus RX Vega 64 and
many more
stripped Asic minor is programmed to
minescript-based cryptocurrencies like
Dogecoin like bitmain and minor L3
bwl21 script Miner Etc
if you are new to Dogecoin mining then
using your PC CPU will be the right
choice and CPU minus the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using GPU
or graphics card you can have a wide
range of software
some of the best software is kudamina
which works perfectly with Nvidia
products CG Miner which works with most
GPU hardware and easy Miner is
considered suitable for beginners
script Asic miners are considered to be
very powerful hardware and multi-miner
is excellent with this Hardware moving
ahead let's understand what those coin
Cloud mining is
going Cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine Dogecoin using vented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in Dogecoin mining at a very
low cost making Dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the Dogecoin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance a direct energy cost
this whole concept of Dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
this dot coin Mining Profitable
those coin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumptions
hash rate and cost the Dogecoin mining
calculator is used to make it simple in
this calculator
the default value for the latest
Dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
Dogecoin difficulty Target is pre-loaded
for better results Dodge Coin mining's
reward is
44 lakh 44
412.25 dollars per year that is 14
million dollars per year the block time
for Dogecoin is one minute which means
the supply of Dogecoin will never go
down
after deducting mining power costs and
Mining fees the final daily dose coin
mining profit is 22.53 Dogecoin to USD
with the profit margin of positive 81.72
percent also I think Dogecoin mining is
fun so that brings us to what is
Dogecoin wallet
a Dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a real
life wallet Dogecoin wallet consists of
its public and private key connecting it
to the distributed Ledger over the
Dogecoin Network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
Dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user the private key of
your wallet is used to approve
transactions in The Ledger your wallet's
public key is used to receive dogecoins
from other users on the other hand your
wireless private key is only used to
send those points to other users in the
network so what are the types of
Dogecoin wallet
Dogecoin wallet is up two times digital
Dogecoin wallet and physical Dogecoin
wallet digital Dogecoin wallet is
accessible through the web and you can
also download it according to your
handset or operating system
on the other hand physical Dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible so moving on let's see how to
create a Dogecoin wallet
to create a Dogecoin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
Step 1 choose the correct volume
Dogecoin core followed and multi-toge
wallet have been created and are
maintained by the developers team of
Dogecoin
here we will be using the Dogecoin core
wallet as reference
Step 2 download and install the Dogecoin
wallet in your handset you can also use
the official website of this wallet for
your windows
and step 3 open the Dogecoin wallet
application and verify your Dogecoin
wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your Dogecoin wallet now when
you have your Dogecoin wallet in your
hand let's see how you can use it on the
very bottom of the home page of your
wallet there are two options request
coins where you can request those coins
from other users in the Dogecoin Network
and send coins where you can send those
coins to other users in the Dogecoin
Network to receive coins first click on
the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third
have the below generated barcode scanned
by the user you wish to request amount
now to send coins
first type the Dogecoin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now we can use your
Dogecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
Dogecoin so popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
Bitcoin Dogecoin has never missed an
opportunity to be in the Limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
Community other than that social
platforms like Reddit and Twitter also
promoted Dogecoin to a great extent due
to its fun fact though and the whole
joke story behind it
celebrities like Snoop Dogg Kevin Jonas
Elon Musk also started taking an
interest in Dogecoin and posting
pictures and comments on their social
media handles which increased The Craze
of Dogecoin all around the world so this
was all about Dogecoin wallet now let's
have a look at the top 5 Dogecoin
wallets of 2021. these are the top 5
Dogecoin wallets of 2021.
and Kraken
Kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a Dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it and it
accepts a pretty decent amount of Fiat
money in this video we will compare and
contrast Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
based on a few related Concepts around
these cryptocurrencies
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top
cryptocurrencies and will also let us
figure out the individuality of each one
of them
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by Shiva inu's
popular meme AKA Doge but it was very
well received by everyone in the crypto
world and today it is the fourth top
cryptocurrency
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
Bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013. Bitcoin enables
transparent and decentralized
peer-to-peer transaction
Bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to National currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
Ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum gave into the picture years
after Bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
it had himself as a Computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
daps or decentralized application
now let's move on the comparison between
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language
mining process
monetary policies
transactions
today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
Dogecoin uses stripped cryptography for
mining the blocks of the Dogecoin
Network in comparison Bitcoin uses the
sha-256 hashing algorithm for mining its
blocks in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses this
algorithm for mining its transactions
language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized Hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
sh-256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific Network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
Dogecoin is considered to be an all coin
for Bitcoin both Dogecoin and Bitcoin
use the same programming language
C plus plus it is a stack based
programming language used to give
Bitcoin and Dogecoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of these
cryptocurrency let's get to the
following very important parameter which
is mining process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is
mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public Ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
Dogecoin and Bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in the networks and that is
proof of work
although ethereum miners also mine the
unvalidated transactions using the
profile work method it aims to switch to
proof of stake
because it will make its Network more
immune to centralization energy
efficient and more vital support for
shared chains
now we have come to the following
present which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the compete
and monetary or authority to control the
money supply and Achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth
dogecoin's policy is defined by its
block reward paid to its miners whereas
Bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block report
having event is when reward of mining
Bitcoin is cut in half and it also cuts
the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
Bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each block and which is set to
get reduced to 6.25 by 2024
an ethereal's block reward is to ether
per block
Dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block Bitcoin takes 10 minutes to
generate one block
an ethereum generates one block every 14
seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary due to
this over time mining blocks will become
more complex
now moving on to the falling bearizon
which is transactions
Dogecoin is the fastest and can complete
70 transaction in one second and takes
just two to three minutes to confirm a
transaction
Bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second and takes 10
minutes or more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
Dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like Reddit and Twitter
Bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for Fiat money and is used
primarily for real world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
Networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of Dogecoin on today's date is
0.2992 dollars
Bitcoin being the highest is 34 857.58
and ethereum holds a value of
2356.58 dollars
now we have reached the last comparison
of Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of Dogecoin is
1.7 billion
Bitcoin very low as compared to Dogecoin
is just 21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion Dogecoin has
already been mined
for Bitcoin 18 million Bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this draft you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin on the
extreme left you can see first the
options that you can use according to
your requirements like if you want to
know about Dogecoin you can go for the
first option that is
www.dochcoin.com which will lead you to
the official website of Dogecoin if you
want to chat with the executives of coin
Market regarding Dogecoin then you can
go for the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform and
you can also change it according to your
choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Dogecoin which
is 38 billion thirty eight hundred forty
nine million
469 098
it is the total value of Dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 billion 700 million 795 906.
it is the capitalization when Max supply
of Dogecoin was in circulation and on
the right side just before total Supply
you can see the volume of Dogecoin one
billion 779 million
417 647.
it is the value of Dogecoin traded in 24
hours next is Bitcoin similar to
Dogecoin you can see the red box on the
right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
Bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www.bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of Bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Bitcoin which is
651 billion 713 million 10 000 753
is the total value of Bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization that
is 732 billion
387 million two hundred sixty two
thousand six hundred ninety
and on the right side just before the
total Supply you can see the volume of
Bitcoin that is 30 billion
249 million 939 865.
ethereum is no different from Dogecoin
and Bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.etherium.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is 273 billion
576 million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand Forty Nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is 24 billion 100 1 million seven
hundred seventy nine thousand three
hundred forty six but in the end all
these top cryptocurrencies Dogecoin
Bitcoin and ethereum share a few
similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized Authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all the
transactions are verified and validated
before processing after complete
verification further transaction process
takes place also all of them have a
large network of independent nodes let's
get started and understand what kind of
interview questions can come for a
blockchain interview so let's start with
certain beginner level questions now
when You Face a blockchain interview you
can get different variety of questions
so we will be covering that what kind of
questions can be asked at each level
intermediate and expert level so one of
the few questions which you could be
asked is what is the difference between
blockchain and hyperledger blockchain is
basically the underlying concept
blockchain is a decentralized technology
of immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography whereas
hyperledger is a platform or an
organization that allows people to build
private blockchain so basically
basically blockchain is a concept is a
technology using blockchain you can
build public and private blockchains but
hyperledger is a specific technology
which allows you to build only private
blockchains now blockchain is divided
into public private and Consortium
blockchains hyperledger is specifically
a private blockchain technology with
access to blockchain data is limited to
predefined users and it is defined using
certain configurations and programming
blockchain can be used in multiple
Fields like business governments
Healthcare other different kind of
domains and Etc hyperledger is primarily
used in blockchain for enterprise-based
Solutions so wherever we are talking
about public blockluctures like usage of
blockchain on internet and hyperledger
based blockchain Solutions are solutions
which are meant for intranet within an
organization within a corporation second
how do you explain blockchain technology
is someone who doesn't know it so
basically in Sim terms blockchain
technology is a distributed Ledger which
stores transaction details in the form
of immutable records non-modifiable
records which are called blocks which
are secured using cryptography so in
order to explain simplistically let's
consider an example of a school where
blockchain is similar to a digital
report card of a student now each block
contains students records which has a
label dating the date and time of when
the record was entered or when the
record was registered on the blockchain
now neither the teacher nor the student
can modify the details of the block
cannot modify the record of report cards
therefore the record becomes
non-modifiable immutable also the
teacher owns a private key that allows
him or her to make new records and the
student owns a public key to view and
access the report card at any time so
basically the teacher owns the right to
update the record but the student only
owns the right to view the record now
this method makes the data both actable
and secure and this is what blockchain
brings on the table these are the
primary attributes for which blockchain
is getting widely adopted to have
immutable records available for view to
the public and available for updating in
an untemperable way now what is a Merkel
tree Merkel tree is a data structure
which is used for verifying a block it
is in a form of a binary tree containing
cryptographic hashes of each block so
basically a Merkel tree is structured
similar to a binary tree each Leaf node
is a hash of a block of transactional
data so each Leaf node is basically a
transaction which is hashed and each
non-leaf node is a hash of its Leaf node
so basically Hash A a is the hash of two
blocks Hash A and hash B Merkel root or
the hash root is the final hash of all
the transaction hashes so basically
Merkel root is the hash of hash a a and
hash BB so it encompasses all the
transactions which are underlying all
the non-leaf nodes what do you mean by
blocks in the blockchain technology what
is the definition of a block so
blockchain is a distributed database of
immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography now as
you see there are the certain attributes
of a block which are displayed here you
have previous hash transaction details
nons and a Target hash value so a block
is like a record of transactions each
time a block is verified it gets
recorded in chronological order on the
main blockchain so as you can see as it
is represented over here every time a
new block is verified it gets added to
the main blockchain with all those
attributes populated now once the data
is recorded it cannot be modified it
cannot be changed now another question
which could come into your interview is
how is blockchain distributed Ledger
different from a traditional Ledger it
is a very important question we need to
know the basic difference and
justification if we have to move from a
traditional database to a blockchain
based distributed Ledger what benefit it
bring on the table so certain
differences which are very visible are
transparency blockchain distributed
Ledger is highly transparent as compared
to traditional database distributed
ledgers are irreversible once any
information is registered on a
distributed Ledger cannot be modified
whereas on a traditional Ledger it is
reversible basically distributed Ledger
is more secure it uses cryptography
every transaction is hashed and recorded
in a traditional Ledger the security can
be compromised in a distributed Ledger
there is no Central Authority it's a
distributed system the participants of
the network holds the authority to
maintain the sanity of the network and
are responsible for validating the
transactions whereas traditional ledgers
are based on the concept of centralized
Authority and control and all the
transactions are controlled by the
centralized Authority in a distributed
Ledger identities are unknown and are
hidden whereas in a traditional Ledger
identities of all the participants have
to be known before the transaction can
happen in a distributed Ledger there is
not a single point of failure as the
data is distributed information is
shared across multiple nodes even if a
single node fails the other nodes carry
the same copy of the information whereas
in a traditional Ledger in a centralized
database ledger-based system that
particular system becomes a single point
of failure if the single system crashes
the entire application or the entire
network comes to a standstill ability to
modify data know once the data or a
transaction is is registered it cannot
be altered and a traditional Ledger it
is possible how validation is done so in
a distributed Ledger it is done by the
participants of the network in a
traditional Ledger it is controlled by
the centralized Authority copy of Ledger
is shared amongst all the participants
of a distributed Ledger each participant
consists the same information in The
Ledger in a traditional Ledger only a
single copy is maintained at a
centralized location it is not shared
amongst all the participants thereby
again it remains as a single point of
failure if you have any queries you can
put your comments in the comments
section of this video and we will
definitely come back to you how can you
identify a block what are the attributes
of block in order to understand it so
every block consists of four Fields it
holds the hash value of the previous
block therefore it gets Linked In A
blockchain it contains the details of
the aggregated transactions which are
aggregated in the block it has a value
called nons is a random value which is
used to vary the value of the hash in
order to generate the hash value less
than the Target and then finally you
have a hash of the block itself it is
the digital signature of this block a
unique hash for this block it is a
alphanumeric value which is used to
identify a block so that is the identity
of the block the hash address is the
unique identification of a block it is a
hex value of 64 characters that has both
letters and digit it is obtained by
using sha-256 algorithm now this is the
way it is structured the hash of the
previous block the transaction data and
the nouns consolidate the header of the
block they all together are passed
through a hashing function and then the
hash value the digital signature of the
block is then generated what is
cryptography and what is its role in
blockchain blockchain uses cryptography
primarily to secure users identities and
ensure the the transactions are done
safely with the hash function so all the
user identities and the transaction on a
blockchain are encrypted cryptography
uses public and private keys to encrypt
and decrypt data so basically it uses
the public and private key
infrastructure in order to maintain the
encryption of the information on a
blockchain network in blockchain network
public key can be shared with all the
Bitcoin users all the blockchain users
so public key is just like your address
which you can share it with anyone but a
private key is like your password it is
kept secret with the user so basically
blockchain uses cryptography to secure
user identities and ensure transactions
are done safely and how does it do it it
uses sha-256 algorithm which is secure
which provides a unique hash output for
every input and it is a very popular
algorithm the basic feature of sha256 is
that whatever input you pass it will
give you a standard output alphanumeric
output of 64 characters so basically it
is a one-way function you can derive an
encrypted value from the input but you
can't do vice versa now what are the
different types of blockchains which
exists there are three different types
of blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain and Consortium blockchain
public blockchain ledgers are visible to
all the users on the internet and any
user can verify and add a block of
transactions to the blockchain basically
it's publicly available anyone can
participate in the network and get
hooked up so examples are Bitcoin and
ethereum private blockchain ledgers are
visible to all the users on the internet
but only specific users in the
organization can verify and add
transaction so it's a kind of a
permissioned blockchain though the
information can be available publicly
but the controllers and the validators
of the blockchain are within the
organizations and are predetermined the
example is block stack Consortium
blockchain here the consensus process is
controlled by only specific nodes
however ledgers are visible to all the
participants in the Consortium
blockchain example is revenue now what
happens when you try to deploy a file
with multiple contracts in blockchain
deploying a file with multiple contracts
is not possible the compiler only
deploys the last contract from the
uploaded file and the remaining
contracts are neglected and this is the
way a smart contract is deployed on a
blockchain network now very interesting
question what is a Genesis Block it's a
very important question and could be
asked in an interview multiple times so
basically Genesis block is the first
block in the blockchain which is also
known as block zero so as you can see
the sequence number of this block is 0
and in blockchain it is the only block
that does not refer to any previous is
blocked so the hash value of the
previous block will be all zeros because
it is the first block also it defines
parameters of the blockchain such as
level of difficulty consensus mechanisms
Etc to mind the block so basically it
defines the primary attributes of the
blockchain which is going to get
initiated from the Genesis block onwards
now let's look at some of the questions
which would come if you are at an
intermediate level now how is the hash
of a block signature generated in
blockchain to generate a digital
signature transaction details are passed
through a one-way hashing function for
example sha-256 then the output value
was passed through a signature algorithm
like ecdsa with the user's private key
then the encrypted hash along with the
other information such as the hashing
algorithm is called as the digitally
signed document and is called the
digital signature so this is the entire
process us of generating a digitally
signed block list down some of the
extensively used cryptographic
algorithms these are the few popular
algorithms which are extensively used
sha-256 Bitcoin uses it it has ethereum
uses it RSA is one of the other popular
algorithm Blowfish triple Des so it's
very important to memorize these
algorithms the names of these algorithms
when asked and sh-256 and attach are
used in two of the popular public
blockchain networks what is a smart
contract and lists some of its
application so smart contracts are
self-executing contracts these are
basically digital contracts which
contains the terms and conditions of an
agreement between two parties between
two peers now some of the applications
can be used in transportation where
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
using smart contracts so as there's a
movement of goods and it is exchanging
had between different parties there
could be need of a contract and a smart
contract between the parties it is also
used in protecting copyrighted content
like music or books or the literature
which you have written so smart
contracts can protect the ownership
rights it can also be used in Insurance
it can be used to identify false claims
and prevent forgeries Employment
contract smart contracts can be helpful
to facilitate wage payments and it can
be used as a proof of employment now
another important question what is
ethereum network and how many ethereum
networks are you familiar with ethereum
is a blockchain based distributed
computing platform featuring smart
contract functionality that enable users
to create and deploy their decentralized
applications called dapps there are
three types of network in ethereum live
Network the main net then there are
couple of test networks like robsten
Carvin and brinkby and then you can also
create your own private network using
ethereum smart contracts are deployed on
the main Network they are publicly
available and can be used by others also
test networks allows you to run your
smart contracts on a test net validate
the gas which is being used you can just
use this test networks as the mainnet
deploy your contracts verify your
decentralize application and then move
on to the mainnet private Network are
those which are not connected to the
main Network which run within the
premises of the organization but carry
the features of an ethereum Network now
where do nodes run smart contract code
nodes run smart contract codes on
ethereum virtual machine it is a virtual
machine designed to operate as a runtime
environment for ethereum based smart
contracts evm is operated in a sandbox
environment or isolated from the main
net and it is a perfect testing
environment so you can download the evm
run your smart contact locally in an
isolated Manner and once you have tested
and verified it then you can deploy it
on the main name now very important and
a very good question what is a dab and
how is it different from a normal
application we need to understand these
differences very thoroughly in order to
clear our interview so adapt is a
decentralized application which is
deployed using smart contract the
information on adapt is distributed and
shared in a normal application it has a
centralized database which is running on
a centralized server so you have a
single server and a single code which is
maintaining the entire application no
information is shared and it is a single
point of failure adapt has its backend
code a smart contract which runs on a
decentralized peer-to-peer Network in a
normal application it's a typical
computer software application that is
hosted on a central server so if you see
in the differences in the process you
have a front end then in the middle you
have a smart contract which is acting as
the backend code and then the entire
transaction executed on a smart contract
is shared between the blockchain
participants in the P2P Network whereas
in a normal application the front end
interacts with a centralized API which
performs basic crud operations create
read update delete on a centralized
database and it is a single copy of the
information name some leading open
source platforms for developing
blockchain applications so ethereum is
one of the popular platforms for
building blockchain based applications
and it is widely getting adopted Aries
is also used for building
enterprise-based Solutions and also some
of the widely used platforms for
building blockchain are listed below
hyperledger multi-chain open chain are
available in the market what is the very
first thing you must specify in a
solidarity file now it is necessary to
specify the version number of solidity
at the beginning of a code as it
eliminates incompatibility errors which
can arise while compiling with another
version it is a mandatory clause which
has to be there at the top of any
solidity code which you write and you
need to mention the correct version
number for which you have written the
code now what is the difference between
Bitcoin and ethereum and it's a very
important question which I also ask in
lot of interviews and it's important for
you to remember these differences so
Bitcoin the concept is purely P2P
currency based transaction but in
ethereum you can do both P2P currency
transaction plus you can deploy smart
contracts Bitcoin is primarily working
on proof of work consensus mechanism
ethereum is shifting from proof of work
to proof of stay Bitcoin uses sha 256
hashing algorithm whereas ethereum uses
it hash time taken to minor block
currently on bitcoin is approximately 10
minutes whereas in ethereum it gets
processed in 12 to 15 seconds the reward
for mining on bitcoin as of today is
12.5 Bitcoin whereas in ethereum it is
three ethers plus the transaction fees
on bitcoin the transaction fees are
optional whereas in ethereum the fees is
calculated based on the gas which is
being consumed on a smart contract per
transaction value of Bitcoin as of 21st
August was captured at
6934 US Dollars whereas ethereum stands
at 278 dollars now what is norms and how
is it used in mining in blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
now proof of work is the process to
determine a number a nonce that is the
number along with the cryptographic hash
algorithm to produce a hash value which
is lower than a predefined Target nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the hash values so that the final hash
value meets the hashing condition so the
nonce is the value which is being
generated by The Miner in order to guess
the hash value which should be less than
the target value and then only the miner
can claim the reward for if it is mining
a Bitcoin network of 12.5 BTC and F
ethereum network of three ethers now
let's look at some of the advanced level
questions name the steps that are
involved in a blockchain project
implementation so in a typical block
chain-based project implementation we
start off with requirement
identification we need to understand the
problem and goal we need to identify the
suitable consensus mechanism what is the
most suitable platform which can solve
the problem and then identify the
implementation and deployment costs we
need to give an Roi to the client then
we move on to the planning stage in this
step an individual evaluates all the
requirements list them down prioritize
them and decides a suitable blockchain
platform which has to be used to
implement this particular problem then
click soft the development and
implementation of the project you design
the architecture you design the user
interfaces and start building the apis
and then comes controlling and
monitoring the project you apply the
proof of concept you start off with that
and then start building the application
on top of it and then once the basic
version of the application is available
you start identifying bugs and start
fixing them explain a real life use case
where blockchain is being used so supply
chain is the biggest adopter of
blockchain and as you can see as the raw
material moves is exchanged between
different entities in a supply chain the
traceability of that particular digital
asset which in this case is raw material
is a big case study on blockchain in
Supply Chain management smart contracts
provide permanent transparency
traceability and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain Partners so at each level each
supply chain partner has to register the
transaction when it receives a product
and then when it passes it on so
basically the purchaser when consuming
the end product can see the entire
journey of the product list and explain
the parts of evm memory so the memory of
an evm is divided into three parts
storage memory and Stack Storage values
are stored permanently on the blockchain
network and it is extremely expensive so
whenever you will try to modify a
storage based variable you would have to
pay gas for it memory variables are 10
very modifiable storage area it can be
accessed only during the contract
execution and once the execution is
finished the data is wiped off vanished
and it's lost stack on the other way is
a temporary and a non-modifiable storage
here when the execution is completed the
content is lost so basically memory and
stack are relatively much cheaper than
storage variables now what happens if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas initially
your transaction will be executed but if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas then the
miners will stop validating your
contract the blockchain will record the
transaction as fail as highlighted and
also the user does not get a refund so
it becomes of utmost important that when
you are deploying your smart contract
you do the calculation of the gas
consumption in the most correct fashion
what does the gas usage in a transaction
depend on and how is transaction fee
calculated SO gas usage depends upon the
amount of storage you are using if you
are using storage based variables and
the cost of the transactions will be
high the gas will be high and the set of
instruction codes used in a smart
contract basically what operations you
are performing on the storage based
variables either they're costly and if
you are using a huge amount of storage
variables then automatically the cost of
your smart contract will keep on
increasing so basically the transaction
fee is calculated in ethers which is
given as the gas price which you have
determined for your smart contract and
multiplied by the gas limit and this is
how your transaction fee is evaluated
now what is fork and what are some of
the types of forking so in simple terms
updating a cryptocurrency protocol or
code is called forking folk implies that
a blockchain splits into two branches
and forking is done when you want to
modify certain attributes of an existing
blockchain Network it can happen when
the participants of the network cannot
come to an agreement with regards to
either the consensus algorithm or they
want new rules for validation so there
are three types of [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
soft [ __ ] and accidental Forks what
is the difference between proof of work
versus proof of stake and it's a very
important question in blockchain proof
of work is the process of solving a
complex mathematical puzzle called
mining whereas proof of stake is an
alternative proof of work by which the
blockchain aims to achieve distributed
consensus in proof of work probability
of mining a block is based upon the
amount of computational work done by a
miner basically it consumes huge amount
of resources electricity resources and
computational resources of the miner
whereas in proof of stake the
probability of validating the block
relies upon the amount of token you own
beforehand so the more the tokens you
have the more the chance you get to
validate a block so basically of stuff
has been introduced in order to reduce
the pressure on the resources which has
been put by the proof of work consensus
algorithm miners spend a lot of
computing power for solving the
cryptographic puzzle along with the
hardware and it's a huge cost so
basically proof of stake was created as
a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources pentane mining what
is a 51 attack in blockchain 51 percent
attack refers to a vulnerability where
an individual or group of people can
control the majority of the mining power
or hashway so basically they can take
over the 50 of the blockchain network
this would allow the attackers to
prevent new transactions from being
confirmed further they can double spend
the coins now in 51 attack smaller
cryptocurrencies are primarily being
attacked which does not have a huge
Network which has a small consumer base
what a function modifiers and solidity
and mention the most widely used
modifiers in solidity function modifiers
are used to easily modify behavior of
your smart contract it can be associated
with a function and then whenever a
function is called the modifier is
called before the main function in
simple terms it can build additional
features or apply restrictions on the
function of smart contracts the most
extensively used function modifiers in
solidity are view view functions are
functions that cannot modify the state
of a smart contract they are only
read-only functions here is an example
you have a function that simply learn
name and it is having a modifier view
which only returns a value but you are
allowed to use some inbuilt solidarity
functions like MSG dot sender but in
case of pure pure functions are
functions that neither read nor write
the state of smart contracts they return
the same result determined by its input
variables so basically you can even
access the inbuilt functions of solidity
so here here you have a function called
calculate you can only use the input
variables you cannot use any of the
inbuilt functions also of solidity now
let's take a look of an example in order
to write a crowd sales smart contract
code in solidity programming language so
here in the example you have a smart
contract where you have defined certain
smart contract variables of solidity
like address and uint now the address
function is if you want to send your
token to someone and your uint is the
funding goal in ethers basically how
much amount of ethers you want to
generate in your crowd Sale Project then
what is the duration of your project
then cost of each token in ethers then
address of token used as reward so these
are the primary attributes which you
have defined then you have your public
functions which are defined over here
the beneficiary if successfully sent to
the funding goal the deadline of your
crowd sale and the price now here is
your default function which is defined
in a solidity contract which does not
have any function name and is called by
default in your smart contract if anyone
invokes a method in your smart contract
which does not exist in this function
you are making sure that all the amount
which has been passed to the smart
contract is passed to your address
basically you are the originator of your
crowd sale Function crowdsale Smart
contract so you should be receiving the
amount then in your crowd sales smart
contract you can have a method which is
called as safe withdrawal and you have
appended it with a modifier called after
deadline so which basically checks that
you can only do a withdrawal after the
deadline has been achieved and in this
function you are checking the balance
then you are withdrawing that amount
from the sender and transferring it to
your own account as the sender has sent
that amount to you so you do the best
validations whether the sender has that
balance and then you do that transfer to
your account meet Frank and Daniel one
day they decide to go for a trip to
Venice they made a budget list for all
their expenses like residence flight Etc
they thought of making their bookings
online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day while making their respective
flight bookings Daniel's transaction
failed and he missed the offer going on
on the other hand Frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three Lucky Draw winners Daniel
was surprised and asked Frank how he
could make the transaction when Daniel
himself could not to which his response
was it's simple I used Bitcoin a type of
cryptocurrency
Daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
Frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 By
Satoshi Nakamoto Daniel felt that it
sounds similar to other online payment
options yes what makes it so different
Frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference which means it
is not issued and controlled by any
government or Central Authority unlike
other payment systems that Banks or
governments are handling and that's why
a cryptocurrency transaction never fails
there could be many reasons for why
Daniel's transaction failed like he may
have exceeded his transfer limit or his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank but on the other hand
cryptocurrency charges almost no or very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
24 7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges on making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account on any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency this is what makes
cryptocurrency different from other
online payment options Daniel was
impressed by cryptocurrency but he
wondered how it works without the
control of an external Authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology
blockchain is a set of blocks that
record information of transactions like
who made the transaction to whom the
amount of trade in the form of a digital
Ledger that is distributed across the
entire network meaning the data is
replicated and stored on each node
across the entire blockchain network
making it more secure and impossible to
change hack or cheat the system then it
is verified and validated by every node
to proceed with the process of making
the transactions the crypto and
cryptocurrency stands for cryptography
which is a method of using encryption
and decryption to secure the data in the
presence of any third-party with
ulterior motives now Daniel was
completely aware of the whole technology
and concept behind cryptocurrency and
was influenced by Frank to adopt
cryptocurrency in his daily lifestyle
too he did that by booking his ticket
but sadly no discount
like Daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide due to this
increasing popularity new companies like
metoo and PayPal are coming forward and
investing in cryptocurrency every day in
2018 Malta an Island located in the
Mediterranean Sea south of Italy was
titled blockchain Island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
okx have already begun to take advantage
of malta's financial incentives and have
moved their headquarters to the
blockchain island
so here is a question for you which
hashing algorithm does cryptocurrency
use a script
B ethash
c
sha-256 d none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive Amazon
gift vouchers cryptocurrency is
revolutionizing finance and banking
around the world thanks to
cryptocurrency now anyone with an
internet connection can trade spend and
borrow money around the world and nobody
can stop them people like Bill Gates
co-founder of Microsoft Corporation and
Elon Musk CEO of Tesla support
cryptocurrency as it is much better and
secure than physical money and also
holds a great future for the world's
economy and on the other hand some
people think of cryptocurrency as a bane
to the world's economy like Warren
Buffett CEO of Berkshire Hathaway and
Ajay benga CEO of global MasterCard Phil
the cryptocurrency is a platform of
criminal activities and will destroy the
world's economy
well one thing is clear that this
conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer hi guys today we're going
to talk about 10 things you didn't know
about Bitcoin firstly we have the
mysterious Creator now in 2009 a person
or a group of people known as Satoshi
Nakamoto introduced Bitcoin to the world
he vanished off the internet in late
2010 he hasn't been heard from since now
just like his identity shorter than
mystery nobody really knows if he's even
alive or dead the only communication
people had with him were through emails
and forums his Bitcoin wallet holds
around 980 000 Bitcoins which makes him
one of the richest people on the planet
next up we have the Satoshi now as a
sign of respect for the Bitcoins Creator
the smallest unit of a Bitcoin is known
as the Satoshi one Satoshi is valued at
around
0.0000669 for US Dollars which is a very
very low value now to make one Bitcoin
you need approximately 100 million
satoshis now according to the current
bitcoin values which fluctuates lot to
make a dollar you need close to 15 800
satoshis losing Bitcoins losing a
Bitcoin address which is also known as
your private key not only means losing
your unique identification it also means
you lose all the Bitcoins in your wallet
research shows that at least 60 percent
of all Bitcoin addresses are ghosts
which means a huge chunk of the
population that's using the Bitcoin
Network have lost their addresses now
these are the people who have lost their
addresses and have no way to access
their wallet liberland now in April 2015
a micronation between Croatia and Serbia
known as liverland was born now this was
founded by vidyalka a politician
publicist activist and the president of
liverland now the official currency of
liberland is Bitcoin now the government
took this move believing that Bitcoin
and its underlying concepts of
blockchain provides a secure and
transparent method for recording
electronic financial and physical assets
processing power the process of mining
bitcoins is a expensive process now you
pay a high toll to do this like make
your money your time and electricity now
mining bitcoins requires servers that
are used for that specific purpose alone
now the faster you process the data the
faster the block can be added to the
blockchain and the faster you're
rewarded with Bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
Ireland consumes in a year approximately
5000 kilowatt hour now how much do you
think all the Bitcoin mining Farms
together consume 60 terawatt all which
is approximately 6 into 10 raised to 10
kilowatt hours which is a large amount
of power now the entire country of
Ireland which is the second most
populated city in Europe and has 84 421
kilometer square of area consumes lesser
electricity than all these Farms
combined Bitcoin ban now although
several countries around the world like
Canada and America have wholeheartedly
accepted Bitcoin there are some that
haven't countries like Bolivia Iceland
Bangladesh and Ecuador have completely
banned the usage of Bitcoins there are
also countries like India Thailand and
Iran who asked their residents to be
careful while using cryptocurrencies
they haven't completely banned it
however they do not accept it as a legal
tender though limited number there's a
limit to how many Bitcoins can exist in
the market this number is capped at 21
million Bitcoins as of this moment 17
million Bitcoins are already in
circulation to give you an idea that's
almost 80 percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 2140
we'll still have Bitcoins to mine this
is because of how miners are rewarded
now mine is rewarded with 12.5 Bitcoins
for each block added to the blockchain
and every four years the reward reduces
by half the next halving is supposed to
occur in 2020 by the reward reduces to
6.25 Bitcoins the power of B the terms
Bitcoin with an uppercase B and Bitcoin
with a lowercase b mean two different
things the only thing that
differentiates the two into two
completely different things is the
letter B the lowercase b in Bitcoin
refers to the cryptocurrency that is
used to perform the transactions the the
uppercase B in Bitcoin refers to the
Ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at 122.3
petaflops which is nothing but a
quadrillion floating Point operations
per second now if you take the Bitcoin
Network complete into consideration the
processing power is about 80 million
seven hundred and four thousand two
hundred ninety petaflops but the only
thing here is that a supercomputer can
do several different things but the only
thing the Bitcoin network does is ADD
blocks to the blockchain let's talk
about what is Bitcoin mining so what is
bitcoin so let's take an example so
there is someone who wants to send five
Bitcoins to Rachel now we will see how
this transaction can happen now Bitcoin
is based on the concept of digital
currency anyone across the globe can
transfer amount in Bitcoin irrespective
of the geography from anyone to anyone
so basically you need to just open an
account on the Bitcoin Network how have
some Bitcoins in it and you can transfer
it either you can purchase the Bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have Bitcoins in
your account you can transfer it to
someone you want whose address you have
now do you want to know how this
transaction work well this transaction
is done by Bitcoin mining so we will go
deep and understand that how the Bitcoin
transaction Works what all entities are
involved behind the scenes in order to
maintain the sanity of the Bitcoin
Network and make sure that whomever you
wanted the Bitcoin to reach to has
reached and there is no loss of Bitcoin
in the network and it is a successful
transaction so let's understand certain
Basics so what's in it for us today we
need to know what is bitcoin we will
understand the underlying technology
blockchain so we will talk about that
then we will see what are the advantages
of Bitcoin as compared to other digital
currencies and other digital
Technologies then we will go into the
concepts of Bitcoin mining then what is
Bitcoin mining and we will do a demo on
certain aspects of Bitcoin mining now
what is bitcoin Bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like Banks governments agents Brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediate now
Bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called Satoshi
nakomoto now Bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular Fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed the intermediate trees from
between the cost of transaction also
goes down and it is cryptographically
secure it uses cryptography
infrastructure and thereby the
identities of the sender and the
receiver are also secure and the entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the user's information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of Bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a Bitcoin Network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public Ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the Bitcoin Network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so Bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
Ledger in which transactions made in
Bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it's
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized Authority or the body and
the transactions are towed in containers
aggregated in containers called blocks
so a block is the smallest unit of a
blockchain which records all the
transaction a basic structure of a block
is something like this it has four
Fields these are the primary attributes
for Block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block nons
so in proof of work consensus algorithm
which is used in Bitcoin nonce is a
random value which is used to vary the
output of the hash value so every block
is supposed to generate a hash value and
nonce is the parameter which is used to
generate that hash value and the proof
of work is the process of transaction
verification done in blockchain now hash
is the resultant hash value obtained by
passing the previous hash value the data
and the nodes through the sha-256
algorithm to generate the hash of this
block so this is the digital signature
of the block which is generated and this
is the basically identity of this block
now SSH 256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
big alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of Bitcoin
mining what is Bitcoin mining Bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
Bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain Ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by Bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called miners so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of Legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on a regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in Bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining Community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every Miner's job is to to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction The Miner who first solves
the person gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzles as I said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand Bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public Ledger it uses sha 256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
Bitcoin mining so distributed public
Ledger a distributed Ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by Bitcoin users
called as minus is sha-256 now
blockchain prevents unauthorized access
by using a hash function called sha-256
to ensure that the blocks are kept
secure they are digitally signed then
hash value once generated cannot be
altered now sat 256 it takes an input
string of any size and returns a fixed
length 256 bit output value and that is
the primary feature of shf 256
encryption algorithm you give any input
it will always give you a 256-bit output
and it is a one-way function you cannot
derive the input reversely from the
output what you have generated and third
is the proof of work in blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
now in order to do that the primary
objective of the miner is to determine
the nonce value and that nonce value is
that mathematical puzzle that minus
require required to solve in order to
generate a hash Which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the Bitcoin
Network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying a
nonce which produces a hash value lower
than a predefined condition which is
called as a Target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 Bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the Bitcoins associate with
the transactions can be spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of Bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the Sha 256
hashing algorithm you def find the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing non's value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
Define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value Which is
less than the Target now let's check an
example so for example Beyonce wants to
share 10 Bitcoin with Jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so beyond transaction data is shared
with Bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconformed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now minus
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions they aggregate in a data
block and start validating they start
solving the puzzle The Miner who solves
the puzzle first shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners now once the block has been
verified the nonce has been generated
then the nodes will start granting their
approval if maximum nodes grant their
approval the block becomes valid and is
added to the blockchain now
simultaneously The Miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
Bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the Bitcoins the 10
BTC for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from Beyonds to
Jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for Block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash Target of
the first block divided by the hash
Target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have told the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash Target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as I said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of Bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of Mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of whatever the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks ABC Now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to Tamper block block b and tries
to change the data which is aggregated
in the block so if the data of the block
will change the hash value which is the
digital signature of the block will also
change thereby it will corrupt the chain
which is subsequent to it basically the
blocks ahead of Block B will all get D
Link because the previous hash value of
Block C will not remain valid so in
order for the hacker to make the entire
blockchain valid for the Block B which
he has changed he has to change the hash
value of all the blocks ahead of Block B
which will require huge huge amount of
computing power which will be next to
impossible so as you see the results in
the following block being invalid so
with this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying Hardware requirements for
Bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
evolved so in the early days my miners
used to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit CPUs now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as I said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so they
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular CPUs so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any Miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called asric application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so mine is a profitable when
there their cost of resources to mine
one block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they earn so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new Bitcoins are created
in the network so the Bitcoin total
Supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million Bitcoin
are in Supply 17 to 18 million Bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 Bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the Bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the Bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 Bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is Bitcoin mining pool your chances of
winning the lottery is difficult but in
a community if individuals buy multiple
lottery tickets and pool their tickets
together then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed amongst all the participants
Bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to mine a
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result the Bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the best
Bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the Bitcoin Network as you can
see this is a block and this is the lock
reward 12.5 Bitcoin so this was a block
which was mined this is the block number
and these are the set of transactions
which were part of this block now once
this block was mined by The Miner all
these transactions then be done these
are the transfers of Bitcoin from one
account to the other this is the nonce
which was generated by The Miner or the
mining pool in order to mine the block
and these are the other attributes and
if you take a look at this URL this is
an example of a mining pool it's a demo
account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have mine
ethereum and its Concepts ethereum
simply put while Bitcoin is defined as
digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime fraud
and third-party interference and also
has its own cryptocurrency called ether
ethereum aims to enable Innovations in
three key areas
currency Assurance through ether which
serves as an innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum the first feature
of ethereum is that it is secure because
it is almost impossible to tamper with
the transactions in the block or to add
any fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
Community following
ethereum has attracted a lot of
attention from people all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset a virtual share a proof of
membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast while Bitcoin requires a block time
of 10 minutes in ethereum it's only a
few seconds the last feature that we
will discuss is the fact that ethereum
is uncensored ethereum's open source
Network allows complete transparency to
view every transaction alright that's
all about the features of ethereum let
me tell you about an important Concept
in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain it is the crypto fuel for
ethereum it can be considered a
transaction fee which has to be paid
when one party sends ethers to another
party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails gas price is expressed
in ether and the miner decides whether
to refuse the transaction process or not
based on the expected gas price one can
see their transaction fee in eth or USD
when searching for the transaction on
etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit the total cost of a transaction is
the product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single transaction
this avoids situations where there is an
error somewhere in the contract and you
end up spending a very high amount of
gas however the units of gas required
for a transaction are defined by the
amount of code executed on the
blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much if enough
gas to cover the computational resources
of the network is not supplied with the
transaction the transaction will fail
due to an out of gas error SO gas is a
commodity which is essentially a cost of
using the system
like Bitcoins ethereum also has its
currency which is called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations it ensures that the
developers write error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost ethereum is a blockchain based
platform and ether is the cryptocurrency
that fuels the platform it is commonly
denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between Bitcoin and ether
Bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is then the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies while
Bitcoin uses
sha-256 to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses ethash to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
Bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier Bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services however ethereum being a
touring complete platform also supports
smart contracts and decentralized
applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies currently the
price of BTC is approximately 3 500 US
Dollars while that of eth is
approximately 100 US dollars
the market cap of BTC is almost six
times greater than that of BTC even
though eth has a higher circulating
Supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
BTC is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of BTC is
much slower than eth while btc's
transaction speed is measured in minutes
eth is just a few seconds
like Bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets let's understand
what our wallets in ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies basically a wallet
stores the means of accessing your
currency using the private key
now that I have told you about the
ethereum and its currency it will only
be fair that I explain evm now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm is an engine which executes
translation code
smart contracts are compiled into
bytecode which an evm can read and
execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi-turing complete
machine it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm bytecode
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm bytecode
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of five eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in
ethereum-specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm byte code and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity solidity
is an object-oriented high-level
language used for implementation of
smart contracts on the ethereum
blockchain
solidity was influenced by python C plus
plus and JavaScript
it is designed to Target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like language
abbreviated as Triple L it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is Viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is Mouton Mouton is
similar to C like language and supports
a dynamic full higher level language it
compiles to Native ethereum assembler
however Mouton is now deprecated
the last language is Julia it is an
intermediate language that can compile
to various different backends like evm
1.0 evm 1.5 and e w ASM let me now tell
you about the accounts handled by
ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts eoa is an
account controlled by a private key that
has the ability to send ethers and
messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no Associated code
smart contract smart contract is a code
running on top of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other as an account it has the
following properties firstly it has an
ether balance
secondly it has an Associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts and fourthly when
executed it performs operations of
arbitrary complexity some of the
advantages of smart contracts are as
follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes and lastly it lowers
the transaction cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing they operate autonomously
to execute the terms of the contract and
verify the transactions without the need
of a third-party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant process
of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works first an optional
contract between the parties is written
as a code into the blockchain the
individuals involved are Anonymous but
the contact is made through a public
Ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike prices hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next Regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract thus
the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes Undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce in an externally owned account
nonce represents the number of
transactions sent from the account's
address however in a contract account
the nonce is the number of contracts
created by the account
the next property is balance this number
shows the amount of way owned by the
address whether the eoa or contract
account each ether is divided into one e
plus 18 Wei the next property is code
hash it is the hash of the ethereum
virtual machine code of an account this
is the code that gets executed if this
address receives a message call it is
immutable and thus it cannot be changed
once the construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string for contract accounts this is the
code that gets hashed and is stored as
the code hash the last property is
storage root it is a 256 bit hash of the
root node of a Merkle tree that encodes
the storage contents of the account
encoded into the tree as a mapping from
the keycac
256-bit hash of the 256-bit integer keys
to the rlp encoded
256-bit integer values this tree encodes
the hash of the storage contents of this
account and is empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts let's understand the
process of mining now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining ethereum makes use of
proof of work mechanism to ensure
security the algorithm used in ethereum
is called ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a minor is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where Bob
wants to send one eth to Alice
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining first Bob attempts to
send Alice one eth once Bob's
transaction is initiated it is combined
with other transactions that have
occurred in the last block the miners
will then validate the block with a new
set of instructions once validated The
Miner creates a new block and is
rewarded for it
thus Alice receives one eth after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
The Ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 each to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next date for the transaction
State Storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes State routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system State when
the block was created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process to see how ethereum
stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair this way the
last remaining hash becomes the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three Merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state to maintain
the transactions and to maintain the
receipts also each block always refers
to its previous Block's hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools the ethereum
ecosystem consists of eight major tools
they are Geth
ganache
parody
meta mask
missed wallet
swarm
ipfs
whisper
now let's move forward and take a look
at each of these in detail
Geth
Geth is a multi-purpose command line
tool that runs an ethereum node
implemented in go
it is the official golang implementation
of the ethereum protocol and is commonly
used to interact with the ethereum
network
though there are several ways to
download GIF the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache CLI
ganache CLI
ganache CLI is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost thirdly
accounts can be recycled reset and
instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and Mining speed can
be modified fifthly a convenient GUI
gives you an overview of your test chain
events
parody parity is the fastest lightest
and most secure ethereum client that
provides the core infrastructure
Essentials for quick and reliable
services
parity is written in Rust language it
offers better reliability code Clarity
and performance it is an ethereum client
that is integrated directly into your
web browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an ethereum GUI
browser it provides access to a diverse
range of ethereum features including D
apps
metamask metamask turns Google Chrome
into a browser that allows the users to
send and receive transactions and also
fetch data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plugin to your Chrome
browser it permits you to run ethereum
d-apps directly from your browser
without the need for running a full
ethereum node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain to
overcome this metamask hosts a number of
nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install a
metamask and can automatically get
connected to the nodes thus you can use
the ethereum blockchain seamlessly
let's talk Mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
missed wallet
missed wallet is the end user interface
for ethereum that is developed for
browsing and using d-apps mist is an
official ethereum wallet it was
developed and distributed by the team
which is responsible for the management
of ethereum ecosystem it is usually used
by developers who want to create deploy
and use Smart contracts it is a full
node wallet which means you'll have to
download the entire ethereum blockchain
onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second storing ether
third creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services it acts as a
native base layer service of the
ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
Records to distribute blockchain data as
well as the app codes it leverages the
underlying ethereum infrastructure
through the use of contracts in ethers
to encourage cooperation among nodes the
files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micro payments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs stores data by use of a distributed
hash table or DHT once we know the hash
we request the peer Network who has a
copy of the content located at the
corresponding hash and then we download
the content from the node who has the
desired data which we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in BitTorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time thus it defines how
files move across a network making it a
distributed file system by combining all
of these properties
ipfs is enabling a new permanent web and
augmenting the way we use existing
internet protocols like http
whisper whisper is an identity-based
communication protocol for D apps to
interact with each other
d-apps that need to publish small
amounts of information to each other and
have the publication last some
substantial amount of time prefer using
whisper
for instance a d app running a currency
exchange may use whisper to record an
offer to buy a currency at a pre-agreed
price on the exchange platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows it has low level API which is
only exposed to D apps and never to
users second it has low bandwidth and is
not designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency and
lastly it has no reliable methods for
tracing packets
ethereum Frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
Frameworks
web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node it can be done with
the use of IPC or an HTTP connection the
key connection between ethereum Network
and dap that allows you to compile
deploy and interact with smart contracts
is called web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain let's take an example of
traditional development when you develop
a website it talks to apis using Json or
jQuery to make Ajax calls a website
talks to blockchain using web 3 using
json.rpc which is similar to making a
remote procedure call ethereum comprises
of a large number of nodes which talk to
each other we use Json RPC to make a
request to a particular node which is
like an API call thus if we want to talk
to a Smart contract or read an account
we do it through web3
eth.js it is a highly optimized
lightweight JS utility for ethereum
based on web.js in this all the
unnecessary characters are removed from
the source code and the code is reduced
to 160 kilobytes ethereum development
environment the three commonly used
ethereum development environments
include remix IDE truffle and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail
remix IDE remix IDE is a browser-based
compiler and IDE that enables users to
debug transactions and build ethereum
contracts with solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code the next slide shows how
remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle truffle is a development
environment testing framework and asset
pipeline for blockchains using the
ethereum virtual machine or evm it helps
users in developing smart contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications it performs
the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts third managing the complex
systems of interdependent contracts
fourth performing test driven deployment
with contracts using JavaScript
fifth managing different chains like
testnet private net and livenet and
lastly redeploy the contracts if any
changes are done
let's talk about ethereum Networks
ethereum Network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network they are
also referred to as clients they provide
wallet functionality and allow users to
perform transactions on the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
type sub Network there are three main
types of networks the test net the
mainnet and the private Network
ethereum d-apps and daos
the App
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure they run on a
peer-to-peer computer network all the
activity which takes place on an
ethereum decentralized application is
cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
Network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third-party intervention and high
security
example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain and 4G Capital these companies
have developed different applications
using blockchain
next we have the daos
d-a-o
daos are organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a Dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works
let's consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system
a Dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way in this video we will
explore ethereum Mining and we'll go
through some of the fascinating Concepts
and components revolving around it both
we even have an introduction to ethereum
then we will understand what is atheid
mining
then we will explore why should we minor
theorem
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we can understand how the
criteria mining process work
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
The Craft version kill group of work
and then finally we will find out is
Mining ethereum Profitable
so without doing much I do let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments ESO basically acts
as fuel for the ethereum network it
traps and facilitates all the
transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof of work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in Data
Network needs to get approved by the
miners
minus is a community of people using a
hashing strip etash to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
network which helps secure the network
from attacks like hacking or
manipulation of identity
now let's understand why we need to mine
ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a data mining turns at the
signal in the network into a relatively
complex but profitable business also
miners receive a certain amount as a
reward for money each block of the
ethereum blockchain network including
the transaction fees paid by the users
thus iterative mining benefits each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
so what are the types of a theory mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways prepare in Solo mining
ethereum poor Mining and ethereum Cloud
mining
you will get rewarded only if you solve
the puzzle and mine the Italian block
first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also so the mining is poorly profitable
when you have plenty of resources with
you like 100 plus graphics card
and in Solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of data needed
the dragon pool lining is the easiest
and fastest way to get started with
Terraria mining in this you walk along
with other people together in a single
pool and hit someone from the pool get
the hash code correctly they share the
reward among everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool like room
size minimum payout and pool fees
full size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it says the word as the number of
minus increases the chances to get
rewards also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
Italian you need to mine before it gets
credited to the wallet and Port key is
the amount you need to pay to continue
using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
ethereum Cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you
you pay some amount of money as eased to
them for investing their time and
resources
and return they provide you with the
reward the gain by the mining ethereum
first
mining ethereum has to close and consume
close
responsible for any equipment damage you
don't have to acquire all the necessary
equipment and look for ample space to
store it
you can sit back observe the market and
enjoy the reward for your investment in
theater mining
Con in the ethereum price drop then
there is no way you are getting your
money back the money you invested or the
fees paid to The Miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
material Cloud mining is considered a
safer vehicle mining service provider to
guarantee a profit for the resource they
have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
to create a mining follows a specific
set of steps to function
Step 1 a user request for transaction
with the help of the private key of its
digital Wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pinning transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 The Miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transactional data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified and its choose a copy of it in
EDM the process of inform work Begins
for the respective block
step 6 when the notes of the ethereum
network verify how the checksum of the
state of the minus Block matches the
checksum of the updated state of the
event of execution of all transactions
set 7 only after that the block is added
to the ethereum blockchain network
step in on successfully mining the block
it rewards The Miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet the block reward
of ethereum is three ether
of Step 9 the requested processing is
approved and credited to the respective
wallet or wallet
each transaction is mined only one with
every participant of the ethernet
Network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
Miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are and it has a wallet to
store all your currency all
GPU drivers or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb RAM
a mining software suitable according to
your Hardware like GPU
and a compatible operating system the
Windows 7 or 10 with 64-bit
before getting started with mining
attention you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your info
treasure Model T and Ledger Nano are the
most reliable and secular wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing GPU drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet
you'll need to update all the hardware
that is drives in a system
you can use two types of graphics card
they are AMD graphics card and Nvidia
graphics card
Claymore is considered the best
profitable mining ethereum on GPU
drivers
now we need to follow a few
set of step to get started with mining
Step 1 download the latest version of
Claymont the Dual Miner for the
operating system the latest version is
Claymore 11.0
Step 2 click on the latest version of
Windows and download the zip file
step 3 extract the files of Claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5 right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6 edit the start.exe file and add
these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better Source results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your pool address instead
of mining pool address
step 9 say you start the pxt file within
new updates remember while saving select
type as all files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
so let's explore will the proof of State
transition field group of work
the newly introduced concepts of
ethereum 2.0 the roadmaps plans to
upgrade to Google State consensus
algorithm in which it will provide all
existing miners of the ethereum network
with a limited time to earn a return for
the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
October 2020 but the history of delayed
regarding this update is worth talking
about
nobody told notes when ethereum 2.0 will
be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now when we know all about ethereum my
name this make you wonder if Academy
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area as a rule anything
below
0.12 per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered profitable you can mine
either and turn it into a vital source
of income by analyzing these figures
like hash rate of ethereum block reward
number of blocks per day and the coin
price of ethereum
do they also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors or you can use this
formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and Save in ethereum in this video we
will explore ethereum 2.0 and we'll go
through some of the fascinating Concepts
and components revolving around it
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
either is the cryptocurrency for
ethereum used to build decentralized
application smart contracts and make
standard peer-to-peer payments it tracks
and facilitates all the transactions and
makes sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
the what led to the religion of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions currently it is capable
of handling 15 to 45 transactions per
second which is comparatively impressive
but it is not enough to handle all of
Italian's users worldwide also the high
demand is affecting the driving up of
transaction fees
notes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger couldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.2
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of state and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
Luna's proof of work to record and
validate their transactions
the problems with proof of Works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain undergoes verification by all
participating nodes that means that the
speed of its fluids participant limits
the processing speed of the entire
network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasked among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the Network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
while ethereum 2.2 has been in research
and development since 2014. it has
actually been making some progress the
baking chain went live in December 2020
introducing this taking concept but
still there is no official claim for the
completion of this transition
the next phase is minute
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum Network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increase transactions per
second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way into
completing the whole trans session so
what is the future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total Game
Changer it will create a modified
Network that could potentially process
One lag transactions per second
and a much more sustainable Network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide increasing the
ethereum's network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
Alec buterin once said that the issuance
of new doku should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain network in the
previous videos we covered what Bitcoin
and ethereum are let's proceed further
and have a look at how they both differ
from each other did you know there are
more than 1600 cryptocurrencies
worldwide
and among them Bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
Bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide Trading
according to dtrip.co every day new
companies like Mito and people are
coming forward to invest in Bitcoin and
ethereum on March 7 2021 we too
confirmed that it had purchased 40
million in Bitcoin and ethereum on the
other hand PayPal is about to launch a
scheme with the public in purchase and
sell cryptocurrencies initially
featuring Bitcoin and ethereum via
Paypal digital wallet but have you all
ever wondered how they compare based on
their similarities and differences in
various aspects well before moving any
further let's have a quick look at how
Bitcoin and ethereum originated and made
a benchmark in the economic system
worldwide
Bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
Satoshi Nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after Bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
they take themselves as a Computing
platform that enables its developers to
build and deploy their decentralized
application now let's move ahead and see
the difference between them which make
them compete with each other in this
economy this video will cover individual
aspects for comparing ethereum and
bitcoin's performance and that
particular field first we will look into
the introduction of academic Bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language
mining process of ethereum and Bitcoin
monetary policy
transaction
and availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time Bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
Bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for Bitcoin it is an
alternative to Fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using daps or decentralized application
on the other side Bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain Network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the etash cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
Bitcoin uses the sag-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
Bitcoin Network
algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy a certain Network requirements
sat 256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private Keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum and Bitcoin
ethereum uses solidity solidity is a
high level programming language used by
ethereum for implementing smart
contracts but in terms of programming
language Bitcoin keeps it simple Bitcoin
uses C plus plus as its programming
language it is a stack based programming
language used to give Bitcoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both mining is
a process in which transaction made are
validated and added to blockchain public
Ledger and blogs and the people mining
these blocks are called miners a theory
minus mine the unvalidated transaction
using the proof of work method but it
aims to switch to proof of stake because
it will make its Network more immune to
centralization energy efficient and
stronger support for its shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the proof of
work method to mine unvalidated
transactions these method is enough to
function in Bitcoin Network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies but
let's first understand what monetary
policy is monetary policy is known as
the process of drafting announcing and
implementing the plan of actions taken
by the competing monetary authority to
control the money supply and Achieve
goals that promote sustainable economic
growth so ethereum's policy is defined
by the reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises of
two parts having and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining Bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of Bitcoins
you get if you successfully mine a
blockchain block the current block
reward for ethereum is to either per
block and for Bitcoin the block reward
is 12.5 Bitcoins per block also every 14
seconds a block of ethereum is generated
and one block of Bitcoin take 10 minutes
to generate monetary policies are
considered to be fixed and
non-inflationary due to this over time
mining blocks will become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
Bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and Bitcoin is only
used as the value for real world
transactions to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and Google pay a determine Bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption now talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies ethereum is not limited
but it can occasionally reduce due to
large Network upgrades however Bitcoin
is limited to 21 million coins and as of
today 18 million Bitcoin is already used
but in the end both Bitcoin and ethereum
being the top cryptocurrencies share a
few similarities like both a decent
mentalized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction proof of work
also both have a large network of
independent nodes now let's have a demo
now let's have a look at the media
outlet website coindesk where we will
see all stats related to bitcoin and
ethereum in detail contest is a site
specialized in digital currencies it is
used to explore the news and price data
related to cryptocurrencies and also
explains how cryptocurrencies contribute
to the evolution of financial system
worldwide now see this graph this graph
shows the change in bitcoin price in 24
hours duration this graph shows the
gradual change in the price of Bitcoin
it started from 64
439.29 on April 14 at 12 pm and right
now by April 15 at 6 00 am it is at 63
189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
which shows the change in the price of
Bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2. the value of ethereum
started at
2388.13 on April 14 at 12 pm and the
current status on April 15 is positive
with a value of
2442.37 with an increasing rate of 4.67
percent down below we have a metrics
table that shows the change between the
starting and ending value of ethereum
the total supply of a cryptocurrency in
24 hours the total number of
transactions that occurred and the
average transaction fee for all these
transactions now this graph shows the
current status of cryptocurrency in USD
dollars we can also see its value
according to any centralized currency
like Euro or INR this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an R to its lifetime recently we
all have been hearing about the
cryptocurrency famously known as
Dogecoin but what exactly makes it so
different from others that almost every
person is talking about it
so let me tell you that Dogecoin is an
altcoin and an almost sarcastic mean
coin that serves as a peer-to-peer open
source cryptocurrency well that's not
enough
so let's dive down and understand the
concept of Dogecoin more precisely but
before starting let's have a look at why
is it in the news since the beginning of
the year 2021 Dogecoin has surged more
than 950 percent from less than half a
penny to more than five cents per
Dogecoin then Elon Musk CEO of test line
corporation took his interest in it and
tweeted too much concentration is the
only real issue for cryptocurrency
making the owner of the Dogecoin wallet
a subject of attention later on are the
celebs like Snoop Dogg also started
taking an interest in Dogecoin and
started tweeting and promoting it on
social platforms which made Dogecoin
climb to a peak of 8.2 us cents and
market capitalization of 10 billion
dollars in this video we will come
across the following topics first we
will see the origin of Dogecoin and then
we will understand what is Dogecoin how
does it exactly works and then we will
see what led to the growth of Dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of Dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of Dogecoin today
and lastly how can we buy it let's start
with the origin of Dogecoin
Dogecoin was invented by two software
Engineers IBM engineer Billy Marcus and
Adobe engineer Jackson farmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the Year 2013 Bitcoin and
Deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is Dogecoin Dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a mean coin inspired by Shiba inu's
popular meme AKA Doge moving ahead let's
have a look at how it works to
understand the workflow let's take the
example of two friends Mark and Susan
Mark owes some money to Susan and now he
needs to return it
he thinks of an idea and decides to send
her Dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital Vault
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information first his private key and
second her public key
to get access to Susan's private key he
needs to scan a QR code from his
smartphone
then the application alerts all the
Dogecoin miners around the world to
proceed further with the process the
Dogecoin miners validate where the Mark
has enough Dogecoin to make the payment
or not and after the validation process
they approve the transaction request
Dogecoin miners race with each other to
collect all the data of depending
transaction known as the nons
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for that particular nodes of the
pending transaction The Miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 Dogecoin in
his account
after that Mark and Susan gets a
confirmation message that the request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of Dogecoin is credited into the
wallet of Susan thus the transaction is
completed so what led to the growth of
Dogecoin Dogecoin officially Came live
in 2013 and became an instant hit within
the community of people who just wanted
to play around the cryptocurrencies
freely
as I said earlier Dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for Content creators but
they were very well receipted users of
Internet forums like Reddit and Twitter
adopted Dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
Dogecoin made it surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically Bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000 for a NASCAR driver Josh
Weiss and in return he printed the logo
and 98 Dodge Coin over this race car
eventually it almost became the mascot
for what crypto should be let's have a
look at who uses Dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants crosses web hosting products
retailer ebook Sellers and travel
Services uses Dogecoin for transaction
these are a few example of companies in
every sector that uses Dogecoin grossers
hello pets gamerheats.com for web
hosting
gamer for products retailer meltdown and
Nordic ebook seller canal and travel
services like Velo leo.it this makes me
curious about the current value of
Dogecoin let's have a look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is
0.059357 USD with a trading volume of 16
billion dollars the circulating supply
of this cryptocurrency is 129 billion
Dogecoin and the max supply of Dogecoin
is not available
how can we buy Dogecoin
so to buy Dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps Step One open a
digital wallet buy you coin is
considered a perfect application for
trading cryptocurrencies Step 2 register
your account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhar card step 4 add your
bank account details step 5 secure your
account by creating a convenient trading
pin that is only accessible by you
and step 6.
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about Dogecoin currently we
have heard a lot of us about the
cryptocurrency Dogecoin and the
shenanigans of its community
did you know that on 20th April 2020
Dogecoin searched its value to one
dollar making this day named after
itself as doste the supporters of
Dogecoin were trying to amplify the
value of it to make it one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called Miner and this is what affected
Dogecoin resulting in the rise of its
value
mining coins of the Dogecoin network is
called Dogecoin mining now let's move
ahead and see what's in this video for
you
first we will have an introduction to
what is Dogecoin
then we will figure out the net worth of
Dogecoin today
we will understand what Dogecoin mining
is
then we will have a comparison of mining
process of Dogecoin with a few other
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
then we will dive into how to mine
Dogecoin
in this segment first we will see types
of Dogecoin mining like pool and solo
then we will see what exactly you
require to start Dogecoin mining What
hardware and software you need for those
coin mining
and then we will understand A New
Concept of Dogecoin mining which is
Dogecoin Cloud mining
and in the end we will analyze whether
Dogecoin mining is profitable or not
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is storage coin
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology also it provides its users a
completely unknown decentralized and
secure environment free from any
third-party interference to make their
transactions
to secure all its transactions this
makes me curious to know what is a net
worth and availability of those coin
today
according to market cap today the
current value of Dogecoin is
0.266 247 USD dollars the circulating
supply of the cryptocurrency is 127
billion Dogecoin
so that brings us to what is Dogecoin
mining
Dogecoin mining is a process of
validating the data blocks of
transactions by solving a complex
mathematical problem and adding them to
the Dogecoin Network
each confirmation of transactions adds a
new block to the Dogecoin Network
miners perform this process Dogecoin
miners are a community of people who
perform complex mathematical Solutions
on the transactions for mining Dogecoin
that makes me wonder what the difference
between Dogecoin Mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining clauses
let's have a comparison between Dogecoin
Mining and the Bitcoin mining process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors first
algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm Dogecoin mining uses
script Bitcoin mining uses sh-256
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the SSG 256 algorithm
making mining easier for miners of the
Dogecoin Network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty Dogecoin is
2798
252 Bitcoin is three trillion 511
billion 60 million
552
899 thus the cruise the Dogecoin is easy
to mine among other cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is the time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
Dogecoin is one minute for Bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at fourth and fifth we have reward
per block and per block USD
it is the amount
in USD to The Miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for Dogecoin is 10 000
dogecoins per block which in USD is
27.36 Dodge coins
for Bitcoin it is 12.5 Bitcoin per block
and in USD it is 86
391.63 Bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine Dogecoin
Dogecoin can be mined in two ways the
first one Dogecoin pool Mining and the
second is solo mining
a Dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
Dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of Mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between Dogecoin pool Mining
and solo mining
in Dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees in Dogecoin
solo mining you don't need to pay any
fees and your mine all by yourself
also in pool mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the poor
one button solo mining the total reward
earned will be received by you only
as on pole mining many people work
together so the Mind blocks more often
and on the other side solo mining could
take a lot of time before one mine their
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in Solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about Dogecoin pool
Mining and solo mining let's proceed
further and see what we need to start
mining Dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us a PC with any operating system
like Windows Linux Ubuntu Etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the
dogecoins you mine which hardware and
software can we use for Dogecoin mining
you will need your PC CPU which should
be powerful enough to mine Dogecoin a
GPU a graphics card can also be used for
mining Dogecoin for example Sapphire
pulse Radeon RX 580 Asus RX Vega 64 and
many more
stripped Asics minor is programmed to
mine script based cryptocurrencies like
Dogecoin like bit Main and Miner L3
bwl21 script Miner Etc
if you are new to Dogecoin mining then
using your PC CPU will be the right
choice and CPU Miner is the most
appropriate software if you are thinking
of mining using GPU or graphics card you
can have a wide range of software
some of the best software is Buddha
Miner which works perfectly with Nvidia
products CG Miner which works with
most GPU hardware and easy Miner is
considered suitable for beginners
script is IC minus are considered to be
very powerful hardware and multi-miner
is excellent with this Hardware moving
ahead let's understand what those coin
Cloud mining is
going Cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine Dogecoin using rented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in Dodge Point mining at a
very low cost making Dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the Dogecoin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance a direct energy cost
this whole concept of Dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
is Dogecoin Mining Profitable
Dogecoin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumptions
hash rate and cost the Dogecoin mining
calculator is used to make it simple in
this calculator
the default value for the latest
Dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
Dogecoin difficulty Target is pre-loaded
for better results Dodge Coin mining's
reward is
44 lakh 44
412.25 dollars per year that is 14
million dollars per year the block time
for Dogecoin is one minute which means
the supply of Dogecoin will never go
down
after deducting mining power costs and
Mining fees the final Daily dosecoin
Mining profit is 22.53 Dogecoin to USD
with the profit margin of positive
81.72 percent also I think Dogecoin
mining is fun
so that is all about Dogecoin mining we
cover what Dogecoin is its value today
and understood Dogecoin Mining and its
Concepts in the previous two videos now
let's proceed further and look at how to
create a Dogecoin wallet and how to use
it let's get started what is Dogecoin
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on a
blockchain technology also it provides
its users a completely unknown
decentralized and secure environment
free from any third-party interference
to make their transactions Dogecoin uses
cryptography to secure all its
transactions now let's proceed further
and have a look at the process of how to
buy Dogecoin
you can buy Dogecoin by following these
Steps step one create a Dogecoin wallet
step 2 locate your specific Dogecoin
address which is a long array of
characters that starts from capital D
followed by any other Capital character
or any number
and step 3 find a source that sells to
each coin and voila buy Dodge coins so
that brings us to what is Dogecoin
wallet
a Dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a real
life wallet Dogecoin wallet consists of
its public and private key connecting it
to the distributed Ledger over the
Dogecoin Network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
Dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user the private key of
your wallet is used to approve
transactions in The Ledger
your wallet's public key is used to
receive dogecoins from other users on
the other hand your wallet's private key
is only used to send those points to
other users in the network so what are
the types of Dogecoin wallet
Dogecoin wallet is of two types digital
Dogecoin wallet and physical Dogecoin
wallet digital Dogecoin wallet is
accessible through the web and you can
also download it according to your
handset or operating system
on the other hand physical Dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible so moving on let's see how to
create a Dogecoin wallet
to create a Dogecoin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
Step 1 choose the correct volume
Dogecoin core followed and multi-tools
wallet have been created and are
maintained by the developers team of
Dogecoin here we will be using the
Dogecoin core wallet as reference
Step 2 download and install the Dogecoin
wallet in your handset
you can also use the official website of
this wallet for your windows
and step 3 open the Dogecoin wallet
application and verify your Dogecoin
wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your Dogecoin wallet now when
you have your Dogecoin wallet in your
hand let's see how you can use it on the
very bottom of the home page of your
wallet there are two options request
coins where you can request those coins
from other users in the Dogecoin Network
and send coins where you can send those
coins to other users in the Dogecoin
Network to receive coins first click on
the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third have the below generated
barcode scanned by the user you wish to
request amount
now the send coins
first type the Dogecoin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now you can use your
Dogecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
Dogecoin so popular despite being in
tough competition with other strong
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin Dogecoin
has never missed an opportunity to be in
the Limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
Community other than that social
platforms like Reddit and Twitter also
promote a Dogecoin to a great extent due
to its fun fact though and the whole
joke story behind it
celebrities like Snoop Dogg Kevin Jonas
Elon Musk also started taking an
interest in Doge point and posting
pictures and comments on their social
media handles which increased The Craze
of Dogecoin all around the world so this
was all about Dogecoin wallet now let's
have a look at the top 5 Dogecoin
wallets of 2021 these are the top 5
Dogecoin wallets of 2021.
Ledger Nano X freezer model T
bananas and Kraken
Kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a Dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it and it
accepts a pretty decent amount of Fiat
money what comes to your mind first when
you hear the word Dogecoin
I'm pretty sure either it's a meme or
Elon Musk well whatever we think of this
cryptocurrency we can't deny the fact
that Dogecoin started as a joke not
turned into the crypto star of the
future
everyone one or the other way knows
about Dogecoin but do you know what
makes it so unique and popular in this
video I will take you through some
amazing top 10 facts about Dogecoin so
let's get started
number one Dogecoin has seven safety
levels
security levels are partially based on
the number of nodes or cryptocurrency
Dogecoin has 1090 nodes which makes it
irresistible to hacking plus sometimes
the traffic increases in the Dogecoin
Network making it more vulnerable to its
security
number two use an interactive community
of followers
among all other cryptocurrencies those
coined today has the biggest community
of followers they genuinely believe that
Dogecoin will rule the future and this
Unity proved to be an advantage for
Dogecoin for instance once China banned
all the payment companies dealing with
Bitcoin
which led to the increase of Dogecoin
Reddit users up to 19 000 in just two
weeks thus the price of Dogecoin
escalated to 300 percent
those coins followers provide full
support to Dogecoin and act in unity to
try every bit to make it more popular
and grow once they raised a fund of 55
000 for a NASCAR driver John Weiss who
in return covered his entire car with
Dogecoin and Reddit alien images
such a beautiful family
number three Dogecoin is the easiest to
buy
the platform for cryptocurrency exchange
provides the most convenient ways to buy
Dogecoin all you need is to create a
digital wallet which can be done on any
cryptocurrency exchange platforms
official website
and choose a reliable exchanger like
Kraken or coinbase
and you will also need some Bitcoins to
exchange it with Doge that's it it is
this simple to trade Dogecoin now you
can get rolling with buying Dogecoin
number four
Dogecoin wallet inspired by Lucky coin
Dogecoin was based on Lucky coin as both
of them use the stripped language
to make Dogecoin more ridiculous Palmer
and Marcus added a weird feature to the
Dogecoin wallet stating that it's minor
could receive either zero or potentially
thousands of free coins to produce new
blocks inspired by one of the quirky
features of Lucky coin
after a while they changed the block
reward to a fixed number of 10 000 to
make it more feasible well I think
Dogecoin needs to be a little different
from these cryptocurrencies as it holds
a different history of original role
to maintain the faith of its Community
it needs to upgrade itself a bit
number five largest circulating supply
of the coin
Dogecoin in the crypto Market holds the
position of the largest circulating
supply of coins since both the founders
of Dogecoin wanted it to be a ridiculous
show they thought of generating as many
Dogecoin unit as possible therefore they
ended up making a circulating supply of
127 million Dogecoin Which is relatedly
higher than the volume of other
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin or
ethereum
till today almost 113 billion dogecoins
are already mine
every day 10 000 new dogecoins are
released in Block Rewards
every minute roughly 14.4 million new
Dodge coins entering into the
circulation every day therefore 5.2
billion dogecoins per year
those coin mining process is one of the
fastest
at least
98.9815 Dogecoin can be mined every day
those can use a script encryption which
cannot be harvested using Asics making
an easier and faster to mine other than
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
also the block rate is one block per
minute this provides an excellent
opportunity for miners to mine more
blocks and earn as many block rewards as
possible and minor can make make at
least 10 000 dogecoins as a block reward
number seven market capitalization over
435 million dollar
when Dogecoin was first introduced to
the crypto world it was supposed to be
taken as a joke
but the people very well received it
this led its most value than 435 Million
by 2017.
I don't know about others but this value
of money is a lot
imagine if you had invested 1000 on
Dogecoin in January 2017 and then sold
it all after a month do you know how
much money you would have earned almost
twenty two thousand dollars
today the market cap worth of Dogecoin
is 70 billion dollars
making it the fourth most valued coin
number eight huge fan following in the
entertainment world
Dogecoin seems to have gained a lot of
popularity among celebrities like Snoop
Dogg
Kevin Jonas Eugene Simmons and Elon Musk
recently Kevin Jonas the eldest Jonas
brother posted saying all I was saying
Doge showing his interest in dogecon
Gene Simmons from the classic rock band
KISS also made a massive Revelation that
he owns six figures worth of Dogecoin
well some have been posting funny
pictures or comments to promote this
crypto over social media and some have
been trying to change the perception of
people for Dogecoin
number nine widely represented on social
media
Dogecoin has been widely represented on
social media since its origin platforms
like Reddit and Twitter adopted Dogecoin
in its initial days and started
promoting it by tipping Dogecoin to
their content creators which turned out
to be a massive success for Dogecoin
Dogecoin began to catch the attention of
every user on these platforms I feel
Twitter has been a slam book for
togecoin as everyday one or the other
person tweets about Dogecoin there later
other platforms like Tick Tock also
started developing their interest in
Dogecoin in summer 2020 Tick Tock
introduced a Dogecoin challenge to
encourage people to invest in Dogecoin
number 10 Elon Musk the flag bearer of
Dogecoin
when deutschwan is mentioned how can we
not talk about Tesla ceol on Mars but
the question is what makes him love
Dogecoin so much
recently one of his followers tweeted
and asked him why do you love those so
much he reacted that he loves dogs and
loves memes
he has been so active with Dogecoin by
constantly tweeting about it hit his
first tweet was torched to the Moon
which grabbed the attention of both the
followers of Elon and followers of
Dogecoin this led to the overnight
increase in the price and popularity of
Dogecoin later he posted a still from
The Lion King movie which with his space
in place of Rafiki holding Simba with
the face of Dogecoin stating that he
will always have dogecoins back
his most recent tweet was on Wednesday
May 5 2021 the Dogecoin father SNL May
8. which is a reference to both his
constant tweets on Dogecoin as well as
his appearance on Saturday Night Live on
May 8 2020. in the previous few videos
we learned about what Dogecoin is and we
also had a comparison between ethereum
and Bitcoin in which we talked about
their features and Concepts behind the
mechanism
but in this video we will compare and
contrast Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
based on a few related Concepts around
these cryptocurrencies
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top
cryptocurrencies and will also let us
figure out the individuality of each one
of them
Dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by Shiva inu's
popular meme AKA Doge but it was very
well received by everyone in the crypto
world and today it is the fourth top
cryptocurrency
Dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
Bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013. Bitcoin enables
transparent and decentralized
peer-to-peer transaction
Bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to National currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
Ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after Bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
it had himself as a Computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
daps or decentralized application
now let's move on the comparison between
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language
mining process
monetary policies
transactions
today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
Dogecoin uses stripped cryptography for
mining the blocks of the Dogecoin
Network
in comparison Bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm for mining its blocks
in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses this
algorithm for mining its transactions
language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized Hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
sh-256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific Network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
Dogecoin is considered to be an all coin
for Bitcoin both Dogecoin and Bitcoin
use the same programming language
C plus plus it is a stack based
programming language used to give
Bitcoin and Dogecoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of these
cryptocurrency let's get to the
following very important parameter which
is mining process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is
mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public Ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
Dogecoin and Bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in the networks and that is
proof of work
all the ethereum miners also mine the
unvalidated transactions using the proof
of work method it aims to switch to
proof of stake because it will make its
Network more immune to centralization
energy efficient and more vital support
for shared chains
now we have come to the following
present which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the compete
and monetary or authority to control the
money supply and Achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth
dogecoin's policy is defined by its
block reward paid to its miners whereas
Bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block report
having event is when reward of mining
Bitcoin is cut in half and it also cuts
the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
Bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each blog and which is set to get
reduced to 6.25 by 2024.
an ethereum's block reward is too ether
per block
Dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block Bitcoin takes 10 minutes to
generate one block
and ethereum generates one block every
14 seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary due to
this over time mining blocks will become
more complex
now moving on to the falling bearizon
which is transactions
Dogecoin is the fastest and can complete
70 transaction in one second and takes
just two to three minutes to confirm a
transaction
Bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second and takes 10
minutes or more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
Dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like Reddit and Twitter
Bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for Fiat money and is used
primarily for real world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
Networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of Dogecoin on today's date is
0.2992 dollars
Bitcoin being the highest is 34 857.58
and ethereum holds a value of
2356.58 dollars
now we have reached the last comparison
of Dogecoin Bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of Dogecoin is
1.7 billion
Bitcoin very low as compared to Dogecoin
is just 21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion Dogecoin has
already been mined
for Bitcoin 18 million Bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this graph you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin on the
extreme left you can see first the
options that you can use according to
your requirements like if you want to
know about Dogecoin you can go for the
first option that is
www.dochcoin.com which will lead you to
the official website of Dogecoin if you
want to chat with the executives of coin
Market regarding Dogecoin then you can
go for the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform and
you can also change it according to your
choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Dogecoin which
is 38 billion thirty eight hundred forty
nine million
469 098
it is the total value of Dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 billion 700 million 795 906.
it is the capitalization when Max supply
of Dogecoin was in circulation and on
the right side just before total Supply
you can see the volume of Dogecoin one
billion 779 million
417 647.
it is the value of Dogecoin traded in 24
hours next is Bitcoin similar to
Dogecoin you can see the red box on the
right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of Dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
Bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www.bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of Bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of Bitcoin which is
651 billion 713 million ten thousand
seven hundred fifty three
it is the total value of Bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization that
is 732 billion
387 million two hundred sixty two
thousand six hundred ninety
and on the right side just before the
total Supply you can see the volume of
Bitcoin that is 30 billion
249 million 939 865.
ethereum is no different from Dogecoin
and Bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.ethereum.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is 273 billion
576 million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand Forty Nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is 24 billion 100 1 million
779
346 but in the end all these top
cryptocurrencies Dogecoin Bitcoin and
ethereum share a few similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized Authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all their
transactions are verified and validated
before processing after complete
verification further transaction process
takes place also all of them have a
large network of independent nodes meet
Susan an aspiring painter she wishes to
conduct an online painting exhibition
for all her digital artworks however as
the exhibition is online she is worried
that her paintings won't be secure as
anyone could easily Forge or replicate
them her friend Mark came to her rescue
with an idea of nft he suggested that
Susan could buy nfts for all her
paintings as nfts are trustworthy easily
transferable and will also maintain her
ownership rights on her artworks Susan
had no idea what nfts were so Mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind by creating a unique digital
signature which defines the ownership of
your assets and that can be bought and
sold for real money cryptocurrency or
any other asset like a non-fungible
token AKA nft non-fungible tokens means
that they are not interchangeable and
each of them represents unique assets
owned by a specific person on the other
hand fungible tokens are interchangeable
and can be divided into smaller units to
form the same value for example a 100
bill is fungible as you can exchange it
with five twenty dollar bills or two
fifty dollar bills but the painting of
The Last Supper is non-fungible as it
cannot be generated in bulk even if it
is copied it will not be authentic each
nft contains distinguishable information
like who owns the digital asset and who
sold it making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to
forward such a certificate it will
secure her painting's originality
after learning what nft is Susan was
curious to know how exactly nft Works
nft basically creates a blockchain-based
digital certificate for your digital
Collectibles including Games music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork A Unique identity the
underlying technology and the
programming language used by nfts are
the same as other cryptocurrencies such
as blockchain and the programming
language ethash or script nft majorly
exists on ethereum blockchain the
distributed public Ledger that records
all the transactions however nft is
quite different from these
cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and ethereum
are fungible tokens which means if you
trade Bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money on the
other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands crypto punks is
a remarkable example of nft it enables
you to buy sell and store 10 000
Collectibles with a proof of ownership
being stored on the ethereum blockchain
after exploring how nfts work Susan was
convinced and bought nfts for all her
paintings due to this her artworks were
secured from any kind of forgery and
also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear all in
all her exhibition was a complete
success similarly nft has proved itself
to be a boon in the lives of many others
like Jack Dorsey the CEO and co-founder
of Twitter with his very first and
famous tweet just setting up my Twitter
and Vignesh sundarsan famously known as
medicovan who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people owing
to its increasing popularity people are
now willing to pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars for nfts
nft has enhanced media exposure and
special perks for aspiring artists like
Susan on social media this popularity of
nft creates new opportunities for new
art platforms motivating people to buy
art from internet platforms and
promoting copyright or originality of
digital assets so here's a question for
you what makes any item non-fungible a
exchangeability b unique digital
signature C tradability D distributed
public Ledger please give it a thought
and drop your answers in the comments
section below many experts in the crypto
industry say that around 40 percent of
new crypto users will use nfts as their
entry point as a result of its growing
popularity nft could represent a more
significant part of the digital economy
in the future
in this video we will explore about
Shiba in a coin and we'll go through
some of really exciting Concepts and
components revolving around it
so how did this Shiba inucoin originate
the Shiva inucoin was created in August
2020 by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi and Indian
it was intended as an altcoin of
Dogecoin which itself was created as an
altcoin of Bitcoin
and this meme coin has been named after
the Japanese dog breed Shiva Inu
it feels like the shiba inu coin was
built into existence and is now insanely
popular among major crypto exchanges
through the power of its following crowd
memes and a very cute dog now we know
how it originated so let's have a look
at what is Shiba in a coin
Shiva inucoin is a decentralized
community building cryptocurrency or we
can say an experiment developed within
the shiba inu ecosystem and built on top
of the ethereum blockchain network like
many other coins
it is a meme coin launched as a rival of
Dogecoin a doge killer both Dogecoin and
sheepcoin were made in a humorous manner
but cheap coin has already taken over
some Dogecoin markets attracting a lot
of attention and Rising as a popular
choice among investors
especially after such market crash of
cryptos like Bitcoin and ethereum
but what is the difference between Shiba
in a coin and Dogecoin
although put Shiva inucoin and Dogecoin
are main coins and share the same tree
of origin both of them differ a lot from
each other at the same time
and the very first difference between
them is the Sheep coin is a token and
Dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development
Shiba Inu coins or sheep coins are built
on and powered by the ethereum network
while Dogecoin has been developed using
the same technology as Bitcoin
then is use cases
sheepcoin is still working upon price
more due to its high popularity than
utility but on the other hand Dogecoin
has already established itself to some
extent as a medium of online payments
there is value according to coin market
cap the current value of sheepcoin is
0.00007378 dollars and that of Dogecoin
is 0.261711
and at last availability the
availability of sheep cointel today is
394 million and for Dogecoin it is 130
billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind why is Shiba in a coin so
popular
Shiba Inu coin is majorly popular
because of two reasons
Tesla found the Elon Musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a Sheba Pub that hyped the crypto
market and its prices Rose by 300
percent
on the other hand its prices fell by
around 40 after the founder of ethereum
blockchain network metallic buterin
donated 50 trillion Shiba Inu coins to
Indian government
for covet Relief Fund of an Indian
crypto entrepreneur Sandeep naival
so now that we know about Shiba in a
coin and its Concepts let's have a look
at what is the future of Shiba Inu coins
is only known as a meme coin it's
increasing popularity and people's
interest in participating in it is
pointing towards a different but bright
future
according to
investingcube.com the Sheba coin is
predicted to rise again
although there isn't much movement among
this token and its value active buyers
could help its value rise the value
could rise to
0.00001040 in a more active buyers
Market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount due to its popularity
in future it can have a significant
influence over large investors of the
crypto Market
in this video we will explore some are
very interesting and important aspects
of Solana crypto
first we will understand what is Selana
then we will look into what is a soul
token or Sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of Solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method the Solana use
after which we will understand how
Solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of Solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of Solana holes for itself
and at last we will look into real-like
users of Selana
so without doing Much Ado let's start
the video
let's explore what is salana
Selana is a cryptocurrency that is used
to pay for transactions but a
decentralized Computing Network
Solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability by combining proof of stake
and proof of History consensus as a
result Solana promises to be capable of
processing 50 000 transactions per
second while maintaining
decentralization
now the question arises what is the SL
token or Soul token
so that has ecosystem uses the SL token
as its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the Solana cluster in exchange for
running on-chain programs or so to find
their results
it can also be used to make micro
payments known as lamp boards
now when we are talking so much about
Solana crypto let's also dive down and
explore how and when exactly it came
into existence
established the Solana platform in 2017.
before launching Solana
worked at Qualcomm after working as a
software engineer at Dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge with
compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties in
the Bitcoin anything in blockchain
with the help of Eric Williams and
Solana's CTO Greg Fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol with increased
scalability the team now has experience
from leading companies around the world
including Apple Google Microsoft Intel
Twitter Dropbox and others
now that we know what Solana is and all
about its background let me ask you a
question recently Solana joined hands
with two foundations to raise a fund of
5 million dollars to encourage the next
wave of creators and fans onto crypto
networks so comment down your answers in
the comment section below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it unique and popular
scalable Solana uses proof of history
and a number of other group
groundbreaking features to allow the
network to scale at the rate of Moore's
Law
cost for applications with billions of
users Solana is designed to keep feasts
low
so you will never have to worry about
Rising fees as your user base grows
composable the single Global state of
Solana guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history but what exactly is it
that we will discuss within the type of
consensus method Solana uses
the Solana Network which has 200
physically different nodes can handle a
throughput of more than 50 000 DPS
when using gpus is one of the most
performant permissionless blockchain
unlike Bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm as the system
decentralized clock Solana uses the
proof of History technique
you can use proof of History to
construct historical records that verify
and event occurred at a given point in
time this algorithm is a verifiable
delay function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps to evaluate
each transaction or even that is
examined will be assigned a unique hash
an account that can be verified publicly
and effectively
the account serves as a cryptographic
timestamp allowing us to determine when
each transaction or event occur
this provides increased throughput and
efficiency within the Solana Network
now let me know about its structure and
mechanism let's explore how Solana works
now we know Solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time of a transaction known as proof of
History
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
Step 1 input the details of transactions
performed in the network to its leader
Step 2 leader will now efficiently
sequence and organize the messages so
that they can be processed by another
nodes
step 3 the leader then executes the
transactions based on the Ram's current
state
step 4 the completed States transactions
and signature will then be published by
the leader to the verifiers or
replication nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation the verifiers will perform
the same transactions on their copies of
the state and publish their signatures
are at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use the published
confirmations as votes now that we know
everything about Solana let's have a
look at the price and volume of Solana
according to market capitalization
the Solana Network can process more than
50 000 transactions in one second and
the current price of it is 30 dollars
with a circulating volume of 270 million
as soil coins which is quite impressive
considering its time span in market
capitalization as well as compared to
other cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the Solana holds
for itself
also being a new project has delivered
on its Promises of speed and scalability
its token price has also done well at
attracting investors attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage are still in the early stages
we won't know whether Solana speed make
a significant difference in the Bitcoin
real
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages will only occur as more
people utilize it and more use cases
emerge real life uses of Selana
serum radium bone peda Orca oxygen and
Phantom wallet are some of the recent
projects that Solana is working with
well this is all about Solana crypto
first we will explore what is binance
coin following that we will understand
how it works
then we will dive down deeper and
explore a very interesting concept
followed by Finance which is BNB burning
then we will look at the uses of the
binance coin
followed by its benefits
after that we will come across some
important factors to consider before
investing in the binance coin and at the
end we will see the pricing dynamics of
the binance coin the first thing that we
are going to explore is what is binance
coin so binance coin or BNB is a
cryptocurrency that may be used on the
binance cryptocurrency exchange to trade
and pay fees as of January 2018 the
binance exchange was the world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange conducting over
1.4 million transactions every second
this coin is limited to 200 million BNB
tokens and runs on the ethereum
blockchain using the standard erc20
protocol
as an incentive binance coin users
receive a reduction in transaction cost
on the finance Exchange
other cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin
ethereum Litecoin and others can be
exchanged or traded for BNB
now let's move on and see how it works
BNB is a crypto asset that fluctuates in
value as individuals use and trade it
similar to other digital assets on the
market
DNB can be stored in suitable wallets
obtained from crypto exchanges and send
directly to others for payments and
other purposes
but there is a whole working initiative
behind this process binance layer 1
blockchain is much to form the BNB chain
previously the binance mark chain and
the binance chain binance design the
blockchain for best performance when it
comes to trading on chain when building
the pnb chain and binance Dex
it is also based on this newly developed
chain furthermore BNB chain transactions
are powered by the BNB gas token which
stands for build and build previously
also known as binance coin
now BNB Beacon chain and BNB smart chain
make up the BNB chain the former is
concerned with BNB chain governance
which allows BNB holders to vote and
stake their coins then it's a consensus
layer that's compatible with the
ethereum virtual machine and has
multi-chain hubs
now moving on let's have a look at the
BNB burn concept
binance uses 20 of its profit each
quarter to buy back and burn binance
coins completely destroying them binance
has consistently performed quarterly
burns the most recent being on October
17 2020 which was the 13th quarterly
burn
binance will continue to burn BNB coins
every quarter until it has purchased and
destroyed 100 million binance coins or
half of the total Supply
Finance coin Supply is reduced as a
result of the procedure and its Rarity
is affected which could affect the
assets value
binance also has a program called the
BNB Pioneer burn program which asses
cases when BNB holders have
unrecoverably lost BNB and compensate
them by reducing the amount from the
next BNB bone
now let's have a look at some of the
uses of the binance coin
the finance coin like other developing
cryptocurrencies has a variety of
applications outside of the binance
exchange including
first is trading binance coin can be
exchanged for other cryptocurrencies on
a variety of exchanges depending on the
exchanges regulations
next is transaction fees on the binance
exchange
users can use BNB to pay for
transactions on the binance exchange and
earn a hefty discount
next we have is credit card payments on
crypto.com BNB can be used to pay for
crypto credit card bills
next is premium processing Merchants can
accept BNB as a form of payments giving
customers more options in terms of
payment methods
next we have is booking travel
arrangements and certain websites BNB
can be used to book hotels flights as
well
next is entertainment now BNB is used
for a variety of purposes in the
entertainment industries from paying for
virtual gifts to purchasing lottery
tickets as well
next in the line is investment
binance coin can be used to invest
in stocks ETFs and other assets on a
variety of platforms
and at last is loans and transfers on
some platforms BNB can be used as a
collateral for loans there are also apps
that allow users to use Finance coin to
split bills and pay friends and
relatives
so now that we have covered the basics
of the binance coin let's have a look at
some of its benefits that makes it
unique
starting with quick transactions when
you trade on the exchange with BNB
you'll have access to the platform
property matching engine which can
handle up to 1.4 million orders per
second finding the appropriate
transaction is always possible and using
BNB makes it even easier and more
reliable
next is secure and trustworthy binance
already has millions of cryptocurrency
users and dealers who rely on the
platform and believe in the security and
protection aspects of this exchange to
keep your funds safe The Exchange uses a
multi-cluster and multi-tire system
framework as well as the secure assets
funds for users next is trade multiple
cryptocurrencies
you can trade more than 150
cryptocurrencies on the exchange with
BNB thanks to a rapid secure and low
cost transaction matching technology
aside from that BNB has its own trading
pair to fulfill your individual training
needs there's no need to seek elsewhere
moving ahead is Trading discount
you will also get a 50 discount on your
trading charge if you use BNB with
traditional payment methods if you buy
ten thousand dollar worth of coins
you'll be charged 10 and if you use BNB
though the trading charge is cut in half
so you'll just have to spend five
dollars next is spending binance coin
you can utilize BNB in a variety of ways
in addition to having a smooth
experience within the binance ecosystem
and receiving transaction fee discounts
several service providers particularly
in the travel and hotel Industries
accepted using BNB you can purchase
dinner or a new phone as well
now let's have a look at some of the
factors that you should consider before
investing in binance coin
now binance coins can be used to invest
in some icos listed on binance Launchpad
program The binance Exchange will
publish new cryptocurrencies and the use
of binance coins will provide a seamless
Marketplace for trading a range of
virtual tokens
binance will eventually become the
decentralized finance exchanges
principle currency
the Visa debit card of Monaco the
world's first payment and cryptocurrency
platform and the platform's mobile app
also support binance coin
now as we are talking about Investments
let's have a look at the Peak at BNB
pricing and Dynamics
bnb's pricing has traditionally varied
in a similar way to the price of other
crypto assets traded on the market
binance coins market capitalization has
increased over time topic 70 billion
dollars BNB was also sold for around
0.10 per token during finances Ico
today the current value of BNB is
286.67 dollars with the market
capitalization of 46 billion 801 million
two hundred ten thousand eighty one
dollars BNB has seen a tremendous
increase in value since its Ico reaching
a high of more than six hundred dollar
per coins at time is it wise to invest
in binance coin well if purchase join
and sold at the right times it's
conceivable and past price growth
resulted in profit however only time can
tell where the price of BNB will go in
the future
first we will understand what is Ripple
followed by what is xrp
then we will see the working of Ripple
then we will learn how to mine xrp after
that we will have a comparison between
Bitcoin and ripple then we will explore
the pros and cons of Ripple after which
we will see how you can actually use
Ripple
followed by we will see how can we
buyable
and in the end we will see if it is a
good investment or not so let's get
started with the video
first let's understand what is Ripple so
the firm behind xrp is Ripple which is a
payment settlement systems and currency
engine Network that can handle
transactions all across the world
basically it's acts as a trusted
intermediary between two parties in a
transaction
as the network can be immediately
validated that the transaction was
completed successfully
Ripple can ease the exchange of a wide
range
of Fiat currencies and cryptocurrencies
including Bitcoin so when users utilize
the network to make a transaction the
network takes a modest charge in the
form of xrp
and ripple was built from the ground up
to be a swift a leading money transfer
Network successor or to otherwise
replace sentimental layer between large
financial institutions so this raises
the question of what is XR so let's have
a look at it the xrp Ledger created by
Jade mikhailer Arthur Brito and David
Schwartz is a blockchain that runs xrp
Mach 11 Brito would go on to form Ripple
which would employ xrp to enable Network
transactions
you can acquire xrp as an investment
crypto to trade from other
cryptocurrencies or as a way to fund
Ripple Network transactions xrp is
blockchain in particular drifid from
that of most other cryptocurrencies
other cryptocurrencies give anyone who
can solve difficult equations quickly
access to their transaction ledgers and
verification processes Ripple
transactions on the other hand are safe
since the majority of Ledger holders
must agree to the verification before
they can be added also the Ripple
Network which employs xrp is somewhat
centralized and uses a consensus
protocol this means while anyone can
download its validation software it has
its own node list that consumers can use
to validate transactions based on which
participants they believe are least
likely to cheat them
so now that we know the basics of Ripple
and xrp let's have a look at working of
Ripple two verify transactions the xrp
cryptocurrency employs a consensus
protocol validators verify that proposed
transactions are valid by comparing them
to the most recent version of The xrp
Ledger
now a transaction must be accepted by
the majority of validators in order to
be verified once it's verified the
transaction is then added to the
blockchain so now that we know it's
working let's have a look at how Ripple
can be mined by its users ripples or
Excel is created using a crypto Ledger
that is akin to blockchain technology
and is Federated by financial
institutions and payment processor
Networks
while it is true that Ripple xrp cannot
be mined by miners it is technically
viable to do it using other
cryptocurrencies so one of the most
viable techniques for mining xrp is to
mine other cryptocurrencies such as
Bitcoin and ethereum and then transfer
the mine crypto for ripple through
exchanges
and that's how the mining is done so as
we have discussed all the basics of
Ripple let's type down Depot and have a
look at how it differs from Bitcoin to
verify transactions and distribute new
currencies Bitcoin employs mining
participants set up mining devices to
solve complex mathematical equations
with the first person to solve the
equation winning the right to add a
block of transaction to bitcoin's
network
then participants receive Bitcoin
rewards for each block they are in the
exchange for Bitcoin mining whereas the
consensus protocol used by XR plan
confirms transactions for a transaction
to be accepted it must receive the
approval of a majority of validators who
actually review it then Bitcoin
transaction confirms can take several
minutes and are associated with
significant transaction charges due to
the intricate
and expensive nature of mining utilized
in the cryptocurrency but on the other
hand xrp transactions are instantly
confirmed and having cheap transaction
fees the user is charged a small amount
of xrp each time a transaction is
completed on the Ripple Network
now the supply of Bitcoin is limited to
21 million which means there will be
never more than 21 million Bitcoin the
artificial scarcity of 12 Bitcoin has
sparked investor interest in the
currency's potential as a safe haven but
in contrast at the time of introduction
1 billion xrp was pre-mined and
progressively distributed under the
market by the company's major investors
next we have when miners discover
Bitcoins they are released and added to
the network they have no set release
date and their supplies is largely
determined by Network speeds and the
difficulty of the algorithm used to
create coins on the other hand the
release of xrp is controlled by a smart
contract
according to an inbuilt smart contract
Ripple is expected to distribute a
maximum of 1 billion xrp tokens per
month so the current circulation is 55
billion till now
so this was all about the difference
between Bitcoin and ripple and I'm
pretty sure that till now you have
understood all the basic knowledge about
triple so let's move ahead and look into
some of the pros and cons
of purple
though xrp transactions are quick and
inexpensive ripples consensus protocol
is perhaps less secure than other crypto
transaction processing Technologies
next is even though Financial
organizations are already using ripples
payment Network ripples Financial
Partners primarily use triple net rather
than xrp cryptocurrency
next we have is small company owners and
individuals who can utilize xrp to make
safe money transactions yet because it
is administered by a private Corporation
and because of the SEC litigation Ripple
has sparked the debate
and for foreign currency transfers xrp
can be utilized as a British currency
but in the United States buying Sarpy is
quite challenging so now that we know
its pros and cons Also let's have a look
how you can actually use Ripple xrp can
be used in the same way as any digital
currency for transaction or as a
possible investment other sorts of
transactions such as currency exchange
potentially be processed using the
Ripple Network for example instead of
dealing with the currency conversion
directly through a bank or money
changing exchange you may first exchange
your US dollars for xrp on the Ripple
Network and then use them to buy euros
rather than paying the healthy cost that
Banks and money transmission businesses
May demand this can be a lot fast and
less expensive option
so now that we know everything about
triple let's explore how can we actually
buy Ripple so all you need is sign up
for an account on an exchange that sells
ripples xrp cryptocurrency to buy it
then using any of the exchanges allowed
payment methods buy it here are a few
places where you can get xrp Q coin
uphold and coin mama
now the question is
repel a good investment
so xrp
is a risky investment that is not for
the faint of out
however if you feel Ripple will succeed
as a payment system it may be worthwhile
to invest in xrp so just be sure you're
not gambling with money you can't afford
to lose
well this was all about what is Ripple
recently you all must have noticed that
the crypto Market has caused quite a
buzz in social media and other online
forums and perhaps even in your dinner
time conversations
but what is all this commotion about
this is about the recent downfall of
cryptocurrencies in the crypto Market
in this video we will let you through
some very important aspects of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency
first of all we will understand what
cryptocurrency and crypto Market are
after that we will understand how the
market works
then we will look into the reasons for
the market crash of cryptocurrency
and how it has affected people at all
levels
then we will figure out the factors that
can help the market to grow again
and at last we will look into the future
of cryptocurrency and crypto Market
so let's start with the very first
aspect that is what cryptocurrency and
crypto Market are
a cryptocurrency is a kind of virtual or
digital currency that works on
blockchain technology a public Ledger
enforced by distributed network of
computers
it works as a medium of exchange online
to buy goods and services and make
payments like for example Bitcoin
ethereum Dogecoin these are some of the
popular cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference which
means it is not issued or controlled by
any government or Central Authority
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which uses encryption and
decryption to secure the data
crypto Market is where you can trade
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency trading is
an act of speculating the price movement
of cryptocurrency without taking
ownership of the underlying coins
through a trading account or by buying
and selling the underlying coins through
an exchange
you can buy cryptocurrency if you think
it will rise in value or sell them if
you think it will fall
now let's understand how it works
the price of cryptocurrency is quoted in
traditional currencies such as the US
dollar I never take ownership of the
cryptocurrency itself one can buy and
sell a cryptocurrency through their
trading account or via exchange which
helps them speculate on whether the
chosen cryptocurrency will rise or fall
in value
both buy and sell are leveraged products
which means you only need to put up a
small amount as a deposit known as
margin to gain total exposure to the
underlying Market
your profit or loss is majorly
calculated based on the total size of
your position so leverage can affect
your profits as well as your losses if
the market moves against you
so that makes me question what the
reasons behind the market crash of
cryptocurrency are
on 19th May 2021 the crypto Market saw a
massive drop in prices or
cryptocurrencies including Bitcoin
ethereum and BNB crashing up to 30
percent within a span of just 24 hours
this game in the backdrop of the Chinese
Regulators announcing a ban of
cryptocurrency
China has banned payment companies and
financial institutions from providing
any services such as registration
trading clearing and settlement related
to cryptocurrency transactions
this announcement made by China broke
the markets back
and then the Panic increased because
Tesla announced that they would not
favor Bitcoin on environmental concerns
anymore therefore they will not accept
any payment made by Bitcoin
and also there are rumors of IRS
investigation into the largest crypto
exchange platform binance which also has
weakened investors resolution to invest
more in crypto Market
now we know the reasons behind the
crypto market crash so let's take a look
at how it has affected people at all
levels
the crypto Market means different things
to different people it is an object of
speculation that consumes almost all the
media coverage about the space to many
people for them the day crypto Market
crashed was a black day as they faced a
tremendous loss of the leverage invested
in cryptocurrencies even the Bloomberg
Galaxy crypto index launched 19.2
percent in its worst slide in more than
a year
and to others the crypto Market is more
than a speculative instrument for them
this incident proved to be a huge
opportunity as they got a chance to
uncover problems of the system of the
crypto market like high fees to trade at
the most crucial moments and find
solution to these problems by adding
more capacity and efficiency to the
system
so now we have covered everything about
the market crash of cryptocurrency let's
dive into the factors that can help the
market to grow again
despite their dramatic downturn these
cryptocurrencies have consistently
recovered from their downtime people in
the crypto Market systems have termed
this decline as a short-term correction
long-term investors like microstrategy
call this crash a buying opportunity of
these cryptocurrencies and is investing
more to stabilize them
many people believe that what they
witnessed in the last few days was the
liquidation of the leverage long
positions followed by a panic sell-off
and is considered a very normal
phenomenon in thin markets like
cryptocurrency
they believe that this situation can be
thought down by extensive adoption of
cryptocurrency and constant
participation in the crypto Market
well this whole scenario makes me
question what the future cryptocurrency
and crypto Market holds
cryptocurrency is a highly speculative
and volatile investment and it may or
may not succeed over time
therefore there is no guarantee for
these cryptocurrencies that all will
always recover from this type of Market
crashes
a few Experts of the crypto Market
saying that investors should hold a
long-term view of the digital assets
Market as they will bounce back swiftly
also small investors should be better
off staying away from the market as this
current volatility can be overwhelming
for them
and some experts suggest that holding on
to these cryptos will be a wise option
and small investors should buy these
cryptos slowly and steadily through a
systematic plan
therefore if you're thinking about
investing in cryptocurrency be sure you
know what you're getting into although
the crypto Market is lucrative keep in
mind that there's always a chance that
sometimes cryptocurrencies are not able
to bounce back let's have a look at the
top crypto trading platform in 2022 but
before diving right into the list let's
have a quick and crisp understanding of
what crypto trading actually means
so taking a financial on the price
direction of individual cryptocurrencies
against the dollar or against any other
cryptocurrency is what crypto trading is
all about
cfds or contract for difference are a
popular way of trading cryptocurrencies
because they offer more flexibility
leverage and the ability to trade both
long and short positions
also it's essential to consider things
like supported assets fees
payment methods and security when
considering a cryptocurrency trading
platform so we have also considered
these factors to give you a better idea
of which platform will be the best for
you
so now that we have a basic idea of what
crypto trading is let's dive into the
list of top crypto trading platforms for
2022. the first platform in the list is
coinbase
for many first-time cryptocurrency
buyers coinbase has become the go-to
exchange the platform has the appearance
and feel of an online banking tool which
the maturity of consumers are already
familiar with making the transfer to
crypto investing simple
coinbase is the finest cryptocurrency
exchange overall as well as the best
cryptocurrency exchange for beginners it
supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrencies and provide a high
level of security
it's also wonderful alternative for
expert Traders because it offers an
advanced trading platform coinbase Pro
in addition to being a beginner friendly
platform
so let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for coinbase
it supports more than 150 Plus cryptos
for trading with the transaction fee
ranging between zero percent to 0.60
percent also the minimum deposit of
purchase price should be at least two
dollars now let's have a look at pros
and cons
coinbase offers large volume of
cryptocurrencies
for to trade for it provides smooth
experience to beginners as well as offer
easy trading to advance members of it it
also provides liquidity and ease on its
platform
now cons the customer service provided
by them is not up to the mark as well as
coinbase.com is an Institutional account
which means you don't have access to
your private keys
moving on next we have is crypto.com
crypto.com offers a diverse digital
asset ecosystem that includes is its own
blockchain the crypto.org a native token
known as cro a crypto Visa card yield
generating crypto products and more it
was chosen as the top mobile crypto
exchange application because it offers a
comprehensive digital asset trading and
investing environment that you can
access from your smartphone
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for crypto.com
it supports more than 250 Plus cryptos
for trading with a transaction fee
ranging between 0.04 percent to 0.40
percent also the minimum deposit or
purchase price should be at least one
dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
crypto.com supports a huge range of
cryptocurrencies to trade for and other
crypto related services like payments
and asset evolution
now moving towards cons it fees is
relatively High also the customer
service is a little poor and stagnant
next in the list we have is Gemini
Gemini stands out as a sign that
prioritizes security and compliance hot
wallet insurance is provided by the New
York based exchange to ensure that user
funds are protected in the event of a
security comprise because it has
comprehensive security protocols ensures
customer cash and is SOC 2 certified
Gemini is the most secure crypto
Exchange
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for Gemini
it only supports 75 plus cryptos for
trading with the transaction fee ranging
between 0.99 to 2.99 also it has a
minimum deposit or Portuguese price and
it varies according to the asset
invested
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
Gemini is available in all 50 states of
United States with extremely liquid
Market
all the funds stored in the wallets are
perfectly insured and secure also its UI
is pretty strong
coming to its cons many traders in it
have high cost also as compared to other
crypto trading platforms it supports
less cryptocurrencies as well
now moving on to the next platform in
the list we have binance
the most appealing feature of binance is
its low cost when compared to other
exchanges beginners will appreciate the
simple Buy sell option while
professional Traders will appreciate the
in-depth basic and advanced trading
platforms
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for binance it supports
more than 500 plus cryptos for trading
with a transaction fee ranging between
0.10 to 0.50 also it has no minimum
deposit or purchase price of 50 dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
purchase piece is non-imediate as well
as instant also huge variety of coins is
available on its platform along with
this it offers various other services
coming to the cons once the verification
of account was hampered it is not yet
available in United States and its
corporate structure is pretty opaque
next we have is
Kraken
Kraken is one of the world's most
well-known Bitcoin exchanges in the
early days of the crypto Market it
established itself as the go-to site for
professional investors it has retained
its image as a trustworthy and
professional trading venue it has some
of the lowest fees in the cryptocurrency
exchange world it's also a top pick for
experienced Traders as it allows
leverage and Futures Trading as well as
enables complex order types now let's
have a look at the account prerequisites
for Kraken
basically it supports more than 120 plus
cryptos for trading with a small
transaction fee ranging between 0.00 to
0.26 also it has minimum deposit or
purchase price of minimum one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
supports a large range of cryptocurrency
with minimum fee and also provide the
Traders more Market liquidity
coming to the cons not all states in U.S
can accept it as options for financing
your account are limited
next in the list we have bitstamp
bitstamp is one of the most cost
effective Bitcoin exchanges it offers a
simple pricing structure that bases your
trading fees on your 30-day trading
volume
for users with less than
ten thousand dollars on bitstamp the
highest trading cost is merely zero
point five zero percent with pros and
cons
in terms of trading fees with stamp is
one of the top cryptocurrency exchanges
trade view a real-time trading platform
is also available this version contains
more extensive charting and trading
forms this platform offers a diverse
range of coins including many of the
most popular as well as some lesser
known cryptos and the cons are while
bitstem offers a good selection of
cryptocurrencies there are a significant
ones that aren't available
allows you to onpass money but there are
a few drawbacks as well in 2015 hackers
who successfully in launching a Fizz
fishing salt against bitstem workers
which resulted in a security breach
following bitstamp we have bit mark
bitmart is a global Bitcoin exchange
with over 180 locations users can
purchase sell and store over 1000
different digital currencies and tokens
investors wishing to add newly launched
or obscure crypto assets to the
portfolios while likely find what they
are searching for on this exchange as it
offers more assets and trading pairs
than its Market leading counterparts
let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for bitmap bitmap offers 1
000 Plus cryptos for trading with a very
small transaction fee that ranges
between
0.045 to 0.25 percent
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 30 when purchasing
via big mark for spot trading the price
is not published yet
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
bitmart supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrency and provide great
opportunities to earn cryptocurrency as
well along with that it provides an easy
trade option for buying and selling
cryptocurrencies
now moving on to the cons there was a
large scale hack on this platform in
2021 also the customer reviews are
average for this application
moving on next in our list is cuecoin
Q coin is a third party cryptocurrency
exchange that lets you buy sell and
trade a variety of cryptocurrencies
the Founder's goal was to provide a
simple and secure platform for people
all around the world
to exchange a variety of digital
currency cuecoin has a large number of
cryptocurrencies to choose from and has
minimal cost when compared to other
cryptocurrency exchanges staking
leverage Futures and peer-to-peer
trading are all supported which may
appeal to more experienced users now
let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for cuecoin so cuecoin
offers only up to 28 cryptos for trading
with a very small transaction fee
ranging between 0.00 to 0.10 percent
also coming to its minimal deposit or
purchase the price is nearly five
dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
qcoin maintains the anonymity of the
user while trading yet it offers secure
platform as well also it supports
multiple cryptocurrencies
coming to the cons the trading volume of
cryptocurrencies are pretty low and also
during heavy traffic it can face some
serious issues
following cuecoin in our list we have
cash app
now individuals in the United States and
the United Kingdom can use the cash app
to send spend deposit and invest money
it's an essentially a peer-to-peer
payment app with an investment component
through the cash app
users can also invest in stocks ETFs and
Bitcoin it enables you to purchase sell
and store Bitcoin
from your smartphone itself in a more
simpler and safer manner
now looking at its account prerequisites
like we discussed cash app is only a
Bitcoin exchange application so it
supports only one cryptocurrency that is
Bitcoin the transaction fee varies
depending on the action also the minimum
deposit of purchase is just one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
up provides an easy access UI and quick
withdrawal from its wallets other than
this it also supports Bitcoin lighting
Network it's a second layer Bitcoin
technology that employs micro payment
channels to increase the blockchain's
ability to perform transactions more
quickly
moving on to the cons it only supports
Bitcoin the wallet is always volunteered
and it has limits on everything be it
deposits sales and other items
so now we have reached a last crypto
trading platform in our list which is
bishk
Bish is the peer-to-peer cryptocurrency
trading platform that allows individuals
from all over the world to trade a
variety of digital currencies and tokens
customers are not required to complete a
know your customer or kyc identity
verification process and this trading
platform is not restricted to users in
specific jurisdictions it lets users to
buy and sell Bitcoin at other
cryptocurrencies with a variety of
payment options such as bank wire
transfers ACH transfers and cash
deposits as well
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
Bish currently supports 100 plus
cryptocurrencies for transaction with
transaction price ranging between 0.10
to 0.70 and there is no minimal deposit
or purchase required
now moving on to its pros and cons
this Bish application is available
throughout the world and anyone can use
it it provides a high insecurity and
doesn't require any sort of kyc or ID
verification and it provides almost 50
payment options for crypto transactions
moving on to the cons the speed of the
transactions are pretty low and low
trading values are also possible as it
doesn't consist of any minimal deposit
or purchase
also it is not a great option for active
trading and with that we have come to
the end of this video on blockchain and
cryptocurrency full course for 2022. I
hope you found it useful and
entertaining please ask away any
questions you have concerning the topics
covered in this video in the comments
down below our experts will assist you
in addressing your problems thank you
for watching stay safe and keep learning